SENATE NOT TO RESEARCH IN WATER
WE'RE GONNA CONVENE AS A SUB
COMMITTEE IN THE INTEREST OF
TIME.
AND THEN WE'LL -- WE'LL HEAR
BILLS AS A SUB.
AND THEN WAIT TILL WE ESTABLISH
A QUORUM TO TAKE OUR VOTES BUT
WE DO HAVE ASSEMBLY MEMBER WOULD
WITH US.
WELCOME MEMBERS.
DO YOU CARE TO PRESENT.
GOOD MORNING.
SO WE'RE GONNA GO A LITTLE OUT
OF ORDER THIS MORNING AND WILL
START. FOR THOSE PAYING
ATTENTION IT'S WELL ACTUALLY
SORRY FILE ITEM ONE A. B. THIRTY
WE'RE NOT AT WORK SO.
MIKE IS YOUR SERVICE.
THANKS THANK YOU VERY MUCH
SENATOR AND ME AND MISTER CHAIR
AND MEMBERS -- IN OCTOBER TWO
THOUSAND SEVENTEEN THE TUBS FIRE
STARTED IN CALISTOGA.
A LITTLE UNDER FOUR HOURS AS
WELL -- TWELVE MILES THROUGH
CINEMA COUNTY IN INTO THE CITY
OF SANTA ROSA.
DURING THAT TIME OF FIVE
THOUSAND SIX HUNDRED AND FORTY
THREE STRUCTURES WERE DESTROYED.
AND THAT AND TOOK THE LIVES OF
TWENTY TWO PEOPLE NEARLY ALL OF
THEM WERE FROM COMMUNITIES I
REPRESENT.
AT THAT TIME WE KIND OF FELT
LIKE THIS WAS A WE WERE
EXPERIENCED A ONCE IN A LIFETIME
TRAGEDY BUT SINCE THEN WE'VE HAD
THE THOMAS FIRE THE WILL THE
FIRE THE CAR FIRE THE WHICH FIRE
CAMPFIRE -- AND AND WE WE DON'T
KNOW WHAT'S THE WHAT'S GOING TO
HAPPEN THIS YEAR AND SO SADLY
WE'VE BEEN PROVEN WRONG.
WE NOW UNDERSTAND THAT THESE
CATASTROPHIC WILDFIRES ARE PART
OF THE NEW ABNORMAL.
AND WE'RE STARTING TO COME TO
TERMS WITH THE SCALE OF THE
PROBLEM WE HAVE ON OUR HANDS.
LAST YEAR IN SB NINE A ONE WE
COMMITTED SIGNIFICANT RESOURCES
TO HELP IMPROVE THE HEALTH OF
OUR FORESTS AND WILD LANDS WHICH
IS CRITICAL TO THE BIGGER --
CLIMTE CHANGE PICTURE I'M
FORTUNE WE HAVE OVER TWO MILLION
HOMES ALREADY BUILT IN HIGH OR
OR VERY HIGH FIRE HAZARD
SEVERITIES OWNS AND HE'S
COMMUNITIES ARE IN IMMINENT
DANGER.
CURRENT BUILDING CODES REQUIRE
NEW CONSTRUCTION TO UTILIZE
MATERIALS LANDSCAPING AND
DESIGNS THAT HELP PREVENT
WINDBLOWN EMBERS FROM IGNITING
THE BUILDINGS AND SPREADING
THROUGH NEIGHBORHOODS HOWEVER
THE VAST MAJORITY OF HOMES WERE
BUILT LAW.
THE THE LONG BEFORE THESE BILL
BILLING CODES WENT INTO PLACE.
AB THIRTY EIGHT IS OUR ATTEMPT
TO BEGIN ADDRESSING THE HUGE
CHALLENGING REPAIRING THIS OLDER
BUILT ENVIRONMENT FOR THE FIRES --
OF THE NEW CLIMATE CHANGE ERA.
IN THIS BILL WE'RE PROPOSING A
TWO PRONGED APPROACH FIRST FOR
PROPOSING A REBATE OR NO LOW NO
OR NO LOW INTEREST LOAN INTEREST
REVOLVING LOAN FOG FIND.
THE PROVIDE MUCH NEEDED
RESOURCES FOR HOMEOWNERS TO
RETROFIT HOMES IN HIGH FIRE
SEVERITY A HIGHER HAZARD
SEVERITIES OWNS.
THE FUND WOULD BE OPERATED BY
THE CALIFORNIA STATE COMMUNITIES
DEVELOPMENT AUTHORITY SECOND WE
WE ARE REQUIRING HOMEOWNERS IN
VERY HIGH FIRE HAZARDS INSTANCES
A SEVERITY ZONES.
DISCLOSE WHICH FIRE HARDING
RETROFITS ARE NEEDED TO PROTECT
THE HOME FROM WINDBLOWN EMBERS.
AND AND TO PROVDE PROOF OF SIX
OF A SUCCESSFUL DEFENSIBLE SPACE
INSPECTION WHEN THE HOME IS SO.
THE WORKING CLOSE WITH THE
OPPOSITION TO ENSURE THESE
REQUIREMENTS DO NOT HAVE THE
UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCE OF
PREVENTING HOMERS FROM SELLING
THEIR HOMES.
I'M OPTIMISTIC THAT BEFORE THE
HOUSE THE BILL REACHES THE FLOOR
I WILL FIND A BALANCE TO CREATE
THE FLEXIBILITY FOR WOULD BE
HOME SELLERS.
AND INCREASE THAT THAT INCREASES
THE INSPECTION A RETROFIT RATES
OF HOMES IN DANGER OF
CATASTROPHIC WILDFIRES.
IS THIS NOT A SILVER BULLET --
IS TAKEN AS GENERATIONS TO GET
INTO THE SITUATION IT WILL TAKE
US YEARS TO GET OUT OF IT BUT I
BELIEVE AB THIRTY EIGHT MOVES IN
THE RIGHT DIRECTION.
I'D LIKE TO THANK THE COMMITTEE
FOR THE EARLY ENGAGEMENT AND
WORK ON THIS BILL I ACCEPT THE
RECOMMENDED AMENDMENTS HERE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT IS LOSE
FORSBERG WITH THE NATURE
CONSERVANCY [inaudible] TWENTY
WELCOME THANK YOU CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY NAME
IS LIZ FORCED BURKE AND I'M THE
ASSOCIATE DIRECTOR OF POLICY FOR
THE NATURE CONSERVANCY.
DID YOU CONSERVANCY IS AN ACTIVE
MEMBER OF THE FIRE ADOPTED
COMMUNITIES LEARNING NETWORK A
NATIONAL GROUP WORKING TO BUILD
SUSTAINABLE WILDFIRE RESILIENCE
CAPACITY IN FIRE PRONE
COMMUNITIES.
AND WE ARE HERE TODAY IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF AB.
THIRTY EIGHT CALIFORNIANS
EXPERIENCE THE WORST WILDFIRES
IN HISTORY SETTING NEW RECORDS
FOR THE LARGEST AND MOST
DESRUCTIVE.
AND THE FACE OF MAKE A FIRES WE
HAVE A RESPONSIBILITY TO INVEST
IN AND CREATE FIRE RESILIENT
COMMUNITIES.
BUT WE CAN'T STOP THIS PROBLEM
OVERNIGHT THERE ARE TWO THINGS
WE NEED TO INVEST IMMEDIATELY TO
PROTECT PEOPLE AND NATURE IN THE
FACE OF WILDFIRE.
FORCED RESTORATION AND AGAIN
FIRE RESILIENT COMMUNITIES.
LAST YEAR CALIFORNIA MADE A ONE
BILLION DOLLAR COMMITMENT TO
FOREST HEALTH AND FEELS
REDUCTION OVER THE NEXT FIVE
YEARS.
NEED A COMPATIBLE INVESTMENT
COMMUNITY PROTECTION TO ADOPT
OUR HOMES TO DEAL WITH THE
ESCALATING THREAT OF FIRES.
THE FIRE HARDENED HOMES
REVOLVING LOAN FUND CREATING AB
THIRTY EIGHT WILL HELP US REACH
THIS GOAL BY PROVIDING RESOURCES
TO HOMEOWNERS TO RETROFIT HOMES
FOR FIRE.
IN ADDITION AB THIRTY EIGHT ONCE
OR COMMUNITIES ACROSS THE STATE
WILL HAVE THE CAPACITY TO
IMPROVE FOREST HEALTH FIRE
RESILIENCY AND SAFETY.
THE BILL WILL IDENTIFY WHICH
COUNTIES NEED MORE RESOURCES AND
TECHNICAL EXPERTISE TO IMPROVE
FIRE SAFETY AND A DOCTOR
COMMUNITIES TO DEAL WITH.
THE NEW THREATS OF FIRE WE THINK
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WOULD FOR HIS
LEADERSHIP ON THIS ISSUE AND
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY TO HAVE OTHERS HERE IN
SUPPORT.
THIS IS YOUR NUMBERS SO ELEVEN
SALAS I'VE BEEN ASKED TO
REGISTER FOR SUPPORT ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA LEAGUE OF
CONSERVATION VOTERS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
OTHERS.
GOOD MORNING NOT YOUR MOM ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA FIRE
DISTRICTS ASSOCIATION IN THE
CALIFORNIA FIRE CHIEFS
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
THE BARN WE HAVE THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF RESOURCE
CONSERVATION DISTRICTS IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU SO MUCH.
TINO OTHERS I DO HAVE ANY
OPPOSITION.
MORNING MORNING MR CHAIR MEMBERS
OF MAYBE ANNA BACK ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
REALTORS.
I'M AS WRITTEN -- CA ARE HAS AN
OPPOSING UNLESS AMENDED POSITION
ON THIS BILL HOWEVER WE'VE BEEN
ENGAGING IN COMING IN OR IF YOU
JUST PULL THE MIKE A LITTLE
CLOSER IT'S IT'S LOUD IN THE
HALL.
SERVICE ANYWAY.
AS WRITTEN WAS THE A. R. HAS AN
OPPOSE I'M UNLESS AMENDED
POSITION ON THE BILL BUT WE'VE
BEEN ENGAGING.
IN VERY PRODUCTIVE CONVERSATIONS
WITH THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER AND HIS
STAFF AND WE CERTAINLY.
CS GETTING TO A POINT WHERE WE
CAN ALL AGREE I'M WE CERTAINLY
AGREE ON THE CONCEPT IN THIS
BILL IT'S JUST GETTING TO THE
POINT WHERE -- WE CAN MAKE
TRANSACTIONS VIABLE.
VERY GOOD YEAH THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR THE INPUT -- DO WE HAVE
OTHERS IN OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE I WILL BRING IT BACK
TO THE DíAS.
SENATOR JACKSON'S.
I WANT TO THANK THE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER FOR BRINGING THIS SIDE
LIKE TO SAY GREAT MINDS THINK
ALIKE BUT I DON'T WANT TO BE SO
PRESUMPTUOUS.
THIS IS SO IMPORTANT TO MENTION
THE FIRES UP IN NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA COURSE I PERSONALLY
EXPERIENCED THE THOMAS FIRE --
IN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA DURING
DECEMBER AND IN THE SANTA
BARBARA VENTER AREA WHICH REALLY --
WAS QUITE A I THINK A LIFE
CHANGING EXPERIENCE TO BE IN THE
MIDDLE OF OF A FIRE THAT BURNED
FOR FORTY DAYS -- AND YOU KNOW
IT'S CLEAR THAT WE HAVE GOT TO
START HARDENING OUR HOMES IT'S
CLEAR THAT THERE ARE A NUMBER OF
THINGS AND I APPRECIATE WHAT YOU
SAID IT'S THIS IS BEEN A PROBLEM
YEARS IN THE MAKING.
WE CANNOT DE MINIMIZE.
I'M A CHANGE AS A CRITICAL
COMPONENT OF ALL THIS AND IT'S
FRUSTRATING TO SEE US SAID TO
SEE OUR NATIONAL LEADERSHIP.
ROLLING IT BACKWARDS.
BUT IN THE PROCESS.
WE NEED TO CONTINUE TO GO
FORWARD AND I I KNOW THAT YOU
HAVE ALSO IDENTIFIED.
THE IMPORTANCE OF MITIGATION AND
THE IMPORTANCE OF PREVENTION --
WHILE WE'RE SITTING HERE TALKING
ABOUT HOW WE BAIL OUT UTILITIES
AND WHAT WE DO TO PROTECT THEIR
BOTTOM LINE THE BEST WAY TO
PROTECT THEIR BOTTOM LINE AND
MORE IMPORTANTLY THE BOTTOM LINE
OF HEALTH AND SAFETY FOR OUR
PEOPLE HERE IN CALIFORNIA.
IS EXACTLY WHAT YOU'RE TALKING
ABOUT NOW IS THE MITIGATION AND
PREVENTION.
AND IT IS MY HOPE THAT THE
ASSOCIATION OF REALTORS WILL
COME ON BOARD BECAUSE IF WE
DON'T HAVE HOMES TO SELL.
OR TO BUILD FOR A VARIETY OF
REASONS THEY BURN DOWN YOUR IN A
HIGH RISK ZONE INSURANCE
COMPANIES WON'T INSURE.
MORTGAGE COMPANIES WON'T GIVE
MORTGAGES -- THEN WE ARE IN OVER
A REAL KEEP THE TROUBLE SO.
I APPRECIATE YOUR FOCUSING ON
THE MITIGATION AND PREVENTION
PART OF THIS BATTLE OF THE HOME
HARDENING OF FUND IS A GREAT
IDEA I DID A BILL LAST YEAR THAT --
PROVIDED PACE MONEY AND WE KNOW
THAT THAT PROGRAM ISN'T THE
PANACEA -- BUT I THINK THIS IS A
A WONDERFUL BILL AND IN FACT IF
IF THERE IS ANY OPPORTUNITY TO
AMENDED I WOULD LOVE TO BE ADDED
AS A CO AUTHOR THANK YOU FOR
YOUR GOOD WORK.
WE SHOULD HAVE OPPORTUNITY FOR
THAT.
AMENDMENTS COMING IN TODAY SO
THEIR MONEY.
THANK YOU ICE ALSO ONE THINK THE
AUTHOR FOR BRINGING THIS FORWARD.
I KNOW WHERE THE POLICY
COMMITTEE BUT JUST QUICKLY HOW
DO YOU CONTEMPLATE.
FUNDING THIS [inaudible]
FUND.
WELL WE'RE STILL WORKING ON THAT
QUITE FRANKLY AND WE HAVEN'T WE
HAVEN'T LANDED ON THAT
UNFORTUNATELY.
THE IDEA WE HAD -- HASN'T WORKED
TO PAN OUT WE BELIEVE THERE ARE
OPPORTUNITIES OUT THERE WILL
CONTINUE WORKING ON THAT AND AND
WE WILL BRING IT UP ON WHO WE
WILL BRING IT UP ON THE SENATE
FLOOR UNTIL WE CAN SEE.
IF WE GET OUT OF HERE WELL
BECAUSE ONE CONCERN I HAVE IS IF
YOU HAVE.
A HOME SELLER.
WHO IS TRYING TO DOWNSIZE OR
SELL A HOME?
IN THEY DON'T MEET ALL OF THE
REQUIREMENTS HERE.
DON'T HAVE THE CAPACITY.
OTHER THAN TAKING A LOAN OUT ON
THEIR HOME OR SOMEHOW INCOME
RINGER DELAYING THE SALE.
WE WANT TO ACHIEVE THE PUBLIC
SAFETY OBJECTIVE THAT SAME HERE --
BUT I'M ALSO JUST SAYING Là THE
SUPPORT OF TODAY BUT I WANT TO
FOLLOW HOW.
SOME EXAMPLES OF HOW A FAMILY
THAT IS REQUIRED TO UPGRADE.
IT DOESN'T HAVE THE MEANS.
IN THEIR OWN BUDGET TO DO IT.
THIS CONTEMPLATES THERE IS A
FUND.
AVAILABLE IS THAT FOR A LOAN SIR
IS THAT OUTRIGHT GRANTS WE WOULD
ENVISION IT AS LOW INTEREST
LOANS OR OUTRIGHT GRANTS
REGIONALLY -- WE WANTED TO
REQUIRE THE RETROFITS NOW WHAT
WE'RE ASKING IS IN THE EVENT
THAT A HOUSE IS ON THE MARKET SO.
THAT.
THAT THE SELLER DISCLOSE WHAT
RETROFITS HAVE BEEN DONE SO THAT
THE BUYER KNOWS EXACTLY WHAT
THEY'RE BUYING.
AND AND THAT THEY'VE HAD ALSO A
AND X. A AND A A AN INSPECTION.
AROUND THE PROPERTY AS WELL SO
THAT THE ONCE AGAIN THE BUYER
KNOWS WHAT THEY ARE BUYING A
REQUIRES DISCLOSURE BUT IT
WOULDN'T PREVENT SCO SO LONG AS
THE DISCLOSURES BEEN MADE.
CORRECT -- BUT WE AND PART OF
THAT BUT IS ALSO THE DISCLOSURE
IF THE DISCLOSURES BEEN DONE AS
IT DOES NOT PROVIDE PREVENT THE
SALE WE JUST WANT PEOPLE TO KNOW
RIGHT AND THEN YOU MIGHT
NEGOTIATE BETWEEN SELLER AND
BUYER.
IT BUT THERE'S NO MANDATE TAX
RIGHT TO THE UPGRADE FOR THOSE
PEOPLE WHO WHO RECOGNIZE THE
NEED TO DO THE UPGRADES WE WANT
TO BE ABLE TO HELP THEM OUT
THAT'S THE PURPOSE OF THIS.
AND THE BILL HAS CHANGED YOU
KNOW ORIGINALLY I WANTED I
REALLY DID.
THINK THAT MAYBE THE BEST WAY TO
DO THIS WAS TO MANDATE THIS AND
AND AND WE FOUND OUT WAS PART
THERE'S NO THE RESOURCES ARE
CHALLENGE AND SO ON BUT FOR ME
ANOTHER COMPONENT IT GOES BACK
TO WHAT CENTER JACKSON WAS
TALKING ABOUT IS PREVENTION.
THESE THESE RETROFITS ARE
CRITICAL TO PREVENTION BUT ONE
OF THE MOST CRITICAL THING
SECOND TO THAT GOES ALONG WITH
THAT IS A DEFENSIBLE SPACE PART
OF THAT.
WE'VE GOT TO FIND A WAY TO MAKE
SURE THAT THAT THE THAT THAT.
WE PROTECT IT AS MUCH ASWE CAN
AROUND THE DEFENSIBLE SPACE.
OF COMPONENT OF THIS BILL AND
THAT'S WHAT I'M GOING TO
CONTINUE WORKING ON ROTH
APPRECIATE YOUR WORK ON THIS
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU -- AND I
APPRECIATE.
ALLOWING TO YOU TO ME TO BE THE
PRINCIPAL CO AUTHOR HERE AT AND
THAT ON AND I WAS TREMENDOUSLY
FRUSTRATED IN THE BUDGET PROCESS
TO SEE.
ALL OF OUR RESILIENCE FUNDING
GUIDED -- THE SENATE PUSHED OUT
A HUNDRED MILLION DOLLAR LONG
TERM RESILIENCE FUN THAT I THINK
THIS COULD HAVE CERTAINLY BEEN A
CANDIDATE -- FOR I THINK WE
APPROPRIATED ABOUT A A BILLION
OR SO TO CAL FIRE THAT STILL MAY
BE A VIABLE PATHWAY BUT BETWEEN
SB ONE EIGHTY TWO WHICH IS
SENATOR JACKSON'S FRAME WORK ON
ON LAND USE AND DEFENSIBLE SPACE
AND FRIEDMAN AS A BILL COMING UP
TODAY FIFTEEN SIXTEEN WHICH ALSO.
IS IMPORTANT PIECE THAT PUZZLE
AND DIED AS A FEW MEASURES.
WE'VE GOT TO PUT A PREVENTION
PACKAGE TOGETHER I THINK ON A BI
CAMERA WILL BASIS AND I THINK
THIS IS.
THE ONE OF THE LYNCH PINS OF
THAT FRAMEWORK -- THESE ARE THE
THE BIG EXPENSIVE RETROFITS TO
THAT WERE WERE THINKING ABOUT
HERE WHERE IF TO REMAKE THE
ENTIRE HOME THIS IS A SIMPLE IN
SOME CASES PUTTING SOME GAS
GETTING.
AS I UNDERSTAND IT ON YOUR
GARAGE OR MAKING SURE YOUR
VENCER SEALED -- THERE MAY BE
YOU KNOW THOSE OF US WHO HAVE
BIG DECKS AND THINGS LIKE THAT
OKAY WELL YOU IN THAT CASE YOU
MAY HAVE TO HARDEN YOUR DECK BUT
FOR THE AVERAGE FAMILY.
WOULD TALK I MEAN WHEN WE TALK
TO THE FIRE MARSHAL -- REACH
WINE.
THE ESTIMATE WAS FIVE HUNDRED
BUCKS WOULD EVEN GET YOU SOME
WAYS MAYBE EVEN A THOUSAND
DOLLARS YOU SEE I MEAN IN TERMS
OF PRICE RANGES AND SORT OF THE
EASY LOW HANGING FRUIT.
IS IT IS THIS -- IS THIS GOING
TO HELP YOU GET TO THOSE THOSE
LOW HANGING PIECES MAYBE THERE'S
BIGGER PIECES TO THAT YOU MIGHT
NEED A LOAN FOR VIET MORE MEANS
BUT DO YOU ENVISION THOSE ARE
THE LOW COST EASY WHEN GAS AND
AND AND WE'RE WORKING TO
IDENTIFY EXACTLY WHAT THOSE ARE.
AND AND TO GIVE PEOPLE AN IDEA
WHAT THOSE LOW COST RETROFITS
MIGHT MIGHT COST -- BUT YOU KNOW
I COULD GO BACK TO SOME OF THAT
DEFENSIBLE SPACES IS NOT A
RETROFIT IT'S A IT'S IT'S ACTUAL
ON THE BOOTS ON THE GROUNDS ON
BOOTS ON THE GROUND.
ACTIVITIES TO PROTECT YOUR HOME
AND WE THINK THAT PEOPLE WOULD
WANT TO KNOW THE BEST WAY TO
PROTECT THE HOME AND AND GIVE
THEM AN OPPORTUNITY AND HELP
WITH IF WE CAN DO THAT.
AND YOU KNOW THERE'S ALREADY
WE'VE APPROPRIATE IS A
LEGISLATURE FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS EARLIER THIS YEAR FOR AN
OUTREACH EFFORT AT REGION
EDUCATION I BELIEVE IS.
THE OSTENSIBLE PURPOSE OF THOSE
FUNDS I'M ALSO WONDERING IN THAT
EFFORT.
WORKING WITH FIRE SAFE COUNCILS
ARE CD'S THOSE KIND OF FOLKS WHO
ARE THOSE BOOTS ON THE GROUND
MAYBE WE CAN START GETTING THE
WORD OUT COMMUNITIES AT LEAST
KNOCKING ON THE DOOR AND SAYING
HEY.
YOU KNOW.
YOU'VE GOT AN ISSUE HERE AND YET
TRYING TO JUST MITIGATE THAT
RISK THE LAST THING I WOULD JUST
NOTE FOR FUTURE PURPOSES.
MY HOPE IS THAT.
THE RISK WERE MITIGATING WITH
YOUR BILL WHEN IT BECOMES LAW
BECAUSE THIS NEEDS TO BECOME LAW.
OUGHT TO BE RECOGNIZED BY THE
INSURANCE INDUSTRY SO THAT ALL
THOSE WHO ARE HAVING THEIR
POLICIES CANCELED OR NON
RENEWALS WE'RE REALLY HOPING
THAT THEY SORT OF TAKE INTO
ACCOUNT THAT RISK SO THEN. FOR
THOSE HOMEOWNER TRANSACTIONS WE
CAN ACTUALLY SAY OKAY YOU'VE
DONE YOU'VE DONE THE WORK RIGHT
YOU'VE DONE THE THE HEAVY
LIFTING AND YOU OUGHT TO BE
REWARDED FOR THAT AND THOSE WHO
DON'T THEY OUGHT TO PAY THE
PRICE OF THAT THAT RISK ON THEIR
SYSTEM SO -- ANY OF THANK YOU
FOR BRINGING THIS FORWARD AND
HOPEFULLY WE CAN PARTNER HERE
ALL TOGETHER AND TRY TO GET
PREVENTION AS PART OF THIS
BROADER PACKAGE I'LL ALLOW YOU
TO CLOSER IF ANY MEMBERS HAVE
FURTHER COMMENTS.
TURN JONES ONE ITEM NUMBER ONE
A. B. THIRTY EIGHT ON HOME
HARDENING YES SIR.
WE DO HAVE A QUORUM FOR JUST
TAKE A PAUSE REAL QUICK.
WE WILL CALL THE ROLL.
STERN HERE STERN HERE JONES
JONES HERE ALLEN PORCHES CARILLO --
HERTZBERG HUESO JACKSON.
JACKSON HERE MONEY.
MONNING HERE.
THANK YOU -- ANY OTHER COMMENTS
QUESTIONS YOU GOOD OKAY ALLIED
CLOSER JUST JUST BRIEFLY I THINK
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND AND
THANK YOU TO SENATOR JACKSON'S
WELL LOOK FOR TO WORKING WITH
WITH ALL OF YOU ON THIS ON THIS
EFFORT.
I THINK FOR ME -- THIS IS THIS
IS.
A KEY LYNCH PIN TO THE WHOLE TO
THE WHOLE BIG PICTURE -- YOU'RE
NOT GONNA BE OF THE CELL HOMES
THAT THAT -- IN AREAS WHERE YOU
CAN GET FIRE INSURANCE.
IT'S NOT GONNA HAPPEN PEOPLE I
CAN BE ABLE TO BUILD NEW HOMES
WERE YOU CAN'T GET FIRE
INSURANCE AND SO.
SO THE IDEA IS WE'RE TRYING TO
TO PROVIDE TO TO CREATE AN
ENVIRONMENT WHERE PEOPLE CAN
PROTECT THEIR HOMES AND THEN BEABLE TO BUY INTERESTS WE HAVE
ENTIRE ZIP CODES IN CALIFORNIA.
THE HAVE BEEN CANCELED FIRE
INSURANCE RIGHT NOW AND THAT'S
SIMPLY NOT AND THOSE ARE PEOPLE
THEIR PEOPLE IN THE ZIP CODES
WANT TO SELL THEIR HOMES.
AND ARE NOT GOING TO BE ABLE TO
DO THAT SOMEONE'S GONNA HAVE TO
GO TO THE FAIR PLAN THEY'RE
GONNA TO PAY TWICE AS MUCH FOR
INSURANCE.
IT IS GOING TO BE THE IT'S NOT
COULD BE OF THE SAME QUALITY.
SO I'M I'M HAPPY TO WORK WITH
WITH THE THE OPPOSITION AS WE
MOVE FORWARD BUT WE HAVE TO
THINK THE BIG PICTURE IT'S IT'S
PREVENTION BUT IT'S IS BROADER
THAN THAT AND WE HAVE TO FIND
THE RESOURCES TO DO THIS.
RESPECTFULLY AFTER I LOVE SO
MUCH I'D ENTERTAIN A MOTION AT
THE APPROPRIATE TIME.
MOTION SENATOR JACKSON -- THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
GOVERNMENTAL ORGANIZATION --
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL SENATE
STERN HI STERN I'D JONES.
JONES NO ALAN FORGES CABALLERO
CABALLERO AYE HERTZBERG HUESO
JACKSON.
JACKSON I'D MONEY.
MONEY.
NINE HAS A FOR IT OKAY ONE WILL
BE THE MEASURE A CALL FOR VOTES
THANK YOU SO MUCH SETTLEMENT
THANK YOU.
NEXT FOR THE SAKE OF TIME WILL
BRING UP SOME EVER MAIENSCHEIN --
AND THAT IS ITEM.
NUMBER TWELVE THAT'S AB.
TWELVE SIXTY SO IF YOU'RE READY.
WELCOME THANK YOU MISTER AYE
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS [inaudible]
APOLOGIES.
JUST GIVE A ONE SEC WHETHER IT'S
THE HALL.
GO HOLLER AT HIM.
THE MORNING MORNING WELCOME
THANK THANK YOU AGAIN MISTER
CHAIR AND MEMBERS.
THOUSANDS OF EXOTIC ANIMALS ARE
KILLED FOR THEIR SKINS EACH YEAR
THESE ANIMALS SUFFER GREATLY FOR
THE SAKE OF FASHION AND VANITY
EVEN WALL ALTERNATIVES EXIST.
THERE ARE A BROAD ARRAY OF
LUXURIOUS CRUELTY FREE MATERIALS
AVAILABLE FOR USE -- INCLUDING
EMBOSSED IMITATION WHETHER THAT
LOOKS AND FEELS.
JUST LIKE EXOTIC SKIN WITHOUT
ANY OF THE CRUELTY SEVERAL LARGE
RETAILERS HAVE ALREADY LED THE
CHARGE IN BANNING THE SCANS
INCLUDING CHANEL AND TAYLOR HMM
ADIDAS AND VICTORIA'S SECRET.
JUST TO NAME -- TO NAME JUST A
FEW.
AB TWELVE SIXTY WOULD BAN THE
SALE OF AND THE IMPORTATION WITH
THE INTENT TO SELL OF IGUANAS
HIPPOS CAYMANS AND SEVERAL
SPECIES OF LIZARDS.
HERE AT TO TESTIFY -- IN SUPPORT
RG DEMAND -- SO.
AND THAT WHAT'S NEXT LAST NAME.
THAT IT THANK YOU.
I KNOW MISS NECK NECK IS HERE AS
WELL VERY GOOD SIR THANK YOU SIR.
WELCOME IS MAKING HI GOOD
MORNING WE ARE PROUD SPONSOR OF
AB TWELVE SIXTY AND WE THANK
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MAIENSCHEIN FOR
CARRYING THIS.
I ECHO THE STATEMENTS OF THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA HAS THROUGH
HISTORICAL LEGISLATION
DEMONSTRATED ITSELF TO BE A
PROGRESSIVE IN RESPONSIBLE AT
SORTIE AND ADOPTING PROVISIONS
THAT HAVE AT THEIR CORE THE
RATIONAL.
PROTECTION OF WILDLIFE AND AS
SUCH PROVIDES AN EXAMPLE OR FOR
OTHER STATES AS SOCIETY MOVES
INEVITABLY TOWARDS INFORMED AN
ETHICAL DECISION MAKING BY
GOVERNMENT.
AB TWELVE SIXTY CONSTITUTES A
SELECTIVE EVIDENCE BASED
INITIATIVE FOUNDED ON EXAMPLES
OF ANIMAL ABUSE AND ECOLOGICAL
HARM AND ALSO REPRESENTS A
DIRECTION IN WHICH THE MAJORITY
OF CALIFORNIANS WANT TO GO.
LAST FALL WE CONDUCTED A POLL
THROUGH CONSERVATIVE POLLSTER
VERY WELL KNOWN IN THE STATE AND
75% OF CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT A
BAN ON THE SALE OF EXOTIC SKINS.
OF THOSE 75% 83% SAY THEY
STRONGLY SUPPORT.
AB TWELVE SIXTY REFLECTS THE
WILL OF CALIFORNIANS PROTECTS
WILDLIFE INFORMED ANIMALS AND
WITH THAT I THINK THE AUTHOR FOR
HIS LEADERSHIP AND ASK FOR YOUR
AYE VOTE THANK YOU.
SO MUCH MISTER SECOND.
YES.
IT WILL SUFFER IMMENSELY IN THE
EXOTIC SKIN TRADE FOR EXAMPLES
HUNTER SNEER WILD LIZARDS HACK
THEM APART WITH MACHETES
INCLUDING BY SEVERING THEIR
HEADS AND THEN SCAN THEM. ONE OF
ONE EXPOSE WHICH YOU CAN WATCH
AND PETER DOT ORG SHOWS A LIZARD
BEING SKINNED ALIVE IN WRITING
IN AGONY.
CLIFFORD WARRICK A PROMINENT
SPECIALIST IN REPTILE BIOLOGY
AND WELFARE WHO ALSO WROTE A
DETAILED LETTER TO THE COMMITTEE.
ON THE SUBJECT HAS WITNESSED
SUCH ATROCITIES AND SAYS THAT
BECAUSE REPTILES HAVE A SLOW
METABOLISM THEY CAN REMAIN ALIVE
FOR UP TO AN HOUR AFTER THE
THEIR DECAPITATED AND SKINNED.
CAYMANS TO ARE HUNTED AND KILLED
IN THEIR HOMES IN NATURE OFTEN
BY BEING CRUDELY SHOT IN THE
HEAD SO THAT THEIR SKINS CAN BE
TURNED INTO BAGS BOOTS ANOTHER
EXCESS CERISE.
CAYMANS ARE ALSO KEPT IN FITTED
WATER.
ON EXTREMELY CROWDED FARMS WHICH
ARE OFTEN STOCKED BY CAPTURING
ADULTS IN THE WILD AND FORCING
THEM TO BREED.
ALTHOUGH WE CAN LIVE TO BE
ALTHOUGH THEY CAN LIVE TO BE
SIXTY FIVE YEARS OLD THOSE IN
CAPTIVITY RARELY DO IN FACT THEY
ARE KILLED BEFORE THEY EVEN
REACH MATURITY.
AND HIPPOS ARE OFTEN HUNTED AT
NIGHT WHEN THEY EMERGE FROM THE
WATER TO GRAZE HUNTERS THAN
SNARE SPEAR AND KILL THEM FOR
THEIR TEETH AND SKIN.
PASSING AB TWELVE SIXTY WOULD
SEND A STRONG MESSAGE THAT
KILLING EXOTIC ANIMALS FOR THE
SKINS HAS NO PLACE IN A
COMPASSIONATE SOCIETY.
OPPOSITION TO USING.
EXOTIC SKINS IS GROWING AROUND
THE WORLD AS A RESULT CHANEL
STELLA MCCARTNEY AND OTHERS MADE
MAJOR DESIGNERS AND RETAILERS
HAVE ALREADY BANNED THEM FROM
THEIR COLLECTIONS.
CALIFORNIA HAS ALWAYS BEEN
FORWARD THINKING STATE AND YOU
NOW HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO SAY
COMPASSIONATE EXAMPLE BY VOTING
YES ON A. B. TWELVE SIXTY THANK
YOU.
THANKS SO MUCH OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING ASHLEY DO WELL WITH
THE HUMANE SOCIETY OF THE UNITED
STATES AND STRONG SUPPORT OF THE
SPELL.
VERY GOOD THANKS SO MUCH.
OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
PLEASE COME.
FOR AND YOU STATE YOUR NAME
FILIATION IN YOUR POSITION YEAH
MICHAEL GOLDBERG -- I'M AN
ORGANIZER WITH COMPASSIONATE DAY
IN BERKELEY CALIFORNIA AND I
STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL VERY
GOOD THANKS.
DEBORAH COUPON SEND NEVADA
CALIFORNIA SO THE COMPASSION
LEGISLATION STRONGLY SUPPORT
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
OPAL HANNEKE ELK GROVE SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU IN SAN FRANCISCO
CALIFORNIA AND WAS COMPASSIONATE
BAY AND DIRECT ACTION EVERYWHERE
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU SO MUCH.
DEBBIE BUGLE EISEN FROM PLEASANT
HILL CALIFORNIA WITH DIRECT
ACTION EVERYWHERE STRONGLY
SUPPORT.
LESLEY GOLDBERG FROM ELSE WE
DON'T CALIFORNIA AND I'M AN
ORGANIZER WITH COMPASSIONATE BAY
STRONGLY SUPPORT [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
I AM IN A BOND FROM BERKELEY
CALIFORNIA WITH.
DIRECT ACTION EVERYWHERE I'D
STRONGLY SUPPORT THANK YOU.
IN THE MIDDLE SOURCE SACRAMENTO
CALIFORNIA I'M WITH ANIMAL
DEFENDERS INTERNATIONAL AND D.
X. SEE I STRONGLY SUPPORT.
MUCH.
I'M A LONGER FROM BERKELEY
CALIFORNIA I'M FOUNDER OF CALLED
YOU AND EMPATHY FOR ALL AND
ACTIVIST RE DIRECT ACTION
EVERYWHERE AND I STRONGLY
SUPPORT THE BILL THINKING. TO
THE WINDOW FROM THE NORTH BAY
STRONGLY SUPPORT WITH THE ACSI
AND MANY GROUPS COMPASSIONATE
LIVING.
THANKS SO MUCH.
WHEN THE BRAMBLE FROM SACRAMENTO
CALIFORNIA REPRESENTING IN
DEFENSE OF ANIMALS IN DIRECT
ACTION OF THEIR STRONGLY SUPPORT
THANK YOU THANK YOU?
MARCHING ANIMAL HOPING
LEGISLATION STRONGER SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
ALL O SANTA MARIA -- FAIRFIELD
CALIFORNIA STRONGLY SUPPORT
THANK YOU MA'AM.
ALEX UNTIL YOUR FOR FEELS SOLANO
CALIFORNIA.
IT EXTRACTION EVERYWHERE IN
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU.
MY TEAM A KEY FREE I'M WITH
PROTECTION EVERYWHERE AND I
STRONGLY SUPPORT.
I'M EMILY ROMERO WITH.
DIRECT ACTION EVERYWHERE IN
BERRY ANIMAL SAVE SOME FROM
BERKELEY CALIFORNIA AND I
STRONGLY SUPPORT THE SPELL.
NAOMI ROSE FROM BERKELEY
CALIFORNIA WITH DIRECT ACTION
EVERYWHERE IN STRONG SUPPORT.
THIS IS THE FROM SAN JOSE I
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU SIR.
MIKE SEE SANTA CLARA SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
YES EATING FOR PACIFICA I
STRONGLY SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
DILLON WELLS REPRESENTING
STUDENT ORGANIZATIONS AT SAC
STATE UNIVERSITY IN SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL THANKS SO MUCH.
ROBERT PLAY SOME SOCCER COUNTY
STRONG SUPPORT THIS BILL THANK
YOU.
GOOD MORNING MICHELLE L<c.cyan>G</c>
FROM SAN LEANDRO RESIDENT OF
ALAMEDA COUNTY AND I STRONGLY
SUPPORT THIS BILL AND I'M ALSO A
MEMBER OF TXE DIRECT ACTION
EVERYWHERE.
THANKS SO MUCH.
HELLO I'M LIVED FUNDING FROM ONE
A CREEK AND I STRONGLY SUPPORT
THIS BILL THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING A MALVINA MOM JAM
FROM SAN FRANCISCO AND I
STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL THANK
YOU VERY MUCH.
JERRY BROWN.
STRONGLY SUPPORT THANK YOU.
YOU CAN JUST TAKE THAT AND PULL
RIGHT DOWN THERE YOU GO.
JERRY HANSEN GROSS PHONE CALL
FOR ME AND I TOTALLY SUPPORT
THIS BILL VERY GOOD THANK YOU
MA'AM -- THE YELLOW O'DONNELL
THE GRASS VALLEY AND I STRONGLY
SUPPORT THIS BILL.
BETHANY DAVIS ANTELOPE
CALIFORNIA CALIFORNIA CREDENTIAL
TEACHER AND VEGAN ORGANIZER ICE
STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL.
MUCH.
SCOTT DAVIS AND LOW CALIFORNIA
STRONGLY SUPPORT.
HELLO THE FACT IS A DIRECT
ACTION EVERYWHERE STRONGLY
SUPPORT THIS BILL.
JULIE WATER FROM ON THE CREEK
CALIFORNIA -- ORGANIZER WITH
COMPASSIONATE BAY ANDDIRECT
ACTION EVERYWHERE AND I STRONGLY
SUPPORT THIS BILL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
DOCTOR CRYSTAL HEATH FROM
CLAYTON CALIFORNIA I AM A
VETERINARIAN AND I STRONGLY
SUPPORT THIS BILL.
THANK YOU.
BOB BACK ALAVI FROM WALNUT CREEK
CALIFORNIA I'MA PROUD MEMBER OF
DIRECT ACTION EVERYWHERE AND I
SUPPORT THIS BILL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ANTHONY BY TO HEAR FROM SAN
FRANCISCO WITH THE D. X. IN A
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU SIR.
VICTORIA WOODS FROM SAN
FRANCISCO AND I STRONY FOR
SUPPORT THE FOR A BAND.
VERY GOOD THANK YOU.
HI RAVEN DO BUT SOME BERKELEY
AND I STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
MAY YOUR CHANUKAH I LIVE IN
EMERYVILLE I STRONGLY SUPPORT
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
HI THOMAS CHIANG FROM SAN
FRANCISCO -- ORGANIZE FOR
ANONYMOUS FOR THE VOICELESS AND
DIRECT ACTION WHERE EVERYWHERE
IN STRONG SUPPORT.
WHEN SHOWN FROM BERKELEY
CALIFORNIA WITH DIXIE IN SUPPORT
OF AB TWELVE SIXTY THANKS THANK
YOU -- DANIELLE CODES SACRAMENTO
CALIFORNIA AND I'M SORT.
TO THANKS.
I'M DIANA SALTER FROM SACRAMENTO
AND I STRONGLY SUPPORT.
MAN ON FIRST THING CAM THANK YOU.
MY NAME'S RUTH PRINCE SEATTLE
I'M FROM OAKLAND CALIFORNIA AND
I STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL.
THANK YOU.
AMERIKANISCHER BERKELEY
CALIFORNIA WITH DIRECT ACTION
EVERYWHERE IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS SERGIO FRANCO FROM
PRESIDENT OF ALAMEDA COUNTY NICE
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU SIR.
MY NAME IS DONNA BUT THE SECOND
FOR SITE IS A LIVE IN BERKELEY
AND I'M AN ORGANIZER WITH DIRECT
ACTION EVERYONE I SUPPORT THIS
BILL THANK YOU SO MUCH.
HELLO MY NAME IS CALEY PUNCH OF
A RESIDENT OF YUBA COUNTY AND I
STRONGLY SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
I SEEKING FROM BERKELEY
CALIFORNIA I'M AN ORGANIZER
CHECKED ACTION EVERYWHERE AND I
STRONGLY SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK
YOU VERY MUCH.
HI JOHN CAMERON DUBLIN
CALIFORNIA STRONGLY SUPPORT
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
HI I'M TIFFANY WORTHINGTON I AM
FROM SANTA CRUZ CALIFORNIA AND I
STRONGLY SUPPORT AB FORTY FOUR
AND I'M WITH DIRECT ACTION
EVERYWHERE THANK YOU WE'RE ON A.
B. TWELVE SIXTY ACTUALLY.
ABOUT ONE AS WELL.
MY NAME IS DOUG FULLER IN
BERKELEY IN WITH DIRECT ACTION
EVERYWHERE IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
KEY JONES FROM BERKELEY STRONGLY
SUPPORT.
MEGAN STEINBERG REALLY
CALIFORNIA WITH DIRECT ACTION
EVERYWHERE AND I STRONGLY
SUPPORT THIS BILL.
RUNNING A COLOGNE PRAMANA CREEK
AND I STRONGLY SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
FIND OUT OF POLY WALNUT CREEK
WITH DIRECT ACTION EVERYWHERE
STRONGLY SUPPORT.
CALLING CAMERA IN DUBLIN AND I
STRONGLY SUPPORT OKAY THANKS SO
MUCH.
K. FITZ GERALD STANISLAUS COUNTY
STRONGLY SUPPORT.
VERY MUCH.
HELLO JENNIFER KENNEDY WITH HSUS
STRONGLY SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SIDE NEVADA CALIFORNIA
STRONGLY SUPPORT.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
I'M SEEING NO OTHERS IN SUPPORT
[inaudible] ONE MORE.
GOT A SCOOP.
KAREN GAYLE SACRAMENTO PLEASE
SUPPORT THIS BILL VERY GOOD.
OKAY SO SEEING NO OTHERS IN
SUPPORT DO WE HAVE ANY IN
OPPOSITION HERE.
THE MOTION FROM SENATOR
JACKSON'S SEEING NO OTHERS IN
OPPOSITION.
WILL BRING BACK TO THE DIS ANY
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS MEMBERS.
THANK YOU BRING THIS BORDER%
THANK YOU VERY MUCH I MISTER
CHAIR AND MEMBERS IN
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN AYE VOTE.
AT THE ONE THE ONE QUESTION I
DID HAVE FOR YOU IS WE NEED TO
MAKE THIS LAW WORK -- I WANT TO
GET YOUR YOUR JUST YOUR QUICK
TAKE ON ENFORCEMENT -- I NOTICED
THAT THE FRAMEWORK HERE.
THE FINES MAY NOT BE AS BIG
MAYBE AS SOME OF THE OTHER
FISHING GAME CODE VIOLATIONS AND
ALSO UNDER THEIR SERVICE BASED
BUDGETING WE'VE HAD CHALLENGES.
JUST.
I WANNA SEE THIS MOVIE I WAS IT
IS LAW.
ENFORCED JUST A QUICK INSIGHT ON
THAT FOR US RIGHT SO.
AS MENTIONED IN THE ANALYSIS
WHILE THE EXACT FINE IS SOMEWHAT
LOW -- WITH ADD ONS IT CAN GET
QUITE HIGH UP TO ABOUT TWENTY OR
TWENTY FIVE THOUSAND ALSO.
THERE ALREADY IS A LONG LIST OF
ANIMALS WE DON'T EXPECT THE
DEPARTMENT WOULD HAVE TO HIRE
NEW PEOPLE TO ENFORCE THIS LAW
BUT JUST SOMETHING THAT.
CURRENT MEMBERS OF THE OF THE
SERVICE WOULD KEEP AN EYE OUT
FOR AND IDENTIFYING THESE KIND
OF THINGS ARE NOT NEARLY AS HARD
AS ONE WOULD THINK.
SOCIETY'S HAS A LOT OF
DOWNLOADABLE -- INFORMATION THAT
YOU CAN IDENTIFY THE SPECIES
WITH OR THEY CAN SEND YOU
SAMPLES AND THEN IF YOU EVEN
NEED FURTHER -- YOU CAN SEND IT
TO A LAB UP IN OREGON WHICH IS
RUN BY THE US FISH AND WILDLIFE
SERVICE.
THE ONE THE ONE THING I'LL JUST
ASK AM VERY EXCITED BY THIS
LEGISLATION IS JUST. FOR ALL THE
ACTIVISTS AND ADVOCATES AS WELL
AS THE ORGANIZATION SUPPORTING
THE USE SOME MEMBER WE'VE GOT TO
FIND A WAY TO GET.
FISHING GAME SUSTAINABLY FUNDED
FOR THEIR SERVICE BASS BHAJANS
THEN GO OUT AND PROACTIVELY
ENFORCE THIS KIND OF WORK SO
JUST ON A GO FORWARD BASIS LOOK
FRAMEWORK EVEYTHING ON THAT.
AND I'LL TAKE THAT AS YOUR
CLOTHES THERE IS A MOTION -- AND
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS.
PLEASE CULTURAL CENTERS STERN
HYPE STERN I'D JONES ALLEN.
ALLEN AYE FORGES HAVE EURO.
I HERTZBERG HUESO JACKSN
JACKSON AYE MONNING HAS FOR THAT
IS FOR VIRTUALLY THE MEASURE
UNCLE THANK YOU SEVEN EVER AND
EVERYONE WHO CAME TODAY
[inaudible]
FRIEDMAN -- SO.
YOU'RE YEAH YOU'RE ON THE SPOT
HERE.
STEP RIGHT UP SIR SIMILAR BONTA.
WELCOMING AND GOOD MORNING -- SO
MEMBERS THIS IS FILE ITEM ELEVEN
AB. ELEVEN NINETY ONE FOR THOSE
OF YOU KEEPING SCORE.
WE WERE WAITING BUT THIS
[inaudible]
YEAH.
IF YOU WANT TO DO YOU WANT TO
TAKE A MINUTE ARE YOU OKAY READY
OKAY VERY GOOD SIR.
MY WITNESSES ARE ON THE WAY
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR THANK YOU
COLLEAGUES THANK YOU STAFF FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT AB.
ELEVEN NINETY ONE AS MANY OF YOU
KNOW THE CITY OF OAKLAND THE
OAKLAND EIGHTIES THE STATE LANDS
COMMISSION THE SAM JUST GO BACK
CONSERVATION AND DEVELOPMENT
COMMISSION AND HE PORT OF
OAKLAND HAVE ALL BEEN WORKING.
DILIGENTLY TOGETHER ON A PLAN
FOR PRIVATELY FINANCED STATE OF
THE ART BALLPARK THAT ONE SURE
AT THE OAKLAND A STAY IN OAKLAND.
FOR ANOTHER FIFTY YEARS BUILDING
ON THE FIFTY GREAT YEARS THEY'VE
ALREADY SPENT.
IN THE CITY OF OAKLAND AB ELEVEN
NINETY ONE WILL SUPPORT THE
MIXED USE DEVELOPMENT OF HOWARD
TERMINAL IN OAKLAND TO INCLUDE A
BASEBALL BALLPARK FOR THE
OAKLAND ATHLETICS AS WELL AS
MUCH NEEDED HOUSING.
AFTER THREE THOUSAND UNITS
INCLUDING AFFORDABLE HOUSING IT
WILL ALSO INCLUDE RETAIL AND
PUBLIC GREEN SPACE ON THE
WATERFRONT THIS ARCHITECTURAL
GEM WILL BE MORE THAN A BALLPARK
IT WILL ALSO BE.
A GREEN PUBLIC PARK WITH
WATERFRONT VIEWS ON A SITE THAT
WAS PREVIOUSLY INACCESSIBLE TO
THE PUBLIC.
AS MANY OF YOU KNOW ON THIS
COMMITTEE -- THIS PROJECT IS
REQUIRED TO MEET UNPRECEDENTED
ENVIRONMENTAL STANDARDS LEED
GOLD CERTIFICATION FOR THE
ENTIRE PROJECT NET ZERO GHG
EMISSIONS 20% TRANSPORTATION
EFFICIENCY WITHIN ONE YEAR OF
COMPLETION.
ADDITIONAL G. SHE MITIGATION
MEASURES THAT WILL ENSURE 50% OF
THE REDUCTIONS ARE DIRECT AND
LOCAL.
IN ADDITION OAKLAND AND THE
ATHLETICS ORGANIZATION ARE
COMMITTED TO CONTINUE INVESTING
AT THE CURRENT COLISEUM SITE.
IN EAST OAKLAND INCLUDING
INVESTMENT IN AFFORDABLE HOUSING
THERE.
AB ELEVEN NINETYONE IS
NECESSARY BECAUSE HOWARD
TERMINAL THE HOWARD TERMINAL
SITE.
CONSISTS OF A PATCHWORK OF
UNRESOLVED TITLE AND LAND
BOUNDARY DISPUTES AB ELEVEN
NINETY ONE WILL PROVIDE THE
AUTHORIZATION TO THE STATE LANDS
COMMISSION TO DETERMINE THE
TITLE AND BOUNDARY UNCERTAINTIES
AS IT RELATES THAT THE HOWARD
TERMINAL SITE.
AND ALSO TO APPROVE A TRUST
EXCHANGE NOT JUST TO BE CLEAR
HERE THE BILL DOES NOT REMOVE
THE STATE LAND COMMISSION'S
AUTHORITY TO REVIEW AND APPROVE --
EITHER THE PROPOSED EXCHANGE OR
THE TRUST CONSISTENCY A PROPOSED
USES ON TRUST LANDS NOR DOES
THIS BILL SEEK TO REMOVE.
THE C. D. C.'S AUTHORITY THE
PRODUCT REQUIRES A SIGNIFICANT
PERMIT THAT MUST BE APPROVED BY
THE CDC.
AND THIS PROPOSED BILL.
THE STATE LANDS COMMISSION A. B.
C. B. C. WAS STAY FIRMLY IN THE
DRIVER'S SEAT.
ON THIS PROJECT.
AND THAT THAT OAK OAKLAND.
AT THE CITY OF OAKLAND A SUPPORT
COMMISSION A. B. C. B. C. WILL
CONTINUE TO WORK COOPERATIVELY
ON THE SUPPORT BILL SHOULD WE
GET OUT OF COMMITTEE TODAY.
AND AS THE BILL MOVES FORWARD
TOWARDS THE GOVERNOR'S DESK LET
ME CONCLUDE BY SAYING THAT THIS
PROJECT MEANS A GREAT DEAL. TO
OAKLAND IN THE EAST BAY TO MY
DISTRICT THE ASSEMBLY DISTRICT
EIGHTEEN THIS IS NOT JUST ABOUT
BASEBALL THIS PROJECT WILL
GENERATE ENHANCED WATER FRONT
ACCESS APPROXIMATELY. THREE
THOUSAND SIX HUNDRED PERMANENT
JOBS IN NEW HOUSING AND
RECREATION A BEAUTIFUL PUBLIC
SPACE ON THE WATERFRONT.
AND A HOME FOR THE NEXT FIFTY
YEARS FOR OUR BELOVED OAKLEY
DAYS.
AB ELEVEN NINETY ONE IS VITAL TO
KEEPING OAKLAND ATHLETICS ROOTED
IN OAKLAND.
WITHOUT I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR
AYE VOTE WITH ME TO TESTIFY
TODAY IS THE PRESIDENT OF THE
OPENING DAYS DAVE CAVELL THE
MAYOR OF THE CITY OF OAKLAND
LIBBY SCHAAF.
AND THE HEAD OF THE STATE
BUILDING CONSTRUCTION TRADE
CENTER DS.
ARE YOU THANK YOU
ASSEMBLYMEMBERS I WILL DEFER TO
ALL.
PRESENT. TO MAYOR [inaudible]
THE MAYOR.
GOOD MORNING.
GOOD MORNING CHAIR STERN AN
HONORABLE MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS LIBBY SHAFT
I'M THE MAYOR OF THE AMAZING
CITY OF OAKLAND AND I'M HERE TO
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR AYE
VOTE -- THIS BILL WILL CREATE
CLARITY IT'S TIME IN IS VERY
IMPORTANT THIS REALLY IS A WAY
OF ALLOWING US -- TO COORDINATE
MANY MOVING PIECES THAT ARE
NEEDED TO MAKE SURE THAT THIS
PROJECT GETS DONE IN A TIMELY
AND RESPONSIBLE FASHION.
AND SO AGAIN TIMING IS VERY
IMPORTANT.
THIS PROJECT I WON'T REPEAT WHAT --
MY WONDERFUL ASSEMBLY MEMBER
JUST SAD BUT I'LL JUST ADD THAT
THIS PROJECT NOT ONLY KEEPS OUR
BELOVED ETS ROTED IN OAKLAND IT
ALSO HAS EXEMPLARY ENVIRONMENTAL
STANDARDS AND WILL ALSO PROVIDE
SOME DESPERATELY NEEDED
AFFORDABLE HOUSING FOR OUR
RESIDENTS.
I REALLY AM HERE TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS YOU HAVE BUT YOU NEED
TO KNOW THAT THE CITY OF OAKLAND
IS FULLY BEHIND THIS PROJECT AND
HAS BEEN VERY GRATEFUL FOR THE
COLLABORATIVE NATURE.
OF NOT JUST THE ETS BUT ALL OF
OUR REGIONAL PARTNERS BC DC
STATE LANDS ARE THAT WE HAVE
WORKED WITH IN A VERY
COLLABORATIVE FASHION.
I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU MAYOR CHEF.
I YES DAVE CAVALIER PRESIDENT OF
THE OAKLAND EIGHTIES -- A REALLY
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
ON THIS REALLY TRANSFORMATIVE
PROJECTS FOR OAKLAND FOR THE
OAKLAND ETS TO ENSURE THAT WE
CAN BE HERE -- PLAYING IN
OAKLAND FOR MANY GENERATIONS TO
COME THE IMPACT OF A
PROFESSIONAL SPORTS TEAM IS
BEYOND THE ECONOMICS WHICH IN
THIS CASE IS VERY LARGE SEVEN
BILLION DOLLARS SIX THOUSAND
PERMANENT JOBS. TWO THOUSAND
CONSTRUCTION JOBS BUT THE
QUALITY OF LIFE AND BRINGING
PEOPLE TOGETHER AROUND BASEBALL
IN OAKLAND AFTER FIFTY ONE YEARS
AN INCREDIBLE HISTORY FOR WORLD
CHAMPIONSHIPS WE WANT TO
CONTINUE THAT FOR ANOTHER
GENERATION SO.
IT'S A BIG STEP IT'S A PRIVATELY
FINANCED BALL PARK WHICH IS A
GREAT THING FOR THE COMMUNITY
WHERE THE LAST PROFESSIONAL
SPORTS TEAM LEFT IN OAKLAND THE
RAIDERS AND THE WARRIORS ARE
LEAVING.
AND WE WANT TO DO EVERYTHING WE
CAN AS AN ORGANIZATION A
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATION TO
ENSURE THAT WE HAVE MANY
GENERATIONS OF SUCCESS.
SO WE RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE AND APPRECIATE YOUR
TIME AND I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS ON THE BILL.
A GOOD THANK YOU SIR.
YES I'M SURE MEMBERS AS ARE THE
AS ON BEHALF OF THE STATE
BUILDING CONSTRUCTION TRADES
COUNCIL PROUD TO BE HERE IN
SUPPORT OF THIS IMPORTANT
LEGISLATION -- WHAT YOU HEARD
WAS A PARTNERSHIP BETWEEN ALL
PARTIES THE COMMUNITY OF THE
BALL BALL TEAM OF COURSE
ATHLETICS -- OF THE LOCAL
GOVERNMENT COMMITTEE -- AND
EVERYBODY ELSE THAT'S INVOLVED
IN ACTUAL CONSTRUCTION ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT FOR OAKLAND -- WE
HAVE A LOT OF RESIDENTS IN
OAKLAND ARE IN DESPERATE NEED OF%
THIS ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT AND
THE JOBS.
PLUS THE HOUSING THAT'S GOING TO
BE ACCOMPANIED BY THESE -- BY
THIS PROJECT -- IT'S IT'S BEEN
DONE VERY CAREFULLY WITH
COMMUNITY INPUT NOT TRYING -- TO
TAKE AWAY ANY LAWS OR
REGULATIONS OR BUT IT VERY
CAREFULLY STREAMLINED PROCESS
AND WE NEED THIS LEGISLATION TO
ACTUALLY GET FORWARD AND MOVING
TO THE SEALASKA MISCONDUCT OUT
OF PROPERLY FOR THOSE REASONS WE
ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SIR OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
THIS COME FORWARD IN NAME
AFFILIATION AND POSITION ON THE
BILL THANKS FOR MAKING A TRIP TO
HELL FOR CHAIRMAN NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA TEAMSTERS
CONSTRUCTION AND BUILDING
MATERIALS TRADES COUNCIL.
IN STRONG SUPPORT LET'S GO
OAKLAND THANK YOU SIR.
VERY CLOSE FROM PACIFICA YES
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
HI CRAIG MANTECA -- LOCAL
SEVENTY TEAMSTERS STRONG SUPPORT.
JIM FREE VICE PRESIDENT
TEAMSTERS LOCAL SEVENTY AND
CHIEF SHOP STEWARD OF ALAMEDA
COUNTY WASTE MANAGEMENT FOUR
HUNDRED AND THIRTY EMPLOYEES AND
FORTY TWO HUNDRED MEMBERS AS
MIKE SAID IN WORDS TRANSPORT.
MY Q. STEAMS REPRESENTATIVE FOR
LOCAL THREE FIFTEEN OF MARTINEZ
OF STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
MATALIN DEAN COMMUNICATIONS
DIRECTOR FOR TEAMSTERS THREE
FIFTEEN AND RECENT EMERGE
GRADUATE I STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS
BILL.
THANK YOU MA'AM.
HI I'M BILL PURSELL WE SAY VOCAL
SPORTSCENTER NINETY MEMBERS
SUPPORT THIS BILL.
THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME'S MARK LANE PLAY FONG
ACE FAN AND I WORK IN OAKLAND I
SUPPORT THIS BILL.
VERY MUCH.
I MET DAVIS PORT OF OAKLAND JUST
WANT TO EXPRESS OUR SUPPORT FOR
THIS PROCESS OUR BOARD GETTING
ANIMUS SUPPORT ON MAY THIRTEENTH
FOR THIS TO MOVE FORWARD.
AND WHAT YOU HAVE BEFORE YOU IS
A CONSENSUS APPROACH BETWEEN
STATE LANDS COMMISSION BE CDC
THE PORT THE CITY IN THE AS
THANK YOU FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION
THANK YOU.
I AM STEVE BENDER -- TEAMSTERS
LOCAL EIGHTY EIGHT FIFTY THREE
I'M A BIG ATHLETIC SUPPORTER AND
A SUPPORTER OF THIS BILL THANK
YOU.
HI ERICA BUSH I AM A LIFELONG
EASE FAN AND I WORK IN OAKLAND
AS WELL AND I STRONGLY SUPPORT
THIS BILL THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS TYLER IS IN A
RESIDENT OF EAST OAKLAND AND I
STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL.
THE MORNING MY NAME IS TYLER
ANGLE I'M A RESIDENT OF OAKLAND
AND JACQUELINE AND SQUARE I
STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL THANK
YOU VERY MUCH.
HONORABLE MEMBER STERN MEMBERS
MY NAME IS MIKE BARN BOMB OF
SACRAMENTO.
I HAVING WORKED ON A SIMILAR
PROJECT TO BRING -- THE FOLKS OF
SACRAMENTO PROJECT BIGGER THAN
BASKETBALL BY I STRONGLY FAVOR
PROJECT BIGGER THAN BASEBALL AND
I'M WORKING WITH THE A IS ON THE
TRANSPORTATION PLAN TO BRING
CAPITOL CORRIDOR IN SAN JOAQUIN.
WRITERS TWO GAMES AND JACK
LONDON SQUARE NOW AND IN THE
FUTURE SO I STRONGLY SUPPORT
ASSEMBLY BILL ELEVEN NINETY ONE
THANKS SIR [inaudible]
ROOM SERVICE.
NUMBER ONE IN.
THE TRAIN STATION YOUR HONOR IS
YOUR OF YOUR OBVIOUS YOU TRAIN
GUY -- SO I APPRECIATE THAT
ABOUT YOU -- I'M SUPPORT
ASSEMBLY A BILL US SENATE BILL
SEVEN FORTY TWO THAT'S A GOOD
ONE THAT'S A VERY GOOD.
ONE IT'S GOT A GREAT AUTHOR
ESPECIALLY SO -- THANK YOU FOR
OFFER AUTHORING THAT VERY HUMBLE
AND SO -- SO JACQUELINE SQUARE
STATION IS IS ON THE EAST SIDE
OF JACQUELINE SQUARE IS THAT
RIGHT AND AND THE CITIES ON THE
WEST SIDE -- YOU ACTUALLY IN
THAT PART OF OAKLAND IT WOULD BE
KIND OF A NORTH SOUTH
CONFIGURATION FOR THE STATION IS
JUST TO THE SOUTH OF HOWARD
TERMINALS SIXTY SEVEN AND SIXTY
EIGHT WHEN YOU'RE WRITING EITHER
TRAIN ROUTE.
YOU COME IN AND JACQUELINE
SQUARE YOU COME RIGHT PAST THE
THE HOWARD TERMINAL YOU COULD
SEE THE SITE FOR THE BALLPARK.
AS YOU'RE COMING IN LAS WE
TALKING ABOUT -- WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT A ONE QUARTER TO ONE HALF
A MILE AT THE MOST OKAY AND IS
THE IDEA THAT THE THIS WILL ALSO
HELP WITH ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT
IN AROUND JACQUELINE SQUARE A
LOT A LOT OF RESTAURANTS AND
SHOPS WILL BE UTILIZED PEOPLE
WILL.
TAKE THE TRAIN AND AND THEN BILL
TO WALK TO THE STADIUM MOST
DEFINITELY AND THERE'S ALSO A
HOUSING COMPONENT TO FOR ALL
LEVELS OF HOUSING FROM MARKET
RATE ALL THE WAY TO AFFORDABLE
HOUSING.
THAT'S GOING TO BE ENCOMPASSED
IN THIS PROJECT THAT MAKES THIS
PROJECT A BIG HUGE ELEMENT
MAKING IT BIGGER THAN BASEBALL
OKAY AND HOW DO WE MAKE IT MORE
BART ACCESSIBLE -- TO SO THERE
IS A TRANSPORTATION PLAN FOR THE
HOWARD TERMINAL BALLPARK.
THERE IS -- AN ECONOMIC BENEFIT
ANALYSIS THAT CAME OUT.
RIGHT AROUND THE FAN FEST IN
JANUARY THAT SAYS THE GONDOLA.
FOR THE CITY OF OAKLAND IS GOING
TO BE A HUGE ECONOMIC BENEFIT
FOR THE CITY AND ALAMEDA COUNTY
THAT WILL TAKE PART WRITERS
RIGHT FROM TWELFTH ST OR
NINETEENTH STREET STATION.
RIGHT DOWN TO TO THE BALL PARK
YOU CAN GET RIGHT TO THE BALL
PARK IF YOU ARE WITH IN THE CITY
OF OAKLAND.
MY FOCUS FOR THE TEAM THOUGH IS
HOW DO WE GET PEOPLE ON
INCREASED LEVEL OF SERVICE ALL
THE WAY FROM BAKERSFIELD OR
FRESNO OR ALL THE WAY FROM SAN
JOSE OR OR AUBURN.
AND I'M WORKING WITH THE SAN
JOAQUIN JOINT POWERS AUTHORITY
DOWN LET THAT AND HIS TEAM AND
THE CAPITOL CORRIDOR JOINT
POWERS AUTHORITY ROB PADGETT WHO
JUST.
BECAME THE MANAGING DIRECTOR AS
OF JULY FIRST AND HIS TEAM TO
HELP INCREASE SERVICE BY NEW
YEAR'S EVE.
TWENTY TWENTY TWO OKAY THANK YOU
THE CHAIRS THANK YOU YOUR I
COULD EVEN MAKE YOU WITH A
THOROUGH THOROUGH -- EXPLANATION
WE'LL GET INTO SOME OF THIS
STUFF FURTHER AS WE TALK THROUGH
MAINTENANCE AND FURTHER PLANTS
HERE SO THANK YU FOR THE
TESTING THANK YOU REALLY DO
APPRECIATE IT [inaudible]
LET'S PROCEED. FOUR TWO LIFELONG
RESIDENT OF OAKLAND AND I
STRONGLY SUPPORT THE BILL THANK
YOU SIR.
JAMES MARY BECAUSE AND I WORK IN
OAKLAND AND I STRONGLY SUPPORT
THIS BILL.
HI I'M GORDON COFFIN BORDER
REYES IN OAKLAND I ASK YOU TO
DREAM BIG FOR OAKLAND TO PUT
OAKLAND FIRST.
I FULLY SUPPORT ONE ONE NINE ONE
C¡ ACE THANK YOU SIR.
MR JR MEMBERS RIBEIRO THE
NATIONAL ELECTRICAL CONTRACTORS
ASSOCIATION WE'RE HERE TODAY IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
YOUR MEMBERS MIKE MADIGAN WE
HAVE THE CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSOCIATION OF ELECTRICAL
WORKERS IN THE CALIFORNIA STATE
HI TREES COUNCIL AND A PROUD --
READ NOT A RESIDENT BUT I WAS
BORN OAKLAND SO STRONG SUPPORTER
OF THE OPENNESS THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS MAP PROUD
FOR THE TEAMSTERS IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU THANK YOU SIR.
MISTER CHAIR ROB STOKER
REPRESENTING THAT BUILDING AND
CONSTRUCTION TRADES COUNCIL OF
ALAMEDA COUNTY NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA SHEET METAL WORKERS
STRONG SUPPORT.
MISTER DECKER.
WHY CHAIR JASON BRIAN TO BE
AFTER THAT -- DOWNTOWN OAKLAND
BUSINESS IMPROVEMENT DISTRICT
WERE IN SUPPORT THANK YOU VERY
GOOD THANK YOU SIR.
IRAN BRAND BAY AREA RESIDENT AND
I SUPPORT THIS BILL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
PAUL SUGAMO CASTER VALLEY
RESIDENT I STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS
BILL THANK YOU.
JACK ROWLEY OAKLAND RESIDENT I
SUPPORT THIS BILL THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
ANY OTHERS IN SUPPORT
[inaudible]
YEAH.
MORNING MID MORNING EVERYONE --
AS A RESIDENT WESELTON LIVES
LESS THAN TWO MILES FROM THE
SITE. FOR FOR THE EIGHTIES WAS
FACILITY AND ALSO AS ONE OF THE
COMMUNITY PARTNERS WEBSITE HOME.
TO BE ENGAGED AROUND THE
COMMUNITY BENEFITS AGREEMENT.
THIS PROJECT IS A OPPORTUNITY TO
BRING MORE REFINED SERVICES TO
WEST OAKLAND THAT THEY HAVE BUT
NEVER HAVE SO THIS IS ABOUT
OPPORTUNITY.
AND THERE ARE STILL SOME THINGS
WILL HAVE TO BE WORKED OUT.
AMONGST EVERYONE BEFORE.
THE COMMUNITY REALLY BUYS INTO
THIS.
THESE ARE THESE TWO BILLS
BECAUSE NOT A LOT OF CLARITY AND
HOW WHAT IS THE EQUITY.
WHAT IS LONG TERM SUSTAINABILITY?
WHAT IS THE INFRASTRUCTURE NEEDS
THAT SUPPORT THIS PROJECT?
HOW WILL HOW WILL THE WILL WILL
THAT BE I'M GOING TO ADVISORY TO
GET RECOMMENDATIONS ABOUT HOW
THIS MAN IN THE TAX WOULD PERMIT
MONEY IT'S A LOT THIS?
LOT.
NEGOTIATION HAS TO BE GONE ON
BEFORE.
I KNOW MY ORGANIZATION WAS
OAKLAND VIRAL INDICATORS -- SIGN
ALL TO ANYTHING UNTIL WE HAVE
ALL THOSE THINGS CLEAR FIVE AND
I'M SEEING.
AND THAT'S ONLY REASON WHY I'M
HERE.
WHAT ABOUT THE CLEAR PETITION I
DON'T HAVE?
BOSTON IN THE GAME IS BECAUSE OF
THE MY BACKYARD A WEST OPEN UP
THE SKIN IN THE GAME IS THAT.
THE PEOPLE OF EAST OAKLAND
SHOULD HAVE THE SAME BENEFITS
AND I'M NOT HEARING A LOT OF
BALANCING OF THE EQUITY ISSUES
AROUND THIS PROJECT BOXING BY
THIS PROCESS.
SO.
DOES TO COMMUNITIES ARE.
BASED ON MY EXPERIENCE OF BEING
IN A RESIDENCE IS NINETEEN
NINETY TWO I ALSO A THIRD
GENERATION OF WEST OAKLAND
RESIDENTS THERE'S A LOT MORE
WORK TO BE DEBT.
THANK YOU THANK YOU MA'AM SO ARE
YOU ARE YOU HERE IN SUPPORT OF
THE OF THE BILL THOUGH.
JUST FOR OFFICIAL PURPOSES I'M
SAY IT AGAIN THIS I'M HERE FOR A
LONG TERM SUSTAINED ABOUT IT.
OKAY VERY GOOD SO WE'LL TREAT
YOU IS A TWEENER AND AND ON THAT.
AND ON THAT NOTE.
IN BETWEN SUPPORT AND
OPPOSITION IT AND YOU KNOW MA'AM
[inaudible]
I'M HERE [inaudible]
UNDERSTOOD.
SO WOULD TO NOTE -- AND THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER YOU ARE TAKING
THE AMENDMENTS CORRECT.
ABSOLUTELY AND I WANT TO THANK
YOU FOR THOSE THERE THE VERY
THOUGHTFUL VERY HELPFUL I THINK
THEY MAKE THE BILL EVEN STRONGER
THAN IT ALREADY WAS.
JUST SINCE WE'RE GOING
COMPLETELY OUT OF ORDER WITH
THIS CURRENT TESTIMONY I'LL JUST
JUMP IN FOR ONE SECOND AND NOTE
THAT.
AND BEFORE THE OPPOSITION
APPROACHES -- THOSE LOCAL
AGREEMENTS HAVE TO PRE SEED ANY
FINAL SIGN OFF FROM THE STATE
UNDER THE AMENDMENTS TO THE
LOCAL APPROVALS UNDER THE
AMENDMENTS ACCEPTED HERE TODAY.
ALL NECESSARY LOCAL APPROVALS
WILL HAVE TO OCCUR PRIOR.
TO A B. C. D. C. OR STATE LANDS
COMMISSION SIGN ALSO -- THE
AUTHOR AND THE SPONSORS ARE AT
EXPRESS THAT WILLING IS NOT TO
AND AROUND THE LOCAL PROCESS TO
TO WORK THROUGH IT SO.
AS AS AS WE AS WE RECEIVE ANY
OPPOSITION OR OTHER IN BETWEEN
TESTIMONY BEAR THAT IN MIND THAT --
THOSE AMENDMENTS HAVE BEEN
ACCEPTED -- AND HOPEFULLY SHOULD
LEAVE SPACE FOR THAT COMMUNITY
CONVERSATION TO OCCUR SO WE DO
APPRECIATE YOUR TESTIMONY MA'AM
AND ARE THERE ANY OTHER.
IN BETWEEN OR COMMENTS BEFORE
MOVED OPPOSITION YES MY
PEMBERTON.
I HAD JUST ONE SHERRY PEMBERTON
WITH THE STATE LANDS COMMISSION
I JUST WANTED TO REITERATE THAT
WE HAVE BEEN WORKING%
COLLABORATIVELY WITH THE CITY
AND THE PORTS.
AND OAKLAND AIZEN AUTHORS OFFICE
AND WE'RE LOOKING FORWARD TO
CONTINUING TO DO THAT.
THANK YOU SO MUCH -- AND THE
COMMUNITY.
SO L. WILL WILL MOVE ON NOW --
ANY IN OPPOSITION.
I'M SAID AS LONG AS THERE'S NO
THERE'S IN SUPPORT.
I THINK WE WE READ THROUGH IT
VERY GOOD.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
AND BE CAREFUL THAT WE'LL.
WE'RE FREE WHEELING HERE
[inaudible]
ALL RIGHT.
WELCOME AND GOOD MORNING.
WHERE MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS MIGHT
CHECK WITH PACIFIC MERCHANT
SHIPPING ASSOCIATION THANK YOU
FOR HAVING US TODAY WILL -- Là --
AND THANK HER FOR BEING HERE --
TO AND WE APPRECIATE MISTER
BONTA TAKING THOSE AMENDMENTS
THAT THEY'RE STEP IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION FOR ABOUT BILL THAT WE
ARE STILL OPPOSED -- TO AND WE
FIND -- TO BE PERPLEXING AND IN
ITS NEED -- IF YOU ARE INTENDING
ON FOLLOWING ALL THE RULES ARE
IN PLACE FOR DEVELOPMENT ON THE
WATERFRONT YOU DON'T NEED A BILL --
AND WE WOULD LIKE THE PROJECT
PROPONENTS TO GO THROUGH ALL OF
THE EXISTING REQUIREMENTS IN LAW
WITH RESPECT.
TO THIS PROJECT -- WE HAVE TO
AGREE EMPHATICALLY WITH WHAT
PRESIDENT -- CAVELL HAD TO SAY
ABOUT THIS PROJECT IS
TRANSFORMATIVE.
THEY'RE PROPOSING TO TRANSFORM.
A MARINE TERMINAL INTO AT THREE
THOUSAND UNIT HOUSING COMPLEX --
ONE POINT EIGHT MILLION SQUARE
FEET OF OFFICE SPACE AND THE
STADIUM IN A HOTEL.
RIGHT ON OUR DOORSTEP AND NEXT
TO OUR OPERATIONS.
THOSE OPERATIONS ARE PROTECTED
BY STATE LAW -- HAND WE EXPECT
THOSE -- PROTECTIONS TO BE FULLY
ENFORCED -- BUT I YOU KNOW I
THINK MOVING FORWARD -- AS I
SAID I IF IF THE IF THE GOAL IS.
TO MOVE FORWARD IN A WAY WHICH
IS CONSISTENT WITH THE STATE'S
OBLIGATIONS -- YOU DON'T NEED A
BILL.
AND AND THAT'S THAT IS I THINK
PRINCIPALLY DRIVING A LOT OF OUR
CONCERNS WITH WITH THIS PROCESS --
WE'RE MORE THAN HAPPY TO
PARTICIPATE ON ENABLE EVEN
PLAYING FIELD -- WITH FOLKS WHO
WOULD LIKE TO COME INTO THE
PROCESS -- AND HAVE A DISCUSSION
ABOUT HOW YOU DEVELOP
CALIFORNIA'S WATERFRONT -- WE
BELIEVE THAT OUR FUTURE IS GOING
TO BE.
REALLY DETERMINED BY.
HOW YOU PRESERVE ACCESS TO THE
WORKING WATERFRONT?
WE DO NOT CREATE NEW PORT
PROPERTY WE DO NOT CREATE NEW
DEEP WATER CHANNELS -- AND THE
EXCHANGE AWAY.
FROM THOSE TYPES OF PROPERTIES
CAN OCCUR IT CAN OCCUR UNDER
EXISTING STATE LAW AND YOU
CERTAINLY DON'T NEED A BILL TO
SETTLE TITLES BEATS THAT'S
ALREADY ACCOUNTED FOR IN THE
CURRENT PUBLIC RESOURCES CODE --
SO A PROCEDURE TIME IN AND IN
LETTING US HAVE OUR TESTIMONY
HERE TODAY THANK YOU FORCE.
THANK YOU SIR.
GERMAN STERN MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE.
HI MY NAME IS LEE SANDEL.
I AM THE LEGISLATIVE ADVOCATE
FOR THE NORTHERN CALIFORNIA
DISTRICT COUNCIL.
OF THE INTERNATIONAL LONGSHORE
WAREHOUSE UNION.
THE COUNCIL REPRESENTS LONG
SHORE WAREHOUSE WORKERS MARINE
CLERKS FOREMAN AND NAY IN LIMBO
MENTION OF THE PACIFIC.
AND THEIR MEMBERS FROM EUREKA TO
FRESNO.
WE ARE OPPOSED TO AB.
ELEVEN NINETY ONE THIS BILL IS
INTENDED TO ELIMINATE CURRENT
PUBLIC TRUST PROTECTIONS AT THE
PORT OF OAKLAND SOUR TERMINAL.
EXISTING LAW GOVERNING TIDELANDS
IS HELD IN THE PUBLIC TRUST IN
GOVERNMENT THE STATE LANDS
COMMISSION.
THE PUBLIC TRUST PROTECTIONS.
FOR TAX -- PROTECTS WATER WAYS
FOR NATURAL HABITAT AND MARITIME
ACTIVITIES.
A. B. ELEVEN NINETY ONE IS PART
OF AN EFFORT TO REMOVE THESE
PROTECTIONS IN ORDER TO ALLOW
THE OPENING DAYS.
BASEBALL ORGANIZATION TO
TRANSFORM THE INDUSTRIAL
PROPERTY.
IN THE ART OF THE PORT.
AND TO LUXURY HOUSING AND HIGH
RISE OFFICE COMPLEXES.
NEXT TO THE PROPOSED STADIUM AND
HOTEL.
OUR MARITIME WORKFORCE
REPRESENTS SOME OF THE HIGHEST
SKILLED AND HIGHLY SPECIALIZED
BLUE COLLAR LABOR IN NORTH
AMERICA.
WE ARE DEEPLY CONCERNED THAT THE
CITY AND IS POOR COMMISSION SEEM
TO HAVE A NEW VISION OF THE PORT.
THAT DOES NOT INCLUDE US.
THIS IS TROUBLING HIM CONCERNING
AND THE FACT THAT IT REDUCES
PORT AREA MEANS REDUCE WORK
OPPORTUNITY. FOR THE MARITIME
WORKING COMMUNITY IN THE BAY
AREA.
ALSO TRADING ACTIVE MARITIME
WATERFRONT PROPERTY WHICH CAN
NEVER BE REPLACED ONCE IT IS
GONE. FOR LUXURY HOUSING AND
OFFICE SPACE.
IS INCOMPATIBLE WITH OUR
OPERATIONS IN CREATES NEW
ENVIRONMENTAL AND TRANSPORTATION
CHALLENGES. FOR THE CURRENT AND
FUTURE SEAPORT OPERATIONS AT THE
PORT OF OAKLAND.
WE RESPECTFULLY ASK THE
COMMITTEE. TO PROTECT THE PUBLIC
TRUST BY NOT ALLOWING FOR THE
FOR THE PROJECT.
IT'S AN EXCUSE ME I JUST LOST MY
SPOT CHECK THE PUBLIC TRUST BY
NOT ALLOWING FOR THE CREATION OF
HOUSING OFFICE STADIUM.
COMPLEXES ON OR WORKING
WATERFRONT THANK YOU THANK YOU
SO MUCH.
OTHERS IN OPPOSITION.
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS JOSHUA SHAW
REPRESENTING A COUPLE OF THE
MEMBERS OF THE COALITION OPPOSES
PROJECT. ONE OF OUR COALITION
MEMBERS COULD NOT MAKE IT THIS
MORNING DAVID LEWIS EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF SAVE THE BAY THE
NONPROFIT ORGANIZATION BASED IN
OAKLAND WHOSE SOLE JOB IS TO
PROTECT RESTORE AND PROTECT.
THE SAN FRANCISCO BAY HE ASKED
US TO SAY SAVE THE BAY OPPOSES
THIS BILL IS PREMATURE AND
UNNECESSARY I THINK FOR THE
REASONS THAT.
MY CHECK OF EXPLICATED BUT DOES
DEEPLY APPRECIATE THE
COMMITTEE'S RECOMMENDED
AMENDMENTS THANK YOU.
VERY GOOD THANK YOU.
AARON RIGHT INTERNATIONAL
LONGSHOREMEN'S.
WAREHOUSE UNION.
A BEEN A LONG SHERMAN FOR THIRTY
YEARS AND WE ARE.
ON THE CURRENT BUSINESS AGENT
WE'RE DEEPLY CONCERNED ABOUT
THIS PROJECT.
WE DID NOT SEE A FUTURE FOR THE
PORT OF OAKLAND WITH A STADIUM
IN THE CURRENT LOCATION.
THERE'S A CONFLUENCE OF RAIL
TRUCKING OVERWEIGHT TRUCKING
INDUSTRIAL ZONE.
AND IF YOU PUT A BASEBALL
STADIUM WITH FOUR THOUSAND UNITS
OF HOUSING.
RIGHT SMACK DAB RIGHT THERE.
IT'S GOING TO KILL OUR PORT.
THIS PORTS SERVICES NOT JUST THE
LONGSHOREMEN BUT THOUSANDS OF
TRUCKERS.
IT'S SERVICES AGRIBUSINESS YOUR
RETAIL YOUR MANUFACTURING FOR
CALIFORNIA.
YEAH A. B. NICE SHINEE'S PEARL
IN OAKLAND.
IT SHOULD BE.
IN EAST OAKLAND RIGHT WHERE THEY
ARE NOW. THREE TIMES THE SIZE OF
THIS LOCATION HUNDRED FIFTY
ACRES. TO BE PERFECT FOR A NEW
BALLPARK.
YOU COULD BUILD PLENTY A HOUSING
PLENTY OF LOW INCOME HOUSING.
YOU GET YOU HAVE GOOD
TRANSPORTATION IT'S ALREADY
THERE [inaudible]
WE NEED.
THANK YOU UNDERSTOOD.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH SIR FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY ONE MORE THING THIS
WOMAN.
PLEASE AND AND AND ALL THE
WORKERS THAT CAME HERE TODAY
THAT ARE IN SUPPORT OF THIS
PROJECT.
THAT'S WHAT I WANNA SAY THEY
WILL STILL HAVE A JOB WE DON'T
WANT THEM TO LOSE THEIR JOBS WE
DON'T WANT THE PEOPLE OF EAST
OAKLAND TO LOSE THEIR JOBS.
WE WANT TO KEEP OUR JOBS IF YOU
WANT TO KEEP.
THE ECONOMY OF CALIFORNIA
HEALTHY AND STRONG THANK YOU.
AND AS YOU TESTIFIED JUST BEAR
IN MIND THE AMENDMENTS WILL
STILL REQUIRE.
LOCAL PERMITTING APPROVAL ALL
NECESSARY APPROVAL SO.
THE GOAL OF THE MEASURE NOW.
IS NOT NECESSARILY TO GREEN
LIGHT OR RUBBER STAMP THIS
PROJECT.
THEY WILL THEY WILL STILL BE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO HAVE THESE
CONVERSATIONS THESE DEBATES AS
YOU GO FORWARD -- BUT HOPEFULLY
PROVIDE A LITTLE MORE CERTAINTY
IN THE PROCESS SO WITH ALL MY
NAME IS TIM MAMA LONGSHOREMAN
WORKER AT SAN FRANCISCO WE ALSO
WORK IN OAKLAND THAT'S BASICALLY
OUR MAIN PORT -- LIKE THE YOUNG
MAN JUST SAID THESE TRUCKS THAT
COME IN DALY WE'RE LOOKING AT
THOUSANDS OF TRUCKS COMING IN.
THANK YOU VERY VERY BIG TRAFFIC
SO AS FAR AS THE OTHER WORKERS
THAT WANT THIS AND THEY WITH IT.
THEY'RE GOING TO HAVE JOBS BUT
THE THING IS THIS IS GOING TO
LAST FOR A YEAR YEAR AND A HALF
AND THEN THEY'RE GOING TO GO
SOMEWHERE ELSE.
THE FULL TIME PERMANENT JOBS
THEIR SEASONAL.
THEY'RE NOT FULL TIME DAYS PLAY
CERTAIN AMOUNT OF GAMES AND IT'S
OVER.
THANK YOU SIR I WOULD LIKE IT I
WOULD LIKE IT TO BE BUILT IN
EAST OAKLAND WORDS AT IT DOESN'T
MAKE ANY SENSE TO MOVE IT IT'S
ALL DOWN THERE.
THANK YOU THANK YOU THANK YOU.
AS CHAIR MEMBERS MARIN PM WE
HAVE INTERNATIONAL LONGSHORE AND
WAREHOUSE UNION.
WE TALK ABOUT HOUSING AND LOW
INCOME HOUSING FOR THIS PROJECT
[inaudible]
AND THE NEED FOR HOUSING BECAUSE
OF A HOMELESS WE WE SEE THAT
EVERYWHERE I THINK AT AS THE
POINTS FOR THIS BILL THERE'S
NOTHING IN THE PLAN FOR THAT WE
WE WANT TO SEE THAT IF IT'S A
TRUE EFFORT. TO IMPROVE THE
COMMUNITY DOES DOES DETAILS HAVE
TO BE WORKED OUT AND WE ALSO
HAVE A LOT OF OUR MEMBERS THAT
ARE AYE AYE FAMILIES DEPEND ON
THE JOBS AND I KNOW THAT THE
PROPONENTS OF THE BILLS DON'T
WANNA DISPLAYS THOSE WORKERS I
THINK.
THERE'S GOTTA BE A WAY WHERE WE
ARE BROUGHT TO THE TABLE AND
ACTUALLY WORKED OUT THE DETAILS
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
WE'RE JUST GONNA GO NAME
AFFILIATION IN YOUR POSITION ON
THE BILL GOING FORWARD WE HAVE
TO WE HAVE TO CONTAIN THE NAME
AND PRICE OF LOCAL TEN MILE W.
ON THE MARSHALL TEN YES SIR.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
FOR IT.
WE HEARD.
WE HEARD YOU LOUD AND CLEAR.
THANK YOU SIR.
ANY OTHERS IN OPPOSITION.
OKAY SEEING NONE WILL BRING IT
BACK TO THE DIS MEMBERS HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
A QUESTION FROM CENTER BOARD
JUST.
I JUST WANT TO CONFIRMATION I
THINK -- OUR CHAIRMAN I HAD RE
EMPHASIZE THAT THIS GOES THIS
WILL CONTINUE GO THROUGH A LOCAL
LAND USE PROCESS.
SEQUEL WILL STILL HAVE TO BE
GONE THROUGH SO IF THERE'S
TRAFFIC RELATED ISSUES
ENVIRONMENTAL.
CONCERNS THAT WILL BE THOROUGHLY
REVIEWED.
DURING THAT PROCESS IS THAT
CORRECT AS THE MAYOR OF THE CITY
OF OAKLAND I CAN ASSURE YOU THAT
WE WILL USE OUR LOCAL CONTROL.
TO DO A THOROUGH ENVIRONMENTAL
IMPACT REPORT WE WILL HEAR FROM
ALL THE STAKEHOLDERS OAKLAND IS
CERTAINLY KNOWN FOR BEING A
PLACE WHERE PEOPLE FEEL VERY
COMFORTABLE HAVING THEIR DEMANDS
HEARD.
SO I ASSURE YOU THAT WE WILL
HAVE A VERY ROBUST AND ACTIVE
SESSION DURING THE SEQUEL
PROCESS -- WE EXPECT A DRAFTEE I
ARE TO BE PREPARED SOMETIME THIS
FALL AND I ASSURE YOU THERE WILL
BE MUCH ROBUST DEBATE.
AS THE APPROVAL PROCESS FOR THAT
GOES FORWARD BUT WHEN WE MET
YESTERDAY -- I LEARNED THAT --
THE CITY COUNCIL -- UNANIMOUSLY
VOTED IN SUPPORT OF MOVING THIS
PROJECT ALONG IS THAT CORRECT.
THE CITY COUNCIL TOOK A POSITION
ON THIS PARTICULAR BILL AND THEY
TOOK A POSITION SUPPORT IF
AMENDED THE AMENDMENTS -- THAT
YOU HAVE MADE HERE TODAY ARE IN
THE SPIRIT OF WHAT THE CITY
COUNCIL ASKED FOR SO ABSOLUTELY
AND THAT WAS A UNANIMOUS VOTE.
INDEED YOU FULL OPENING THE
QUESTION THAT I POSED TO
YESTERDAY BY CHANCE DID YOU HAVE
OCCASION TO ON YEAH WE ACTUALLY
SPOKE TO THE POOR AND THEY SAID
THERE WAS NO KNOWLEDGE OF ANY
FEDERAL -- REQUIRED BASED ON THE
CURRENT LOCATION OF HOWARD
TERMINAL AND ITS IMPACT ON THE
LARGER PORT.
MY POSE IN OFF A FINISH WITH
THIS MIGHT UNCERTAIN YESTERDAY
WAS OUTSIDE OUR JURISDICTIONS
MORE ON NATIONAL SECURITY
IMPLICATIONS OF MODIFYING A
VALUED POURED IN TERMS OF
TRANSPORTATION AND IN OUR
ABILITY TO CONDUCT.
INTERNATIONAL COMMERCE BE A C.
WAYS.
I CONSULTED WITH THE MICHAEL
GROSSMAN -- WHO IS A NATIONAL
SECURITY REALM WITHIN -- THE
COMMITTEES AND I GOT
CONFIRMATION THAT -- THERE WERE
NO CONCERNS ON THEIR END AS WELL
SO THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER SENATOR CENTER
BORDER CENTER HUESO MEN SENATOR
MONNING.
I JUST WANTED TO ASK OF ANYBODY
THAT KNOWS -- THE BOUNDARIES OF
THE COASTAL ZONE.
IF THIS PROJECT IS WITHIN THE
COASTAL ZONE GOVERNED BY THE
COSTA COMMISSION.
I KNOW THERE'S THERE'S A A SOME
CARVE OUTS IN THE BAY AREA THAT
ARE NOT COVERED BY.
THE COSTA COMMISSIONS ANYBODY
KNOW THAT ANSWER [inaudible]
THE CDC [inaudible]
I'M I'M [inaudible]
GOV.
THE STOCK ON THE COAST I'M HAPPY
TO JUST THAT VERY QUICKLY MISS
GERMANY LANDS DO YOU WANT TO
WEIGH IN.
THE CHAIR SHERRY PEMBERTON WAS
STATE LANDS COMMISSION I I CAN'T
SPEAK FOR THE COASTAL COMMISSION
BUT I BELIEVE THAT THEY DON'T
HAVE JURISDICTION HERE.
BECAUSE THE SAN FRANCISCO BAY
CONSERVATION AND DEVELOPMENT
COMMISSION HAS JURISDICTION.
IN THIS AREA SO WHO WOULD BE THE
OF THIS.
THE STATE AGENCY OR A LOCAL --
BUT THE PORT AUTHORITY OR
SOMEBODY THAT HAS THE
RESPONSIBILITY TO MAKE THE FINAL
DETERMINATION ON ON COASTAL
ACCESS AND AND GOVERNING.
OF THE WHETHER WHETHER THIS LAND --
IS -- INTENDED FOR COASTAL
PURPOSES COASTAL DEPENDENT USES
AND AND THE LIKE.
I BELIEVE THAT WOULD BE BE CDC.
THERE THERE'S THREE THINGS B. C.
D. C. WHICH IS A REGIONAL
AUTHORITY THAT HAS JURISDICTION
OVER ALL COASTAL DEVELOPMENT ON
THE BAY.
STATE LANDS ALSO HAS -- MANY
RESTRICTIONS ABOUT USE OF LAND
AND THEY WILL STILL RETAIN A
TREMENDOUS AMOUNTOF THAT.
BUT IF I CAN SAY THE CITY OF
OAKLAND TREMENDOUSLY VALUES ARE
MARITIME INDUSTRY IT IS A HUGE
ECONOMIC ENGINE -- I PERSONALLY
AND THE FORMER DIRECTOR OF
PUBLIC AFFAIRS FOR THE PORT OF
OAKLAND AND I CAN ASSURE YOU
THAT THIS CITY IS GOING TO
ENSURE THAT THIS MARITIME
INDUSTRY IS STRONG AND
FLOURISHING.
THIS PROJECT DOES NOT.
THREATEN THE MARITIME INDUSTRY.
IT WE ABSOLUTELY CAN HAVE BOTH A
GREAT MIXED USE BALLPARK AND
VERY STRONG MARITIME INDUSTRY IN
OAKLAND.
WELL IT WOULD BE A LOT MORE
HELPFUL.
IF I HEARD FROM THE LONGSHOREMEN
SAYING THAT WOULD IT WOULD
SUPPORT.
THERE OF INDUSTRY AND THEN WHEN
YOU SAY THAT IT SUPPORTS
SHIPPING OF I WOULD LOVE TO HEAR
FROM THEM.
SAY YES THIS PROJECT WHICH
SUPPORTS SUPPORTS HAVE WRECKED I
RECOGNIZE THAT THEY LOOK ACROSS
THE BAY AND THEY SEE WHAT
HAPPENED IN SAN FRANCISCO.
AND I CAN TELL YOU THAT THIS IS
NOT THE CAMEL'S NOSE UNDER THE
TENT.
HOWARD TERMINAL HAS NOT BEEN
USED AS A MARITIME TERMINAL
SINCE TWENTY FOURTEEN IS ON THE
MOST SHALLOW PART OF THE CHANNEL
WE HAVE UNDER LEAST TERMINALS.
ON OUR DEEP WATER SEAPORT SITE
WE ALSO HAVE ADJUSTED THIS
PROJECT SO THAT WE CAN ACTUALLY
ACCOMMODATE A MUCH LARGER
TURNING BASIN.
SO THAT WE ARE PREPARED TO
WELCOME THE LARGEST SHIPS IN THE
WORLD TWO OAKLAND.
AND WE ANTICIPATE TREMENDOUS
OPPORTUNITY TO EXPAND CARGO WITH
OUT THIS RETURN THAT AGAIN IN
TERMS OF THAT THIS PROJECT IS
GOING TO HELP.
EXPAND [inaudible]
A TERMINAL.
THIS PROJECT IS DESIGNED TO
ACCOMMODATE A WIDER TURNING BASE
IN IN THE CHANNEL ITSELF I WOULD
THAT BE ACCOMPLISHED ANOTHER
WORDS THE PROJECT ALLOWS A
PORTION OF THE LAND TO BE SET
ASIDE SO THAT IF WE ACTUALLY AND
AGAIN WE DON'T EVEN KNOW THAT WE
WILL NEED TO THIS.
IS ALL BEING STUDIED BY THE ARMY
CORPS OF ENGINEERS BUT IF WE
NEED TO ACTUALLY.
DIG INTO ACT I DON'T KNOW WHAT
DAVE ISN'T DOING THIS BUT JUST
SO YOU KNOW JUST SO YOU KNOW I
AM ON TOP OF THIS OKAY I CARE
TREMENDOUSLY ABOUT THIS.
SO WE HAVE STUDIED POTENTIAL
WIDENING OF THE TURNING BASIN
AND THAT MEANS THAT A SHIP KIND
O PULLS IN AND THEN LITERALLY
DOES A PIVOT IT'S A VERY
BEAUTIFUL TO WATCH I WELCOME YOU
TO COME DOWN AND WATCH IT.
SO THERE'S ATTORNEY BASED IN
THERE RIGHT NOW IT'S DUG OUT AND
IT IT HAS TO BE WIDE ENOUGH TO
THE WHOLE SHIP CAN TURN AROUND
WE ACTUALLY HAVE.
PASSED THE ETS TO REDESIGN THE
PROJECT WE'VE EXPANDED THE THE
PORTION UNDER STATE LANDS
CONTROL SO THAT IF NEEDED WE CAN
ACTUALLY.
DIG OUT THAT PART OF THE
SHORELINE TO COMEDY THE ABSOLUTE
LARGEST SHIPS WE WANT THE PORT
OF OAKLAND TO BE SUCCESSFUL WE
WANT OUR LONG SHORT AND BUSY AND
WORKING.
AND WE ACTUALLY HAVE THE PORT OF
OAKLAND HERE MAYBE A MATH BOOK
AND BEFORE WE GET INTO THIS THE
BILLING CHIEF BEFORE THIS
COMMITTEE IS NOT ABOUT THE
MERITS OF THIS PROJECT IS ABOUT
THE PROCESS FOR APPROVAL AND
JUST TO BE CLEAR.
THE AUTHORIZATIONS AND SPILLWAYS
WE HAD A LONG IN DEPTH MEETING
WITH I'LL W. YESTERDAY.
AS WELL AS PAM SO.
AND WE CAN MAYBE GET THEIR
CONFIRMATION AS WELL THEY THEY
CERTAINLY MAY STILL BE OPPOSE
THE PROJECT.
I AM I AM ONLY ASKING ABOUT
PROCESS MR THE PROCESS HERE IS
THEM PRIOR TO SO PRIOR TO ANY B.
C. D. C. SUBMISSION.
OR ANY STATE LANDS COMMISSION
SUBMISSION SO BEFORE THE STATE
AGENCIES CAN ENTERTAIN A PUBLIC
TRUST A TERMINATION OR THOSE
SORT OF COASTAL ACCESS QUESTIONS.
THESE LOCAL DECISIONS HAVE TO
GET MADE FIRST SO ALL LOCAL
APPROVALS HAVE TO OCCUR SO JUST
TO BE CLEAR ABOUT THAT I JUST
WANNA MAKE SURE THAT WITHIN THE
PROCESS THERE IS A CONSIDERATION.
SOMETHING THAT IS VERY IMPORTANT
TO ME AND THAT'S ENSURING PUBLIC
ACCESS TO THE COAST.
AND ALSO PROTECTING COASTAL
DEPENDENT USES AND IF WE'RE
GONNA AND AND AGAIN THE THE BILL
DOES NOT IN ANY WAY COMPROMISED
THE AUTHORITY OF THE STATE LANDS
COMMISSION WHICH IS CHARGED WITH
THE VERY VALUE THAT YOU JUST
ARTICULATED OKAY.
THANK YOU.
WE'RE GONNA COME JUST IN ORDER
HERE SO SENATOR MINING.
THEN THE VICE CHAIR.
AND BACK TO SENATOR HERTZBERG.
THANK YOU GUYS CHAIR WELL I WANT
TO THANK THE AUTHOR FOR BRINGING
THIS FORWARD AND FOR THE WORK
WITH THE COMMITTEE.
IN FOR ACCEPTING AMENDMENTS.
WELCOME TO THE MAYOR THANK YOU
FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP ON THIS AS
WELL.
SO MY UNDERSTANDING IS THAT THE
ENVIRONMENTAL.
IMPACT STUDIES ARE UNDER WAY NOW.
IN THOSE COMPLETION OF THOSE IS
A PRECONDITION.
AS PART OF THIS PROCESS BEFORE
APPROACHING STATE LANDS -- AND I
THINK THIS IS IN THE PUBLIC
DOMAIN BUT CAN YOU REMIND ME THE
FUNDING FOR THE STADIUM THIS.
IS ALL PRIVATELY FINANCE THE
STATE.
BASED ON NO PUBLIC FUNDS IN THE
CONSTRUCTION.
PUBLIC BENEFITS INCLUDING A
COMMUNITY AND IF IT'S AGREEMENT
OBVIOUSLY -- OTHER BENEFITS FOR
THE CITY OF THE COMMUNITY YES.
AND ARE THERE A DEVELOPER'S
IDENTIFIED FOR THE HOUSING
COMPONENT OR IS THAT FURTHER
DOWN THE ROAD THAT STILL BEING
DETERMINED AT THIS TIME BUT
IT'LL INCLUDE A ROBUST
AFFORDABLE HOUSING PLAN TO
ENSURE THAT WE REALLY REALLY
RESPOND TO THE NEEDS OF OUR
COMMUNITY.
IS THAT AFFORDABLE HOUSING
INCLUDE LOW INCOME HOUSING IS
SOMETIMES THOSE TERMS GET.
MURDER GET INCLUDE ALL LEVELS OF
HOUSING YES THANK YOU VERY MUCH
WELCOME.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
THANK YOU CENTER MONNING MISTER
VICE CHAIR.
HE WAS A CHAIR -- MR BONTA.
YOU KNOW I I CAN SEE THIS AS A
LOCAL CONTROL ISSUE SO I'M
TRYING TO GET TO YES ON THIS
THANK YOU -- I THINK THE
AMENDMENTS MAKE IT BETTER.
THAT IS GOOD TO SEE THE
TEAMSTERS HERE -- TODAY BELIEVE
OR NOT MY DAUGHTER'S A TEAMSTER.
AND ONE OF MY SONS -- SO I
APPRECIATE THEIR TESTIMONY.
THERE'S A SOME TRYING TO FOCUS
ON THE STATE ISSUES HERE ARE IN
IN AND ANALYZING THIS BILL.
AND SO I I THINK I'M DOWN TO TWO
QUESTIONS -- AND I'D AND THINK
I'M AS EASY ONE FOR ALL ASSN
BOTH AND THEN YOU ANSWER HOW YOU
AN ANSWER -- IT'S BEEN BROUGHT
UP SEVERAL TIMES THAT THERE'S IN
THE TWENTY FIVE HUNDRED HOUSING
UNITS -- AS PART OF THIS PROJECT
I VAST -- YOU KNOW PROPONENTS ON
BOTH SIDES OF THIS ISSUE ABOUT
THAT SO IF YOU CAN SPEAK TO THAT
AND AND RATE REALLY WHAT MY
CONCERN IS BASED ON MY KNOWLEDGE
ON IT BEING A CITY COUNCIL IN
ZONING. TO FIT TWENTY FIVE
HUNDRED UNITS ON THIS PIECE OF
PROPERTY YOU'RE GONNA.
YOU KNOW I'M JUST GUESSING AT
THIS POINT TIME AND PINS THAT
ARE COMPLETELY BUT THIRTY STORY
BUILDINGS ARE GOING TO GET IT
DONE YOU HAVE TO HAVE SIXTY
SEVENTY STORY BUILDINGS. TO GET
TO TWENTY FIVE HUNDRED UNITS ON
THIS SMALL PIECE OF PROPERTY --
SO WHERE THE TWENTY FIVE HUNDRED
UNITS GOING OUT OR IS THAT EVEN.
IT IS THE PROJECT -- RELIANT ON
THAT -- AND IN THIS I THINK THAT
THE STATE ISSUE THAT I'M MOST
CONCERNED ABOUT IS ON THE LAND
SWAP -- THIS THE TAXPAYERS OF
CALIFORNIA ARE GIVING UP.
A POTENTIALLY VERY VALUABLE
PIECE OF PROPERTY HERE IN THE
BAY.
WHAT ARE THE TAXPAYERS OF
CALIFORNIA?
GETTING IN RETURN OF EQUAL OR
GREATER VALUE THAN WHAT THE TAX
PAYERS ARE GIVING UP.
THOSE TWO THINGS THIS LAND SWAP
IN THAT AND THE NUMBER OF UNITS.
AND THE AND THE NUMBER OF UNITS
IS MORE OF A CURIOSITY THAN
ACTUALLY I MEAN ON THE NUMBER OF
UNITS YOU KNOW WE'VE BEEN
WORKING WTH THE ARCHANGELS
GROUP IN FIELD OPERATIONS OUR
DESIGN TEAM.
AND ACTUALLY WE CAN HAVE AN
ASSORTMENT OF SIZES OF BUILDINGS
TO ACCOMMODATE THAT NUMBER AND
KEEP IN MIND THAT'S JUST A
PROPOSAL THAT WE PUT FORTY THE
INITIAL SEQUEL STUDIES.
SO WE'RE GONNA HAVE TO GO
THROUGH THAT WHOLE PROCESS
DETERMINE WHAT IS VIABLE AT THAT
LOCATION.
SO WHAT WHAT I'M HEARING YOU
ANSWER NOW IS THE PROJECT IS NOT
DEPENDENT UPON THE NUMBER OF
UNITS -- BEING PROPOSED WE WE
STILL HAVE TO STUDY THAT TO
DETERMINE WHAT HOW IT'S GONNA
PLAY OUT YES RIGHT SENATE AND
MISTER MUCH OF YOU CAN ANSWER
TOWARD OR YOU KNOW TOWARD THE
LAND SWAP.
YEAH I MEAN THAT THAT'S THE ROLE
OF OF STATE LANDS COMMISSION TO
MAKE SURE THAT THAT THE YOU KNOW
WHAT TO THE TRUST IS IS IS MADE
HOLE THAT THERE'S NO NET LOSS TO
THE TRUST IN THAT THE LAND OF
SIMILAR VALUE.
NEARBY OR POTENTIALLY ELSEWHERE
THERE'S A LOT OF DIFFERENT WAYS
TO TO DO THE DEAL -- ARE
REPLACED TO THE THE THE STATE
LANDS I TRUST SO -- THAT'S WHY
WE WE HAVE THIS PROCESS THAT'S
WHY THEY'VE BEEN AT THE TABLE --
AND HAS ALWAYS BEEN OUR INTENT
TO MAKE SURE WE HAVE FULL
COMPLIANCE WITH THAT THE STATE
LAND REQUIREMENTS AND THAT.
THE STATE LANDS TRUSSES METAL.
OKAY SO -- A CURRENT YEAR
AMENDMENTS AND THE STATE LAND
TRUSTS HAS A SEAT AT THE TABLE
IN THOSE NEGOTIATIONS THAT'S ONE
OF THE THINGS THAT HAS TO BE
APPROVED.
THEY HAVE TO APPROVE THE LAND
SWAP BEFORE THIS GOES FORWARD
ABSOLUTELY.
THANK YOU.
THE VICE CHAIR OF COMING BACK TO
CENTER HERTZBERG AND THEN.
I JUST WANT TO SHARE FOR THE
RECORD A COUPLE COMMENTS COUPLE
THOUGHTS I HAD THE RESPECT TO
THIS.
TRANSACTION OBVIOUSLY IT CHANGES
TO SOME EXTENT BY VIRTUE OF THE
AMENDMENTS TAKEN IN THE BILL
[inaudible]
FIRST [inaudible]
ARMED.
YOU KNOW ONE OF THE GREAT
CHALLENGES THAT WE ALL FACE WHO
HAVE BEEN INVOLVED IN GOVERNMENT
ISSUE NO MATTER MAYOR IN TERMS
OF LAND USE IN PARTICULAR.
IS SOMEONE THE EXAMPLE THAT I
USE IN A MEETING I HAD YESTERDAY
WHO'S NEXT TO A FREEWAY.
GETS A HOUSE FOR HALF PRICE
BECAUSE OUR NEXT TO THE FREEWAY
AND HE GETS UPSET BECAUSE IT'S
TOO LOUD.
WRITER SOMEBODY MOVES NEXT TO AN
AIRPORT AND THEN OBJECTS TO THE
AIRPLANE NOISE WHEN THEY BOUGHT
A HOUSE.
NEXT TO AN AIRPORT.
AND SO NOW YOU'VE GOT THIS NEW
DEVELOPMENT PART OF A TWO
THOUSAND ACRE.
OUR PORT THAT'S A PRETTY
IMPORTANT TO A PART OF COMMERCE
WITH RESPECT.
TO THE UNITED STATES I WOULD
JUST SAY STE CALIFORNIA NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA THEY REALLY THINK
IT'S PART OF THE WHOLE UNITED
STATES A GRID IF YOU WILL.
SO THE QUESTION IS MY MY
SUGGESTION AS YOU MOVE FORWARD
JUST TO THROW IT OUT THERE.
I MISSED BONTA IS TO MAY BE
REQUIRE -- LIKE WE DO WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF REAL ESTATE THE
STATE DEPARTMENT VILLA STATE
SOME TYPE OF DISCLOSURE DOCUMENT
UP FRONT -- SO THAT EVERYBODY
KNOWS THAT THEY ARE PART OF THIS.
COMPLEX BUT IF THEY'RE GONNA
LIVE THERE OR THEY CAN HAVE A
STORE THERE BECAUSE YOU END OF
GETTING LAWSUITS ALL THE TIME WE
DID KNOW THIS WE DIDN'T KNOW
THAT.
YOU LITERALLY LIKE WHEN YOU BUY
A HOUSE AND YOU HAVE A
DISCLOSURE STATEMENT.
WITH GREAT CLARITY IN THE
STATUTE TO ADD SOMETHING IN THAT
REQUIRES THAT LEVEL OF
DISCLOSURE SO THAT WHEN YOU DO
THIS PROJECT GOING FORWARD.
YOU DON'T END UP HAVING A
GIGANTIC PROBLEM WITH LAWSUITS
OR OTHER KINDS OF CHALLENGES OUR
NEIGHBORS THAT THAT OCCUPY THESE
BUILDINGS AND SAY OH MY GOD WITH
ALL THESE TRUCKS ARE GOING
THROUGH THE SHIP NOISE OR
WHATEVER THE CASE MAY BE.
AS OUR CHALLENGES A LIVING
APPROXIMATE TO SUCH AN IMPORTANT.
INDUSTRIAL ARE PRICED SECOND.
ARMED WITH RESPECT TO THE
THERE'S A NUMBER OF WAYS TO DO
THIS -- FINANCIALLY BUT IT SEEMS
TO ME THAT YOU KNOW YEAH YOU'RE
GONNA HAVE TO HAVE TRUCKS MOVING
MAYBE YOU GET A VIEW OUT THE BIG
GRADE SEPARATIONS AND STUFF LIKE
THAT.
AS YOU HAVE AN OPERATING PORT
BUT YOU COULD POSSIBLY CREATE A
DEDICATED REVENUE STREAM OUT OF
THE NEW REVENUES GENERATED FROM
THIS FACILITY RIGHT THIS CAN BE
A LOT OF BRADLEY BIRDS TAX
CREDIT AND SALES TAX.
THERE'S GONNA BE ALL SORTS OF
NEW PROPERTY TAXES GENERATED BIZ
RESULT OF THIS YOU THINK OF THIS
IDEA.
AND THAT ALLOCATE.
SKINNER HAS A BILL THAT ISSUE
WITH US SENATOR SKINNER.
BUT ALLOCATE BUT THAT'S OUR
FINANCING PEACE BUT THE
ALLOCATION OF MONEY TO THAN HELP
SUPPORT THE PORT.
THAT'S MY POINT NOT NOT THE
ABILITY TO FINANCE IT WHAT I'M
SUGGESTING IS IS THAT OUR IS
SUPPORT I NUMBER FINANCING BY
VOTE ON THAT BILL YEAH BUT THE
GOOD QUESTION IS IS TO CREATE
SOME REVENUE STREAM.
OUT OF THIS PROJECT IT WOULD BE
DEDICATED THAT WOULD SUPPORT
SOME OF THE OPERATIONS OF THE
PORT THE CLEANING UP OF THE PORT
OTHER THINGS.
SO THAT YOU YOU KNOW SO LET'S
ASSUME FOR ARGUMENT'S SAKE IT
GENERATED A HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS OF NEW REVENUE AS A
RESULT OF THIS NEW DEVELOPMENT.
YOU TAKE X. PERCENTAGE THAT
REVENUE CRATE SOME FUND THAT
THEN COULD GO INTO.
CLEAN UP THE PORT FIX THE FORT
MEADE CERTAIN PORT SOCIAL PUBLIC
POLICY OPERATIONAL NEEDS THAT
COULD.
MITIGATE SOME OF THE CHALLENGES
THAT CORRECT ARE OFTEN ARE
CREATED IN THE TENSIONS THAT
EXIST WHERE YOU HAVE THESE IN A
CO EXISTING -- DEALS AND CENTER
ACTUALLY OUT ON THAT POINT.
ARE TERM SHEET AGREEMENT WITH
THE PORT OF OAKLAND STIPULATES A
FUNDING MECHANISM AS YOU HAVE
ARTICULATED OVER TWO HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS IN GUARANTEED
PAYMENTS UP TO POTENTIALLY SEVEN
OR EIGHT HUNDRED MILLION THAT
WOULD GO TO THE PORT OF OAKLAND
FOR THESE TYPES OF THINGS THAT
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT.
SO WE'VE BEEN SPENDING ABOUT A
YEAR AND A HALF WITH THE PORT
NEGOTIATING THIS ECONOMIC TERMS
THAT THERE CAN BE REAL BENEFITS.
FOR THE POOR TO USE AS THEY SEE
FIT YEAH BECAUSE AT SUCH MEAN
YET THREE POINT.
SUCH AN IMPORTANT I USED TO
CHAIR THE LOS ANGELES ACCOUNT
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT BRITIAN AND
WE HAD TO DEAL WITH THE PORTS
AND IN A LOS ANGELES AND AND AND
AND LONG BEACH AND WE JUST
EXTREMELY IMPORTANT -- ECONOMIC
DRIVERS OF SO MUCH OF WHAT WE DO
AND HAS IMPACTS ALL ACROSS THIS
COUNTRY AND WE DON'T WANT TO DO
ANYTHING THAT ADVERSELY AFFECTS
THEIR PRODUCTIVITY.
YOU KNOW SO I JUST THINK THAT'S
PART OF A LARGER ITEMS
UNDERSTANDING WHO STAKEHOLDERS
ARE THERE'S A LARGER DYNAMIC IN
THAT REGARD IS ONE SURE THAT FUN
THANK YOU THANK YOU SENATORS
WERE A CENTER CENTER JACKSON.
AND I WANTED TO SORT OF FOLLOW
UP ON THAT THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR TAKING THOSE AMENDMENTS I
THINK IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT.
YOU KNOW THERE'S A PERCEPTION
THAT WHEN SOMEONE WANTS TO BUILD
SOMETHING BIG THEY DON'T HAVE TO
FOLLOW SEE.
AND THE FACT THAT YOU'RE GOING
TO BE DOING AND I THINK IS
CRITICALLY IMPORTANT IN THERE
WILL BE SOME UPS AND DOWNS I'M
SURE.
I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT TO THE
PORT.
OF OAKLAND IS A CRITICAL
ECONOMIC DRIVER IN THE STATE
VERY IMPORTANT TO OUR WELL BEING
AND ALL AND I I LOOK FORWARD TO
THAT BEING PART OF THE
DISCUSSION AS WELL [inaudible]
SO THAT.
WE CAN CONTINUE TO SEE THAT --
IS A ROBUST PRODUCTIVE --
INSTRUMENT OF ECONOMIC GROWTH AT
THE SAME TIME PROTECTING OUR
ENVIRONMENT IN THE THING SINCE
SHE WAS DESIGNED TO DO SO I JUST
WANT TO THANK YOU FOR TAKING
THOSE MOMENTS THERE.
BY DOING SO I I'M ABLE TO
SUPPORT THIS BILL I AND LOOK
FORWARD TO SEEING HOW THIS
PROCESS MOST THANK YOU FOR BEING
HERE AND THANK YOU FOR BRINGING
US OUR LAWFUL WITH.
THANK CENTER JACKSON.
CENTER HAVE YOUR YEAH MY APOLOGY
FOR MISSING A LOT OF THE
PRESENTATION AND THEN JUST
WALKING IN AND ASKING QUESTIONS
SO I APOLOGIZE IF THEY'VE BEEN
ANSWERED AYE THERE'S THERE WERE
TWO ISSUES THAT I WANTED TO MAKE
SURE THAT.
THAT I WAS SET ON ONE IS THAT IN
REALITY THIS IS A PROPERTY
TRANSFER IT'S NOT ANY.
ENTITLE MENTOR ANY -- WAVING OF
ANY REQUIREMENTS YOU DO
EVERYTHING THAT YOU WOULD
NORMALLY HAVE TO DO NUMBER ONE
NUMBER TWO IS -- JUSTIFIED TODAY
WE'RE GONNA LOOK AT BILLS IT
DIDN'T DEAL WITH SEA LEVEL RISE
AND ADAPT TAPES ADAPTATION AND
ALL THAT KIND OF STUFF.
I'D LIKE TO BE INCREASING
DEVELOPMENT ALONG THE COAST A
REGION -- AT THE SAME TIME THAT
WE'RE SAYING WE'RE GONNA HAVE TO
HARDEN OUR SEALEVEL RISE ISSUES
AND SO I I I I I MY QUESTION
REALLY.
HAS TO DO WITH HOW ARE YOU.
YOU KNOW MA'AM I'M ASSUMING
THAT'S GONNA HAVE TO BE
MITIGATEDSOMEHOW IN IN -- YEAH
AND DOCUMENT DOCUMENTS AND BILLS
WILL SEE ALL OF THAT ABSOLUTELY
AND THAT'S SOMETHING WE'RE
COMMITTED TO PRIVATELY FINANCING --
HANDLING THE RESILIENCY AND THE
SEA LEVEL RISE ISSUES AT HOWARD
TERMINAL RIGHT NOW IT'S NOTHING
WAS DONE EVENTUALLY WE JUST
BECOME KIND OF FLOODED BUT WE'RE
GONNA BE RAISING THE SITE BY
OVER SIX FEET.
MAKING SURE IT FITS INTO THE
SURROUNDING COMMUNITY AND THAT'S
A REALLY IMPORTANT -- POSITIVE
ATTRIBUTES OF THE PROJECT.
WHERE IF I AM IN ONE OF THE
AMENDMENTS -- THE REQUIREMENT IS
THAT THE THE OPC -- OCEAN
PROTECTION COUNCIL EIGHT DAVE
MAXI LEVEL RISE AND SO THERE HI
RANGE SEA LEVEL RISE SCENARIO
WHICH THEY CALL AGE PLUS PLUS.
THAT'S THE WORST SEA LEVEL RISE
SCENARIO THAT'S REQUIRED NOW TO
BE ANALYZED IN THE COURSE OF THE
DEVELOPMENT SO THEY HAVE TO
ACTIVELY PLAN FOR THAT.
JUST TO CLARIFY.
YEAH THAT THAT'S AS A SECTION
FOR OF OF THE STAFF ANALYSIS WE
APPRECIATE THE MOMENT.
CLARIFICATION YEAH ABSOLUTELY --
WE'VE BEEN THOROUGH.
I WOULD ENTERTAIN A MOTION.
AND THE MOTION WOULD BE TO PASS
AS AMENDED.
TO APPROPRIATIONS.
WE KNOW THIS IS A COMPLEX ISSUE.
A LOT OF ENTHUSIASM FOR THE
EIGHTIES.
LOT OF COMPLEXITIES IN AROUND
THE LAND USE LABOR -- PRE SHEET
YOU WORKING WITH ASSEMBLY MEMBER
IN.
PRESERVING IS LOCAL PROCESS AND
BETTER MAYOR IN.
IN KABUL -- THE ONE I JUST ASK
IS THIS BILL EVOLVES IF IF THERE
ARE MAJOR CHANGES OR ANY.
FURTHER AMENDMENTS OUT WE LOVE
YOU TO KEEP WORKING WITH THE
COMMITTEE AND RESERVE THAT RIGHT.
TO SEE IT AGAIN IF IF THERE'S
SOME BIG CHANGE IN THE FUTURE
BUT I THINK IT'S A PRETTY DECENT
WORK PRODUCT TO MOVE FORWARD
WITH HERE TODAY.
ED.
AND RESPECTING THE CONCERNS BUT
I'M COME FROM MOVING THE BILL
FOR TODAY SO WE DO HAVE A MOTION --
FROM SENATOR JACKSON'S TO PASS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS.
WILL LIGHT A CLOSER.
JUST VERY BRIEFLY FOR SOMEONE I
THANK THE CHAIR AND STAFF FOR
DID IMPROVEMENTS MADE TO THE
BILL WE'VE CREATED A PROCESS
THAT I THINK IS AN OUTSTANDING
PROCESS THAT WILL HELP.
MAKE SURE THAT -- WE ARE
COMPLYING WITH ALL THE REQUISITE
RULES AND REQUIREMENTS TO MAKE
THIS A AN OUTSTANDING PROJECT --
FROM ALL MEASURES.
ALSO JUST WANT TO MAKE A BRIEF
STATEMENT ABOUT SOME OF THE
OPPOSITION -- WE DON'T THINK
THAT A SUCCESSFUL PORT OF
OAKLAND WITH GREAT JOBS FOR
WORKING PEOPLE AND THIS PROJECT
ARE MUTUALLY EXCLUSIVE WE THINK
THEY CAN EXIST TOGETHER AND WILL
EXIST TOGETHER AND AND WE'RE
COMMITTED TO THAT AS AS THE THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER THAT REPRESENTS
THE TO THE SOME WHICH AFFECT.
THE PORT OF OAKLAND IS IN MY
DISTRICT -- IT'S THE FIFTH
LARGEST PORT IN THE NATION BY
CONTAINER VOLUME IT'S WHEN THE
BIGGEST ECONOMIC DRIVERS IN THE
EAST BAY IT'S VERY IMPORTANT TO
US WE WANT TO SUCCEED WE'RE
COMMITTED TO HAVING A SICK
SUCCEED.
AND WE BELIEVE A NEW BALL PARK
PROJECT -- WILL THAT CAN
PEACEFULLY COEXIST AND AND AND
THAT THAT SUCCESS CAN CONTINUE --
AND SOME OF THE COMMENTS ABOUT
HOUSING AND COMMERCIAL RETAIL
THERE'S HOUSING AND COMMERCIAL
RETAIL ALL AROUND THE PORT NOW --
SAID THIS ISN'T NEW -- AND WITH
WITH THE PROPER PLANNING WITH
BUFFER ZONES WITH GRADE
SEPARATIONS -- WITH OTHER
SOLUTIONS -- WE THINK THIS IS
GONNA BE OUTSTANDING PROJECT THE
SPACE THAT ALLOWS OUR PORT. TO
CONTINUE TO THRIVE -- WITH WITH
GREAT JOBS WORKING PEOPLE THE
ALAMEDA LABOR COUNCIL IS IN
SUPPORT OF THIS THE PORT OF
OAKLAND IS UNANIMOUSLY IN
SUPPORT OF THIS -- SO WE THINK
REMOVED IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION
OBVIOUSLY THERE WILL BE
CHALLENGES AHEAD BUT WE'RE
COMMITTED TO ADDRESS EACH OF
THEM AS THEY COME.
THROUGH THE PROCESS THAT YOU
LEAVE IT LAID OUT I RESPECTFULLY
ASK DR OUT.
THANK YOU THE MOTIONS TO PASS AS
AMENDED -- PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
THE STERN I'D JONES ALLEN.
OR JUST.
CABALLERO CABALLERO AYE
HERTZBERG HUESO.
JACKSON JACKSON AYE MONEY IN
MONEY NINE HAS FOR SO THAT IS
FOUR VOTES WILL LEAVE THE
MEASURE ON CALL THANK YOU ALL
FOR YOUR TIME EVERYONE SHOWED UP
HERE TODAY I CAN SECURE THANK
YOU COLLEAGUES THANK YOU STAFF
THANK YOU.
OKAY SENATOR THANK YOU FOR
WAITING PATIENTLY.
WE'LL GIVE YOU JUST -- ONE
MINUTE TO TO EXIT THE ROOM AND
RECONVENE HERE.
BUT LET'S MAKE IT IS SPEEDY ONE
MINUTE FOLKS.
YOU ALL ARE WELCOME TO TALK
OUTSIDE THE WHOLE.
FOLKS WE'RE GONNA ASK YOU TO
TAKE THE CONVERSATION THAT THE
WHOLE WE DO APPRECIATE YOUR TIME.
HI GOOD TO SEE A TEN EIGHT ZERO
MARK THANKS FOR BEING HERE
[inaudible]
PROBABLY.
I'M NOT SURE HOW MUCH SHE ASKED
ME WHAT I WAS DOING [inaudible]
I YES I WILL BE [inaudible]
ALL RIGHT.
WE'RE ALMOST THERE.
THE SERGEANTS YOU WANT TO TAKE A
LOOK IN THE HALL LOOKS LIKE WE
GOT A LITTLE BOTTLE NECK OUT
THERE [inaudible]
ALL RIGHT.
THANK YOU ALL WE'RE GONNA
RECONVENE HERE.
THANK YOU SIMILAR FOR YOUR
PATIENCE.
WE HAVE BEFORE US.
I NUMBER TWO IF YOU WANT TO GO
FIRST AB FORTY FOUR VERY GOOD --
PLEASE PROCEED.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR THANK YOU
MEMBERS.
I BRING YOU TODAY A BILL THAT
WOULD BRING STATEWIDE -- A
POLICY THAT'S ALREADY BEEN
INSTITUTED IN SOME OF OUR
LARGEST CITIES INCLUDING LOS
ANGELES AND SAN FRANCISCO.
WILL THAT WOULD REINFORCE
CALIFORNIA'S VALUES OF MAKING
SURE THAT PRODUCTS THAT WE OFFER
TO CONSUMERS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA ARE AS CRUELTY FREE
AS POSSIBLE.
NOW THE VOTERS IN CALIFORNIA
HAVE TOLD US IN MORE THAN ONE
OCCASION THAT IF THEY BY.
AEGS IF THEY PURCHASE MEAT THEY
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT THAT
PRODUCT HAS BEEN RECENT AWAY
THAT IS THIS FREE IS CRUELTY AS
WE CAN GET.
BUT WE HAVE NO WAY OF DOING THAT
WITH THE FOR INDUSTRY MOST FOR
PRODUCTS COME FROM OVERSEAS.
FROM COUNTRIES WERE REGULATION
IS IMPOSSIBLE MANY ANIMALS THAT
ARE USED FOR FOR PRODUCTS ARE
ANIMALS THAT BY THEIR VERY
NATURE IS WILD ANIMAL SUFFER
WHEN THEY'RE IN CAPTIVITY UNLIKE
DOMESTICATED ANIMALS.
NOW THIS BILL TRIES TO BE A
REASONABLE BILL THAT ALLOWS FOR
FOR PRODUCTS THAT ARE FROM
ANIMALS THAT ARE USED FOR MEAT
SUCH AS QUE HOUSE COWS.
OR SHEEP WITH SHEARLING TO BE
USE STILL FOR THEIR FOR BECAUSE
IT'S MY BELIEF THAT IF YOU'RE
GOING TO FORM AN ANIMAL YOU
SHOULD USE EVERY PART OF THAT
ANIMAL.
FROM NOSE TO TAIL SO WE TRIED TO
IN THE CRAFT A BILL THAT STILL
ALLOWS ANIMALS THAT ARE USED FOR
ME TO HAVE THEIR HIDES IN THERE
FOR USED. FOR CLOTHING.
BUT WITH PROP WITH THE ANIMALS
THAT ARE EITHER REYES FOR FOUR
OR MORE COMMONLY TRAPPED IN THE
WILD THAT'S NOT THE CASE.
THOSE ANIMALS ARE TAKEN ONLY FOR
THEIR PELTS THE REST OF THE
ANIMAL IS BASICALLY DISCARDED
ARE TREATED AS A WASTE PRODUCT.
SO THESE ARE ANIMALS THAT ARE
SUFFERING THAT ARE BEING TRAPPED
IN THE WILD LEFT IN KEY IN LATE
THE HOLDS -- LEFT TO DIE
MISERABLY OR WHEN THEY WERE
RAISED FOR THE FOR INDUSTRY.
KILLED IN A WAY THAT IS NOT
REGULATED BY ANY OF OUR LAWS
BECAUSE REGULATION AND HOW
ANIMALS ARE SLAUGHTERED ARE ONLY
GOVERNED FOR FOOD ANIMALS.
SO WE HAVE -- CERTAINLY SEEN
EVIDENCE OF REALLY HORRIFIC
PRACTICES IN THE FOR INDUSTRY
PARTICULARLY OVERSEAS BUT
DOMESTICALLY AS WELL.
OUR CONSUMERS HAVE TOLD US THAT
THEY EXPECTED OF CALVET PRODUCT
IS SOLD IN CALIFORNIA THAT IT'S
BEEN HUMANELY RAISED AND
SLAUGHTERED WE CAN'T GUARANTEE
THAT WITH THE FOR INDUSTRY SO
IT'S TIME THAT WE TAKE.
THE LOCAL BANDS THAT HAVE
ALREADY BEEN INSTITUTED AND
BRING THAT STATEWIDE WHICH I
BELIEVE IS IN KEEPING WITH
CALIFORNIA'S VALUES.
I'D ALSO LIKE TO POINT OUT THAT
MANY OF OUR LARGEST -- CLOTHING
MANUFACTURERS HAVE THEMSELVES
GONE FOR FREE.
THE REASON IS BECAUSE SOME OF
THEM OF TOLD US THAT THEY HAVE
GONE TO TRY TO SOURCE HUMANE FOR
AROUND THE WORLD AND WHEN THEY
DONE THAT AND THEY'VE GONE ON
TRIPS TO LOOK AT FOR
MANUFACTURERS TO LOOK AT FOR
FARMS.
THEY HAVE NOT FELT THAT THAT WAS
IN KEEPING WITH THEIR VALUES IS
A COMPANY THAT THEY COULDN'T
GUARANTEE THAT THOSE ANIMALS
WERE REYES CRUELTY FREE AND SO
THEY'RE SAYING WE'RE NOT GOING
TO DO FOR AT ALL.
NO OTHER THERE ARE A FEW OTHER
STATES THAT ARE LOOKING FOR FOR
MAN'S BUT IN CALIFORNIA WE LIKE
TO LEAD NOT FOLLOW.
AND I BELIEVE THAT IT'S IT'S
TIME FOR US TO TAKE THE FIRST
STEP IN THE COUNTRY AND SAY THAT
AS A STATE WE'RE GOING TO GO FOR
FREE.
WITH ME TODAY TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF AB FORTY FOUR IS PJ
SMITH WITH THE HUMANE SOCIETY
AND MARCHING IS THE FOUNDER OF
ANIMAL HOPING LEGISLATION
WITHOUT I RESPECTFULLY.
REQUEST AN AYE VOTE THANK YOU
SIMPLY MEMBER.
PLEASE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLYMEMBERS
FRIEDMAN AND THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN MY NAME IS PJ SMITH AND
I'M THE FASHION POLICY DIRECTOR
AT THE HUMANE SOCIETY OF THE
UNITED STATES.
A PROUD CO SPONSOR OF AB.
FORTY FOUR ON BEHALF OF THE HSUS
IN OUR SUPPORTERS ACROSS
CALIFORNIA WE URGE YOU TO VOTE
YES FOR THIS BILL. FOR A DECADE
I'VE WORKED WITH DOZENS OF THE
TOP OF PAYROLL COMPANIES FROM TJ
MAX THE BURBERRY AND RECENTLY
PRADA. TO CREATE POLICIES THAT
ARE GOOD FOR THE ANIMALS AND THE
ENVIRONMENT.
WHEN THESE COMPANIES EXAMINE THE
FUR TRADE CLOSELY THEY QUICKLY
REALIZE THAT THERE IS NO WAY TO
HUMANELY SOURCE?
FOR AS WELL CONSUMERS ARE
REJECTING PRODUCTS ASSOCIATE
WITH ANIMAL CRUELTY THIS IS WHY
SO MANY OF THESE COMPANIES ARE
NOW GOING FOR FREE.
RATHER THAN PREPARE FOR
CONSUMERS CHANGING TASTES THE
FOR INDUSTRY CHOOSES TO INSTEAD
CREATES SMOKE SCREENS TO COVER
UP IN MEN SUFFERING IT CAUSES.
ITS LATEST GREENWASHING ATTEMPT
IS CALLED FOR MARK.
UNDER FOR MARK ON DOMESTICATED
ANIMALS ARE STILL KRAMDEN
BEARING CAGES FOR THEIR ENTIRE
LIVES ANIMALS ARE STILL CAUGHT
IN THE WILD IN STEEL LIKE COLD
TRANSFER DAYS WITHOUT FOOD WATER.
AN ANIMAL STILL DIE BY AN
ELECTROCUTION IN FACT THIS IS
ONE OF THE PRESCRIBED METHODS OF
SLAUGHTER.
THE LIST GOES ON AND NUMEROUS
INVESTIGATIONS OF A SHOWN THAT
CERTIFIED FARMS IS STILL RAMPANT
WAS SELF MUTILATION AND
BEHAVIORS CALLS BY MEN STRESS IN
SUCH FEAR.
IN FACT JUST LAST YEAR WHEN THE
<c.cyan>UR TRADE WAS TRYING TO PROMOTE</c>
ITS PRODUCT AS ETHICAL AND
ENVIRONMENTALLY FRIENDLY FRANCES
INDEPENDENT ADVERTISING
AUTHORITY CLAIMED.
THAT THOSE WERE MISLEADING AND
ABUSIVE AND EVEN BASED ON LIES
NAY ADDED NUMEROUS RELIABLE
REPORTS SHOW THAT THE PRODUCTION
OF FOR IS EXTREMELY CRUEL
INCLUDING AND THAT THE FINAL
PRODUCT CONTAINS TALK TO TOXIC
SUBSTANCES.
CALIFORNIANS CARE ABOUT AND THE
ANIMAL WELFARE THEY CARE ABOUT
THE ENVIRONMENT THEY CARE ABOUT
INNOVATION MORE THAN EVER IN
BRANDS ARE RESPONDING BY DINT OF
DEVELOPING SUSTAINABLE MATERIALS
TO HAVE THE SAME LOOK AND FEEL
AS FOR BUT WITHOUT THE CRUELTY.
CALIFORNIA CAN CAPITALIZE ON
THIS GROWING MARKET THE FOR
INDUSTRY CAN'T TOO WEIRD YOU WE
URGE YOU TO VOTE YES THANK YOU
[inaudible]
AYE SIR.
NEXT WITNESS.
HI MY NAME IS MARCHING FROM
ANIMAL OPEN LEGISLACIóN --
WE'RE ONE OF THE CO SPONSORING
GROUPS OF THIS BILL -- PART OF
OUR HISTORY AS A GROUP IS WE'VE
GONE UNDERCOVER INTO FOR FARMS
AROUND THE WORLD IN THE UNITED
STATES AND FINLAND WHICH IS THE
SECOND LARGEST PRODUCER.
FOR IN CHINA WHICH IS THE FIRST
SET AS WELL AS CANADA.
OF THOSE IN OPPOSITION TO THIS
BILL THAT WOULD HAVE YOU BELIEVE
THAT.
A LOT OF THE VIDEOS SEEN ONLINE
ARE FABRICATED OR OUTDATED --
BUT BEING THERE MYSELF I CAN
TELL YOU THAT IT'S NOT.
I'VE WITNESSED UNDOCUMENTED AND
PUT TOGETHER VIDEOS WHICH
REFUSED TO PASS AND BANNED FOR
IN A LOS ANGELES.
OR THE SHOAL FOX'S BEING
ELECTROCUTED.
MANY OF THEM STILL ALIVE AS
THEIR SKIN -- WE'VE DOCUMENTED
FOX FOX'S SCREAMING AS THEIR FOR
IS RIPPED OFF OF THEM -- THEY'RE
SUPPOSED TO BE DEAD BUT BECAUSE
OF THE MASS AMOUNT OF BOXES
BEING KILLED THAT'S NOT ALWAYS
POSSIBLE.
WE'VE DOCUMENTED FOR SEND
BEATINGS OF THESE FOXES.
OF MINK OF RACCOONS OF DIFFERENT
ANIMALS USED -- FOR FOR THE LIVE
THEIR WHOLE ENTIRE LIVES IN
THESE CAGES AND NEVER TOUCH
GROUND -- THE THE ANIMALS USE
FOR FOR THE FOR INDUSTRY THE
MEAT IS NEVER USE SINCE OTHER
REYES SOLELY FOR THIS -- AS PJ
AND LOWER -- MENTIONED THERE ARE
MANY MANY ALTERNATIVES THAT
DON'T.
INVOLVE THE SUFFERING IN EXTREME
TORTURE OF AN ANIMAL.
AND WE BELIEVE THAT CALIFORNIA
IS READY TO GO FOR FREE -- MANY
OF THE RETAILERS HAVE AND LOS
ANGELES TO SAN FRANCISCO HAS
BERKELEY HAS.
AND DO WE ASK -- FOR YES VOTE --
LAST THING IS THAT.
THE OPPONENTS WILL TRY TO SAY
THAT THERE'S AS THEY CAN
STANDARDIZE FOR YOU CANNOT YOU
CANNOT.
HUMANELY REGULATED INDUSTRY
WHERE ANIMALS ARE TORTURED TO
DEATH WHERE THEY'RE SKIN THE
LIVES AND THAT IS IMPOSSIBLE TO
CONTROL.
AND WE BELIEVE -- FOR THIS BILL
WILL.
ATTEND TO THE NEEDS OF
CALIFORNIANS AND LIKE TO THANK
LAURA FOR HER STRONG LEADERSHIP
ON THE BILL AND EVERYONE HERE SO
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
I JUST ADD THAT WE TAKEN
AMENDMENTS -- TO ADDRESS
CONCERNS IN THE AGRICULTURAL
INDUSTRY FROM PAWNBROKERS FROM
SECONDHAND DEALERS FROM THE
HUNTING COMMUNITY WE THINK THIS
IS A VERY REASONABLE BILL IT
ALLOWS FOR THE SALE OF SECOND
HAND. FOR AND WON'T INTERFERE
WITH HUNTING OR ANY OF THOSE
OTHER USES.
VERY GOOD THANK YOU.
OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
NAME AND AFFILIATION.
NICHOLAS SACKETT SOCIAL
COMPASSION LEGISLATION I JUST
WANT TO MENTION THAT ARE
COSMETIC BILL LAST YEAR'S NOW
BEING COPIED IN EIGHT OTHER
STATES GOING TO THE PROCESS AND
HOPE THIS ONE WOULD AS WELL.
SOMEWHAT OF AN AFFILIATION BUT I
APPRECIATED.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SIR MATT ROBINSON ON
BEHALF OF LOS ANGELES MAYOR ERIC
GARCETTI IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK
YOU SIR.
LESLEY GOLDBERG ELSE RURAL
CALIFORNIA STRONG SUPPORT THANK
YOU.
FOR THE LONGER BERKELEY
CALIFORNIA FOUNDER OF CALL DO IT
EMPATHY FOR ALL AND ONE GIVEN
THAT X. ACTION EVERYWHERE I
SUPPORT THE BILL.
THANK YOU.
ROLLED UP IN SAN FRANCISCO
ORGANIZER FOR DIRECT ACTION
EVERYWHERE COMPASSIONATE BAY I
STRONGLY SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
VICTORIA TO SAN FRANCISCO OUR
ORGANIZER WAS DIRECTION XIN
EVERYWHERE AND AND COMPASSIONATE
BAY STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH HI THE
RECALL SEVEN FROM ABOUT -- I'M
HERE ON BEHALF OF MYSELF MY
BUNNIES MOMMY AND BRIDGET WHO
WILL NEVER BE SKINNED ALIVE IN
ORDER TO LINE A PAIR OF GLOVES.
THEY ASKED ME TO COME TO ASK YOU
TO HELP THOSE WHO WILL THANK YOU.
BECKY SIDE OF AUTO -- STRONGLY
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
MICHAEL GOLDBERG I'M AN
ORGANIZER FOR COMPACT BERKELEY
CALIFORNIA'S COMPASSIONATE DAY I
STRONGLY URGE YOU TO SUPPORT
THIS BILL WHICH WILL BAN THE
HORRIBLE TORTURE AND KILLING OF
THESE POOR INNOCENT ANIMALS
THANK YOU.
VERY MUCH.
SCOTT DAVIS AND LOW CALIFORNIA
STRONG SUPPORT.
STEPHANIE DAVIS ANTELOPE
CALIFORNIA CALIFORNIA
CREDENTIALED TEACHER AND VEGANS
ORGANIZER STRONGLY SUPPORT THANK
YOU VERY MUCH.
JUDY LINDO NORTH BAY STRONGLY
SUPPORT.
DEBBIE BUGLE LIES IN PLEASANT
HILL CALIFORNIA I STRONGLY
SUPPORT PLEASE SUPPORT THANK YOU.
HOPO HANNEKE ELK GROVE SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
IN THE MIDDLE SOURCE SACRAMENTO
CALIFORNIA NUMBER PRESIDING.
ANIMAL DEFENDERS INTERNATIONAL
AND DXC AND I STRONGLY SUPPORT
STOP THE PAIN PLEASE.
KAREN GAYLE SACRAMENTO PLEASE
PLEASE PLEASE SUPPORT.
THANK YOU MUCH.
THERE IS A FROM SAN JOSE SUPPORT.
THANK YOU SIR.
BREAK -- THE ELLO O'DONNELL AND
I'M WITH GRASS VALLEY AND I'M
REPRESENTING CAPE CENTER FOR
ANIMAL PROTECTION AND EDUCATION
AND WE STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS
BILL THANK YOU SO MUCH.
JERRY HANSEN FROM GRASS VALLEY
AND I STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL.
THANK YOU.
HAVE YOU OUT LIKE CLARA IBM.
AND MAYBE AYE STRINGS SUPPORT
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
AND AS YOU SPEAK IN YOU IF WHEN
YOU'RE DONE FOR YOU JUST GO THAT
GO THAT WAY IT'LL HELP.
THERE YOU GO.
I'M DIANE AND YVONNE FROM
BERKELEY AND I'M WITH THE DIRECT
ACTION EVERYWHERE AND I STRONGLY
SUPPORT THIS BILL THANK YOU SO
MUCH.
HI JENNIFER KENNEDY WITH HSUS
FROM EL DORADO COUNTY PLEASE
HELP CAN A CALIFORNIA CONTINUE
TO BE A BEACON OF LIGHT. FOR THE
REST OF THE COUNTRY FOR CRUELTY
FREE COUNTRY THANK YOU.
ROBERT BOYLE'S AND SECTOR-LIMóN
STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL THANK
YOU SIR.
MICHELLE LAYING SAN LEANDRO I
VERY MUCH SUPPORT THIS BILL AND
I THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
COMPASSION TOWARDS ANIMALS THANK
YOU.
MALVINA HOME ON JAN FROM SAN
FRANCISCO AIDS SUPPORT THIS BILL
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
LIVE BONE THING FROM ONE OF
CREEK WITH DIRECT ACTION
EVERYWHERE I STRONGLY SUPPORT
THE SUPPORT TO THANK YOU.
A RAVEN DIRECTION BERKELEY
CALIFORNIA AND AS A WILDLIFE
PHOTOGRAPHER WHO SPENDS TIME
WITH THESE ANIMALS AND WHILE
THIS IS THE RIGHT THING TO DO
AND I STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL
THINKING.
CASSIE KING BERKELEY THE EXCEED
ACTION EVERYWHERE AND I STRONGLY
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
DANIEL CO SACRAMENTO CALIFORNIA
STRONG SUPPORT IT'S TIME.
THANK YOU.
WHEN SHOWN FROM BERKELEY FOR
DIRECT ACTION EVERYWHERE AND I'M
SUPPORT?
THOMAS CHIANG FROM CENSUS GO
ANNOUNCER VOICELESS AND DIRECT
ACTION EVERYWHERE IN SUPPORT.
HELLO PACKAGE DIRECT ACTION
EVERYWHERE SUPPORT THIS BILL.
DO WE WALDRON FROM WALNUT CREEK
CALIFORNIA AN ORGANIZER WITH
DIRECT ACTION EVERYWHERE AND
COMPASSIONATE BAY AND PLEASE
MAKE CALIFORNIA THE ETHICAL AND
COMPASSIONATE LEADER IT IS THANK
YOU IN SUPPORT.
DOCTOR CRYSTAL HEATH FROM CLAY
IN CALIFORNIA AND I STRONGLY
SUPPORT THIS BILL.
BOB I. CALABI FROM WALLY CREEK
CALIFORNIA PROUD MEMBER OF
DIRECT ACTION EVERYWHERE AND
WITH THE SOIL BUT REPORT LET'S
AND THIS ANIMAL SUFFERING
SUPPORT AB.
FORTY FOUR WHEN THE BRAMBLE FROM
SACRAMENTO CALIFORNIA
REPRESENTING IN DEFENSE OF
ANIMALS PLEASE SUPPORT THIS I
SUPPORT THIS BILL PLEASE BUT
BASS.
HI TIFFANI WORTHINGTON FROM
SANTA CRUZ CALIFORNIA.
AND THANK YOU FOR SUPPORTING
THIS BILL AND STANDING FOR
ANIMALS COMPASSION TOWARDS
ANIMALS.
YOU MA'AM.
ALEX AND TO REAFFIRM FEEL
CALIFORNIA SUPPORT THIS BILL
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
POLICY CENTER AREA -- FAIRFIELD
CALIFORNIA I SUPPORT THE BILL
THANK YOU.
MATTHEW MICKEY FREE BERKELEY
ORGANIZER WITH DIRECT ACTION
EVERYWHERE AND I STRONGLY
SUPPORT THIS BILL.
THANK YOU.
I MEMORY OR MARYLAND I'M AN
ORGANIZER WITH DIRECT ACTION
EVERYWHERE AND AN ORGANIZER WITH
MARY ANIMALS SAVE.
ANIMALS DESERVE TO LIVE AND I
STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL.
NAOMI ROSE WITH DIXIE AND UC
BERKELEY ANIMAL ADVOCACY AND
STRONG SUPPORT.
VERY MUCH MIKE STAGE SANTA CLARA
SUPPORT.
ANTHONY TO HEAR FROM SAN
FRANCISCO DXT PLEASE SUPPORT
VERY GOOD THANK YOU.
VICTORIA WOODS FROM SAN
FRANCISCO AND I SUPPORT AB FORTY
FOUR THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THREE
IS A HONEY WITH DIRECT ACTION
EVERYWHERE AND I STRONGLY
SUPPORT THIS BILL.
MUCH.
NAY SEATING FROM PACIFICA PLEASE
SUPPORT THIS BILL THANK YOU SO
MUCH.
DILLON WELLS REPRESENTING
STUDENT ORGANIZATIONS FOR ANIMAL
LIBERATION AT SAC STATE
UNIVERSITY WHO SUPPORT THIS BILL.
THANK YOU.
STAY FITZGERALD FROM STANISLAUS
COUNTY STRONGLY SUPPORT THANK
YOU THANKS SO MUCH.
AMIR FROM BERKELEY CALIFORNIA
WITH DIRECT ACTION EVERYWHERE
STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL.
THANKS.
HI GOOD MORNING HONESTLY MCCABE
OF ANIMAL PLANET'S INTERNATIONAL
WE AND OUR THOUSAND SO FAR
CALIFORNIA SUPPORT TO SUPPORT
THIS BILL THANKS SO MUCH.
HI AMBER THIS PRESS ZERO AND I'M
FROM OAKLAND CALIFORNIA AND I
STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL.
THANK YOU.
HI PRISCILLA STILL FROM
SACRAMENTO CALIFORNIA AND I
STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL.
THANK YOU.
FORSKOLIN SACRAMENTO CALIFORNIA
I STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL
[inaudible]
MUCH.
MY NAME IS AN EFFORT IS EXAMPLE
SITE IS A LIEU BERKELEY
CALIFORNIA WOULD DIRECT ACTION
EVERYWHERE AND I SUPPORT THIS
BILL.
MY NAME IS MEGAN STEIN BERKELEY
CALIFORNIA I'M WITH DIRECT
ACTION EVERYWHERE AND I STRONGLY
SUPPORT THIS BILL THANK YOU.
HELLO MY NAME IS CALEY POINT OF
I'M A RESIDENT OF YUBA COUNTY
AND I STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
DOUG FULLER BERKELEY DIRECT
ACTION EVERYWHERE IN SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL HANKEY THANK YOU.
COLLEEN CAMERON DUBLIN
CALIFORNIA AND I STRONGLY
SUPPORT THIS BILL THANK YOU SO
MUCH.
SERGIO FRANCO OAKLAND CALIFORNIA
AND I STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL
THANK YOU.
I'M VERONICA COLOGNE PRAMANA
CREEK AND I STRONGLY SUPPORT
THIS BILL THANK YOU.
ALONG KIND OF POLICY WALNUT
CREEK AND I SUPPORT THIS BILL
TRANSACTION EVERYWHERE THANK YOU.
DOCTOR RIVER MINISTERS CIVIL
RIGHTS AND HUMAN RIGHTS SO
SUPPORT THIS BILL FOR MOTHER
EARTH LEGAL SYSTEM AND JUSTICE
FOR ALL.
BAKER THANK YOU SIR DARK RIVERS
OF CIVIL RIGHTS HUMAN RIGHTS I'M
HERE TO SUPPORT THIS BILL THANK
YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
HELLO MY NAME IS JENNIFER
TENANTS ON BEHALF OF MY FRIENDS
AND MYSELF RESIDENTS OF
CALIFORNIA WE STRONGLY SUPPORT
THIS BILL THANK YOU THANK YOU
VERY MUCH.
HI MY NAME'S JOHN CAMERON FROM
DUBLIN CALIFORNIA AND I STRONGLY
SUPPORT THIS COMPASSIONATE BILL
THANK YOU.
KATIE JOHNSTON BERKELEY
ORGANIZER WITH DETECTION
EVERYWHERE STRONGLY SUPPORT IF
YOU.
MILLION MEDIA BY THOSE SENATE
SOUTH AT THE MENTAL AND STRONGLY
SUPPORT THIS BILL THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MA'AM.
WE HAVE ANY OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
SEEING NONE DO -- DOING ANY
OPPOSITION.
PLEASE COME FOR YOU CAN TAKE A
WILL DO TO WITNESSES UP FRONT
AND THEN.
YOU HAVE ADDITIONAL TESTIMONY
AFTERWARDS.
THANK YOU SO MUCH [inaudible]
MORNING WELDING.
GOOD MORNING SENATORS ARE MY
NAME IS EDWIN LOMBARD I'M HERE
TODAY REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA BLACK CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE THE LARGEST BLACK
BUSINESS ASSOCIATION IN
CALIFORNIA AND THE BLACK
BUSINESS ASSOCIATION.
WHICH IS THE OLDEST BLACK
BUSINESS ASSOCIATION A
CALIFORNIA.
AND I'M HERE TO URGE A NO VOTE
ON ASSEMBLY BILL.
FORTY FOUR IN ADDITION TO BEING.
A NEEDLESS ATTACK ON LEGAL
HIGHLY REGULATED JOB PRODUCING
INDUSTRY.
IT'S ALSO AN AFFRONT TO THE
AFRICAN AMERICAN COMMUNITY.
IN AN ERA WHEN BLACK AMERICANS
WERE PAID LESS FOR THE SAME JOB
FACING REDLINING HOUSING
DISCRIMINATION.
COULDN'T GET LOANS TO START
BUSINESSES SAVING UP FOR AND
BUYING A FOR A WAS A WAY OF
SHOWING THAT WE COULD OVERCOME
THESE BARRIERS. FOR HAS MUCH OF
THE SAME CULTURAL IMPACTS ON
AFRICAN AMERICANS AS IT DOES ON
NATIVE AMERICANS AND RELIGIOUS
GROUPS.
WHICH THEY BOTH HAVE BEEN GIVEN
PASSED BY AB FORTY FOUR BUT NOT
US.
LET ME BE CLEAR ABOUT ONE THING
MOST OF ALL.
WE'RE NOT ASKING THE SENATE TO
KILL AB FORTY FOUR BECAUSE IT.
DOESN'T INCLUDE US WERE ASKING
TO STOP IT BECAUSE OF BAD
ECONOMIC IMPACT THAT IT WOULD
HAVE ON EVERYONE IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
THE FUR INDUSTRY IS NO DIFFERENT
FROM THE INDUSTRIES THAT REYES
BEEF.
CHICKEN PORK LAMB NOT ONLY FOR
HUMAN CONSUMPTION BT ALSO FOR
THE BY PRODUCTS THAT PROVIDE US
LED THE GOODS GARMENTS.
AND MEDICAL RESEARCH.
SINCE WHEN DO WE KILL CENTURY
OLD LEGAL AND HIGHLY REGULATED
INDUSTRIES BY LEGISLATIVE FIAT.
THAT IS WHAT YOU ARE BEING
VOTING WHICH ARE VOTING ON TODAY.
WHETHER TO ADVANCE A FIRST OF
THE NATION'S BILL TO DISSEMINATE
JOBS AND TAX REVENUE SOLELY TO
PLEASE THE POLITICAL WHIMS OF A
DISTANT MINORITY OF ACTIVISTS OF
ACTIVISTS.
ON WHETHER TO STOP A HORRENDOUS
PIECE OF LEGISLATION FROM GOING
ANY FURTHER.
I MUST SAY THAT THERE IS A SLAP
IN THE FACE THING THAT MAKES AB
FORTY FOUR EVEN WORSE.
AS JASMINE SANDERS ROLE.
IN THE NEW YORK TIMES ABOUT
BLACK WOMEN LIVE IN THE NINETEEN
TWENTIES TO THE NINETEEN
SEVENTIES.
IT WAS A NEAR OF SEGREGATION JIM
CROW LAW RED LINING HOUSING
DISCRIMINATION.
SO SAVING ENOUGH TO PURCHASE A
COSTLY FOR COAL.
WAS A WAY OF SHOWING THAT THEY
COULD OVERCOME THE BARRIERS OF
ANY QUALITY.
IT WAS ALSO A WAY OF PRESENTING
AN ASPIRATIONAL IMAGE WILD.
A CHALLENGING THE STEREO TYPES
AND PERCEPTIONS OF BLACK LIFE.
THERE IS A SENSE AMONG MANY
BLACK WOMEN THAT A BROADER.
CULTURAL DISAPPROVAL.
FOR HAS COINCIDE.
OVER OUR INCREASED ABILITY TO
PURCHASE IT.
OR AS PAUL MARIE SENIORS A
CITIZEN A HISTORIAN AND
PROFESSOR AT OF AFRICAN AMERICAN
STUDIES AT VIRGINIA TECH WORLD.
OUR MOTHER USED TO SAY AS SOON
AS A BLACK WOMEN COULD AFFORD IT
TO BUY A MAIN COLD WHITESOCIETY
AND WHITE WOMEN SAID. FOR WAS
WRONG. FOR WOMEN LIKE MY MOTHER
GRANDMOTHER AUNTS SISTERS A FUR
COAT IS MORE THAN A PERSONAL
LUXURY.
IT'S AN EMOTIONAL INVESTMENT.
WE GIVE OUR U. S. SENATORS.
LONG TERM OFFICES SO THAT THEY
CAN THEORETICALLY BE MORE
DELIVER WILL DELIVER IT
[inaudible]
AND IT WILL BE INTERESTING TO
SEE IF THAT CONSERVE HOLDS UP.
THERE FOR ASKS FOR A NO VOTE ON
A. B..
FORTY FOUR THANK YOU SIR PLEASE
GOOD AFTERNOON THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY -- TO ALLOW ME TO
SPEAK TODAY MY NAME IS KEITH
KAPLAN I'M WITH THE FUR
INFORMATION COUNCIL AMERICA.
AND I HAVE TO BEGIN BY SAYING
TRUTH MATTERS THAT MATTERS TO ME
AND I DO BELIEVE IS OUR ELECTED
OFFICIALS OF MATTERS TO YOU AND
WHAT YOU'VE BEEN FED BY THE
SPONSORS TODAY IS ANYTHING BUT
THE SITTING A LIVE VIDEO HAS
BEEN DISPROVED WOMEN'S WEAR
DAILY WROTE EXTENSIVE ARTICLE.
ON THIS THEY HOLD THE AFFIDAVITS
FROM THE PARTICIPANTS WHO WERE
PAID BY THE ANIMAL RIGHTS GROUP
TO CONDUCT THESE HEINOUS
ACTIVITIES ON ANIMALS TO SUPPORT
THE NARRATIVE.
THAT WOULD PUSH THIS CAMPAIGN
FORWARD.
AND AS FAR AS THE GERMAN HSUS
COMMENTING ON THE FOR MARCH
CERTIFICATION PROGRAM HE CLEARLY
HAS NOT READ NOR UNDERSTANDS
THIS PROGRAM WHICH WAS DEVELOPED
AT THE TABLE WITH ALL OF THE
MAJOR FASHION BRANDS AROUND THE
WORLD. TO ME THEIR GUIDELINES
FOR SOCIALLY RESPONSIBLE ETHICAL
SOURCING IT IS THE V. MOST
COMPREHENSIVE CERTIFICATION
PROGRAM OF ANY ANIMAL USE
INDUSTRY.
EMPLOYS THIRD PARTY MONITORING
EXACTLY THE SAME AS THE CATTLE
INDUSTRY AND IT USES BLOCKCHAIN
TECHNOLOGY TO GUARANTEE
TRANSPARENCY AND ACCESSIBILITY.
BUT I'M NOT HERE TODAY TO ASK
YOU TO KILL AB.
FORTY FOUR IN FACT I'M HERE
TODAY IS TO EXPLAIN TO YOU WHY
IT WON'T RESULT IN ANY POSITIVE
MOVEMENT ON ANIMAL WELFARE AND
WHY THE AMENDMENT THAT WE
PROPOSED. FOR FOR MARCH
CERTIFICATION PROGRAM DOES MORE
TO ACHIEVE THE OBJECTIVES OF THE
BILL'S AUTHOR.
FIRST OF ALL OF THE LUXURY
SECTOR BUYERS AREN'T LIMITED
GEOGRAPHICALLY IF THEY WANT TO
PRODUCT AND THEY CAN'T BITE
WHERE THEY ARE LOCAL WHERE THEY
CAN.
LOOK AT RODEO DRIVE LOOK AT
UNION SQUARE AND THE INFLUX OF
FOREIGN BUYERS.
PEOPLE WHO WANT FOR WILL BUY IT
WHEREVER THEY CAN.
AND THAT'S THE POINT.
IF THEY WANTED BILL BY IT.
THIS BILL WILL HAVE NO EFFECT ON
ANIMALS.
BANDS REALLY HURT THE LEGITIMATE
GUY MOST HE'S THE GUY THAT
FOLLOWS THE RULES DOESN'T BREAK
THE LAW.
HE IS THE ONE YOU'RE PUTTING OUT
OF BUSINESS AND IN SO DOING YOUR
FOSTERING THE GROWTH OF THE
ILLEGITIMATE MARKET THE ONE THAT
DOESN'T FOLLOW THE RULES OR
PLAYED BY THE LAW.
YOU TALKED ABOUT THIS WITH
CANNABIS YOU AGREED THAT
REGULATION WAS THE BEST WAY TO
CLOSE ON THOSE BLACK MARKETS WHY
DOESN'T THAT APPLY HERE.
HERE IN ENCOURAGING ILLEGITIMATE
MARKET YOU CAN BET THOSE GUYS
WON'T BE THE ONES CONCERNED WITH
ANY KIND OF ANIMAL WELFARE
GUIDELINES.
EXEMPTIONS IN THE BILL ALLOW FOR
THE SALE OF FOR FROM CERTAIN
ANIMALS AND THE USE OF FOR BY
CERTAIN CULTURAL GROUPS.
BUT WITHOUT ANY REQUIREMENTS FOR
THE APPLICATION OF ANY KIND OF
ANIMAL WELFARE STANDARDS.
WHEN THE CONSUMER GOES TO BY THE
FOR PRODUCT ALLOWED UNDER THESE
EXEMPTIONS YOU CAN BET HE'S
GONNA LOOK AT THE PRICE POINTS
AND PURCHASED THE LEAST
EXPENSIVE PRODUCT?
AND YOU CAN BET THAT PRODUCT
WILL BE THE ONE THE COST AT
LEAST TO PRODUCE AND WHAT DOES
THAT MEAN.
PROBABLY THE LOWER STANDARDS OF
ANIMAL CARE AND FEEDING.
SO YOU HAVE ACHIEVED EXACTLY
WHAT YOU SET OUT NOT TO DO.
THIS IS.
A IN THE CERTIFICATION PROGRAM
WILL PREVENT THAT FROM HAPPENING.
THE MAN THAT HAS BEEN PRESENTED
TO MISS FREEMAN'S OFFICE.
AT FOR CERTIFICATION PROGRAM
THAT COVERS BOTH FARMS AND WILD.
FOR IT WILL REQUIRE ANY FIRST
SOLD OR MANUFACTURED IN
CALIFORNIA MUST BE CERTIFIED.
THROUGH A PROGRAM THAT IS THIRD
PARTY AND INDEPENDENTLY
MONITORED NOW THE WOMAN WHO
WANTS TO BUY A FOR COULD GO BITE
ON RODEO DRIVE.
RATHER THAN HAVING TO GO TO LAS
VEGAS AND THE PRODUCERS OF THE
FOR SHE BUYS HERE IN CALIFORNIA
WILL HAVE TO OF HAD APPEARED. TO
THE A VERY IMPORTANT ANIMAL
WELFARE STANDARDS REQUIRED UNDER
CERTIFICATION WHICH WOULD HAVE
BEEN THE CASE IN LAS VEGAS.
YOU'VE DONE THE JOB.
THE ANIMAL LOVER.
WE ACTUALLY HAD A POSITIVE
IMPACT ON AND ON AND WILL FOR
BEEN DOING THIS AND FOR THE
EXEMPTED USES.
THE EXEMPTIONS SANDERS THE LESS
EXPENSIVE OPTIONS A COULD BE
SOLDIER UNDER THE EXEMPTIONS
THEY WOULD BE ALLOWED ANYMORE.
SO AGAIN YOU'VE ACHIEVED
SOMETHING POSITIVE AND MR
LOMBARDS.
NOTES ABOUT THE AFRICAN AMERICAN
AMERICAN COMMUNITY FOR WOULD BE
AVAILABLE FOR THEM TO AS LONG AS
IT WAS CERTIFIED.
AB FORTY FOUR HAS SOME SERIOUS
FLAWS BUT THE AMENDMENT THAT HAS
BEEN PRESENTED TO MISS FREEMAN'S
OFFICE THE CERTIFICATION PROGRAM
MAKES IT A STRONGER BILL BY
CLOSING LOOPHOLES THAT ALLOW.
OR ENCOURAGE THE SALE OF
PRODUCTS WITH OUT APPLICATIONS
STRICTER BETTER ANIMAL WELFARE
PRACTICES I URGE YOU TO CONSIDER
THE AMENDMENT.
THANKS SO MUCH I DO HAVE OTHERS
IN OPPOSITION HERE WISH TO
TESTIFY [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THAT A CELL BEYOND A ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA GREENVILLE
DISSOCIATION CENTER I ASKED.
IF I COULD ADDRESS AN ISSUE THAT
WAS IN THE IN THE ANALYSIS.
IT TOOK ABOUT THE ECONOMICS OF
SOURCE FALL -- THE THE CONSOLE
THAT OUTSTANDING JOB IN LAYING
OUT ALL THE ARGUMENTS AND
ARTICULATED OUR ARGUMENTS FOR A
VERY WELL BUT I DID WANT TO SAY.
THERE'S SOME DIRECTION ABOUT THE
THE RABBIT INDUSTRY AND THAT
IT'S THAT IT'S WARPED.
IT WAS A PUN.
DWARFED BY THE BY THE LOT OTHER
LIFE SECOND SHE THAT'S VERY TRUE
IN THE NORTH BUT NOT TO THE
PEOPLE WHO ACTUALLY RAISE
RABBITS.
WILL DO THAT QUICKLY THE
ECONOMICS OF JUST THE WHOLE
WORKS WITH WITH WITH THE THE THE
THE THE FOLKS I'M AWARE OF THE
YOU DOLLARS THIRTY FIVE POUNDS.
I POUND CARP RABBIT.
THAT CREATES ABOUT NINE BUCKS IF
YOU DO THE MATH.
IF IF YOU DE VALUED THE THE
CARCASS BY A DOLLAR DOLLAR
TWENTY FIVE THAT'S ALL IT'S
WORTH.
LET'S YOU KNOW THAT'S NOTHING.
THAT'S GOING TO GO INTO THE
ORGANIC WASTE BIN AND THAT'S
GONNA BE THING THAT THAT THIS.
THAT THIS LEGISLATURE TRYING TO
REDUCE THE KNOWER INCREASING
ORGANIC WASTE WERE DEVALUING THE
THE THE THE THE CARCASS AND THE
ENTIRE ELEMENT. TO IT TO AN AREA
WHERE YOU'RE THAT'S
PROFITABILIY YOU'RE ONLY AT
NIGHT BUCKS.
THE DOLLAR FIFTY OR WHATEVER
YOU'RE DOING WE PROVIDED
AMENDMENTS TO THE TO THE AUTHOR --
AND INITIATE CONVERSATIONS -- IN
THE ASSEMBLY AND WOULD LIKE TO
CONTINUE THAT THANK YOU VERY
GOOD THANK YOU SIR.
MY NAME IS ENTITIES IVANA --
FROM GLENDORA CALIFORNIA I'M A
WHILE G. MAJOR AND
ENVIRONMENTALISTS AND I OPPOSE
THE BILL.
VERY GOOD THANK YOU SIR.
MY NAME IS ANGELO GIRL MISSING A
COUPLE OF MANY OF AMERICANS IN A
COUPLE OF POMONA A LITTLE
SILENCE.
THAT PUTS HIS BILL BECAUSE IT'S
FINANCING NEEDS ONLY NATIVE
AMERICANS NOT ONLY IN CALIFORNIA
BUT DROUGHT THE CONTINENT.
THE WORST PART ABOUT HIS BILL IS
PEOPLE OF OTHER PURPOSE CULTURES
ATTORNEY GOT PEOPLE MY CULTURE
THAT WORD OR CULTURE THIS TO ME.
THE WORST OPEN TO BUT HIS BILL
IS THAT WITH SO MANY TO NAME
AMERICA'S ARMED POVERTY AND THIS
IS ONE THAT'S OPPORTUNITY HAS TO
MAKE AN HONEST LIVING PLEASE
OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK YOU SIR.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS MATT GRAY ON BEHALF OF
CAL SMALL BIZ AND TAXPAYERS FOR
IMPROVING PUBLIC SAFETY.
I IT'S ODD THAT WE CAN VERY
THOUGHTFULLY REGULATE THE
CANNABIS INDUSTRY BUT SOMEHOW WE
CAN'T REGULATE THE FUR INDUSTRY
HITS BAFFLING WE ASK FOR YOUR
OPPOSITION THANK YOU SIR.
GOOD MORNING NO -- CREAMERS OF
CALIFORNIA FARM BUREAU
FEDERATION.
THERE ARE A HUNDRED AND EIGHTY
NINE FARMS IN CALIFORNIA THAT
REYES APPROXIMATELY EIGHTEEN
THOUSAND RABBIT SO IT WELL IT'S
NOT A HUGE COMMUNITY THERE WOULD
BE.
IMPACTS ON WE ALSO ARE CONCERNED
ABOUT THE BAN ON TRAPPING AND
THE IMPACT THAT IT COULD HAVE ON
AGRICULTURAL OPERATIONS OKAY
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
MY NAME IS BRYCE ADAMS I'M A
STUDENT AT SACRAMENTO STATE
HIRED YOU -- ON THE COMMITTEE --
TO VOTE NO ON AB FORTY FOUR
THANK YOU.
PAYMENT PHILLIES ARE FOSTER
OTHER THAN SACRAMENTO MIDTOWN.
THIS IS JUST ANOTHER THING TO
REGULATE AND TO OUTLAW.
ARCHER.
YOU GUYS EVER NOT REGULATE.
YOU EVER PASSED LEGISLATION TO
DO IT DID NOT REGULATE THERE
SEEMS TO BE AN AWFUL LOT OF
LEGISLATION OUT THERE CALLING
FOR BAND SALINAS AND THAT.
I ORDERED OPPOSITION THIS IS
ANOTHER ONE WE COULD YOU MIGHT
AS WELL BAD BAD WEATHER AT THE
SAME TIME SO ANYWAY CAPTION IN
OPPOSITION THANK YOU SO MUCH.
TRY TO KEEP YOUR MARKS TO JUST.
NAME OF PHILLY ONLY A PROBLEM
THANK YOU SO MUCH RENDON NELSON
DICKSON CALIFORNIA I URGE YOU TO
VOTE NO THANK YOU SIR APPRECIATE.
NAMES CONOR NIETO CAM FROM CHICO
CALIFORNIA AND IMPOSE A BILL.
THANKS.
HI MY NAME'S RYAN DO FOR ANNA
FROM CHICO CALIFORNIA AND I
OPPOSE THE BILL.
THANK YOU THANKS FOR BEING HERE.
MY NAME IS ALEX LIAM FROM
FREMONT CALIFORNIA AND OPPOSE
THE BILL AND I URGE YOU TO
CONSIDER AMENDED THANK YOU THANK
YOU MISTER.
MY NAME IS HOPE OUR TAURUS SOME
FROM SANTA ANA CALIFORNIA I'M A
STUDENT AT UC BERKELEY AND I
OPPOSE THIS BILL BECAUSE IT'S IT
IS AN INFRINGEMENT UPON OUR
RIGHTS.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
THANKS FOR BEING HERE.
MY NAME IS EMMA TOWARD IS FROM
SANTA ANA CALIFORNIA AND I
OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK.
MY NAME IS EIGHTY NINE YEARS I'M
FROM LOS ANGELES CALIFORNIA AND
I PUTS HIS BILL TO TO THE FACT
THAT.
MANY INDIGENOUS PEOPLE RELY ON
THESE RESOURCES THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS RUBY MANUALS AND
I'M FROM LOS ANGELES CALIFORNIA
AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL BECAUSE
PEOPLE SHOULD HAVE FREEDOM OF
EXPRESSION.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
OTHERS IN OPPOSITION.
OR ASK FOR YOUR NAME WHERE
YOU'RE FROM AND IF YOU OPPOSE OR
SUPPORT THE BILL OKAY MY NAME IS
LISA GARCIA I AM FROM SACRAMENTO
CALIFORNIA I AM IN OPPOSITION OF
AB.
FORTY FOUR WE'VE LOST A LOT OF
BUSINESSES IN CALIFORNIA ALREADY
I'M WORRIED ABOUT THE ECONOMIC
IMPACT OF THAT.
SO AGAIN EIGHT NO ONE AB FORTY
FOUR THANK YOU SO MUCH.
MORNING I'M GORDON TOM SICK
RETIREE IN SACRAMENTO.
I'M IN OPPOSITION OF AB FORTY
FOUR THANK YOU SIR I BELIEVE IN
LAS A FAIR.
THANK YOU OF GOVERNMENT OFF
BUSINESS THANK YOU TO THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS LORD
TAYLOR RETIRED JARHEAD RETIRED
PEACE OFFICER I'M IN OPPOSITION
DAVEY FORTY FOUR THANK YOU THANK
YOU FOR YOUR SERVICE.
HOW YOU DOING ON TO MORE
JEFFERSON FOR SACRAMENTO ON
COMMUNITY ORGANIZER I'M JUST
WANNA JUST ENCOURAGE OUR MEMBER
TO CONSTITUTION THE OLD OF
OFFICE?
OPPOSES BO BECAUSE
INDISCRIMINATE SO -- REGIS AGAIN
THANK YOU BYE TO OUT THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS JESSICA AND I OPPOSES
BILL.
THANK YOU SIR.
I'M BENJAMIN HUNTER FROM POMONA
CALIFORNIA AND I OPPOSE THIS
BILL THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
I'M CHRISTOPHER FRANKLIN FROM --
FROM SAN DIEGO AND I OPPOSE THIS
BILL THANK YOU SIR.
I AM MARSHALL HOT FIELD OF
STUDENT FROM SAN DIEGO AND I
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE -- MY
NAME IS IS FINDING I AM FROM
FREMONT CALIFORNIA AND I OPPOSE
THIS BILL THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
TOO MANY OTHERS IN OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE WILL BRING IT BACK
TO THE DICE MEMBERS QUESTIONS
COMMENTS [inaudible]
SEEING NONE -- SORRY.
WE'LL GO SENATE JACKSON AND
SENATOR GORGEOUS YES I'VE ALWAYS
WONDERED WHY PEOPLE NEED TO WEAR.
FOR MY MOTHER USED TO HAVE A FOR
MY GRANDMOTHER HAD A FOR TODAY
WE HAVE MATERIALS THAT CAN KEEP
YOU WARM WITHOUT USING FOR BUT
THAT BEING SAID -- I KNOW THAT
IN THE PARTICULARLY THE NATIVE
AMERICAN CULTURE THERE IS
SOMETHING MORE. TO THE PROCESS
AND WANTING TO WEAR FOR INTO THE
SLAUGHTER ANIMALS SO I'M
WONDERING HAVE YOU CONSIDERED
PERHAPS TAKING AN AMENDMENT THAT
WOULD.
OR IF YOU'VE ALREADY TAKEN A
BECAUSE I APOLOGIZE I'VE BEEN
ANOTHER COMMITTEE THAT
RECOGNIZES IN SOME INSTANCES
THERE IS A CULTURAL LARA
RELIGIOUS OR ANOTHER TRADITIONAL
ASPECT TO IT.
NOT THAT I WOULD NECESSARILY DO
THAT BUT I WANT TO RESPECT.
OTHER CULTURES WHERE THIS IS NOT
JUST SO MUCH TO SEE IF YOU CAN.
SHOWOFF YOUR FANCY FOR TO YOUR
FRIENDS -- THANK YOU SENATOR
THANK YOU FOR THE QUESTION -- A
SECTION SEE THREE SPECIFICALLY
EXAMS NATIVE AMERICAN --
ACTIVITIES OKAY I APPRECIATE
THAT AND WELL I APPRECIATE THAT
THERE MAY HAVE BEEN A TIME THERE
WAS A TIME WHEN. FOR DID PROTECT
PEOPLE AND KEEP THE MORMON I
SUPPORT THAT NOTION THAT WE
REALLY -- IN THOSE CIRCUMSTANCES
IT WOULD BE APPROPRIATE AGAIN I
JUST -- I FIND IT TROUBLESOME TO
THINK THE WE REALLY NEED TO TO
ENGAGE IN THIS KIND OF BEHAVIOR --
BUT THERE WAS ONE POINT THAT WAS
MADE BY THE OPPOSITION AYE I
WOULD LIKE YOU TO RESPOND TO THE
NOTION THAT THERE ARE.
IF YOU WILL GOOD GOOD ACTORS AND
BAD ACTORS IN THIS INDUSTRY AND
WHILE WOULD ONLY BE BANNING THIS
HEARING CALIFORNIA WHICH MEANS
THAT OTHER STATES COULD CONTINUE
WITH THIS BEHAVIOR -- THERE HAS
BEEN IF I UNDERSTOOD CORRECTLY A
HIGHER STANDARD OR FOR THOSE WHO
PARTICIPATE IN A PARTICULAR
INDUSTRY GROUP.
THAT WOULD BE THREATENED -- BY A
BY OUR EFFORT HERE EVEN THOUGH
I'D LIKE A THE FACT WERE FIRST
IN A LOT OF GREAT THINGS AND
LEAD THE COUNTRY.
I JUST WONDER IF THE THAT MIGHT
CREATE SOME KIND OF A COMPROMISE
SITUATION -- FOR FOR THOSE WHO
INSIST UPON.
UP PRODUCING -- FOR IF FOR THOSE
FOLKS WHO WERE TRYING TO DO IT
IN THE MOST HUMANE.
WAY POSSIBLE TO THE EXTENT THERE
IS A HUMANE WAY COULD YOU
RESPOND TO THAT CONCERT.
THANK YOU SENATOR IF I
UNDERSTAND THE COURT QUESTION
CORRECTLY IT'S ABOUT -- STILL BE
ABLE TO PRODUCE AND PURCHASE FOR
ON THE REST OF THE COUNTRY WHICH
IS CERTAINLY TRUE UNDER THIS
BILL I WOULD POINT OUT THAT WE
HAD A LOT OF THE SAME ARGUMENTS
ABOUT THE COSMETIC TESTING.
AND OTHER COSMETIC RELATED --
THE ISSUES AND WHAT HAPPENED WAS
INSTEAD OF PUSHING THOSE
INDUSTRIES OUT OF THE STATE
EIGHT OTHERSTATES AT THIS POINT
HAVE FOLLOW CALIFORNIA'S LEAD.
AND ADOPTED THE SAME POLICIES
I'M CREATING JUST NATURALLY MORE
OF A LEVEL PLAYING FIELD WE HAVE
ALSO HEARD THE SAME ARGUMENT
WHEN IT CAME TO GETTING CHICKENS
ARE A BEARING CHICKENS.
MORE ROOM AND GIVING FARM
ANIMALS ARE MORE HUMANE
STANDARDS AND THE CALIFORNIA
VOTERS WHEN THIS HAS GONE ON THE
BALLOT OVER AND OVER AGAIN HAVE
SAID.
YOU KNOW OUR CONCERN IS LESS
WITH THE REST OF THE COUNTRY BUT
WE WANT TO KNOW THAT IF WE
PURCHASE A PRODUCT IN CALIFORNIA.
THEN IT IS CRUELTY FREE AS
POSSIBLE I DON'T BELIEVE THAT WE
CAN.
WE CAN DO THAT WITH THIS
INDUSTRY GIVEN THE PLACES WERE A
LOT OF THESE PRODUCTS ARE
PRODUCED WHICH IS IN CHINA AS
THE NUMBER ONE PRODUCTION --
COUNTRY FOR FOR AND I WOULD.
IS SAY THAT IT'S VERY DIFFICULT
TO KNOW WHAT HAPPENS IN THOSE
COUNTRIES EVEN FOR APPLE WITH
THEIR PHONES WE'VE HEARD ABOUT A
LOT OF ABUSIVE WERE ABUSIVE
WORKPLACE ENVIRONMENT AND HERE
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT ANIMALS AND
TRYING TO POLICE THAT -- SO --
AND AND SECONDLY JUST BY THEIR
NATURE.
ANIMALS THAT ARE NOT
DOMESTICATED ANIMALS ARE WILD
ANIMALS ARE VERY DIFFICULT TO
KEEP INTACT CAPTIVITY.
I REPRESENT THE LA ZOO IN MY
DISTRICT THEY SPEND MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS A YEAR TRYING TO DO FOR
FILM AND FOR THOSE ANIMALS
BECAUSE THEIR WILD ANIMALS THAT
NEED TO MOVE THAT NEED TO ROME.
OTHERWISE THEY DO THIS FOR A
DISPLAY STRESSED BEHAVIOR WITH
THESE ANIMALS KEPT IN SMALL
CAGES THERE'S NO WAY TO DO THAT
IN A HUMANE WAY.
SO I GUESS THE THAT THE AND I
APOLOGIZE FOR NOT BEING CLEAR
AND THE QUESTION WAS SENT OUT MY
UNDERSTANDING WAS WAS IT AND
SOMEBODY TESTIFYING ABOUT THE
INTERNATIONAL STANDARDS THERE IS
A GROUP.
THAT ACTUALLY WOULD LIKE TO BE
AS HUMANE AS POSSIBLE IN THEIR
TREATMENT OF THESE ANIMALS SO I
THEY'RE SORT OF THE MID THE MID
WAY GROUP BETWEEN KNOLL.
OF PRODUCTION AND OR KILLING AND
TRYING TO BE POLITE ABOUT THIS
BUT AND IN DOING IT AS HUMANELY
AS POSSIBLE SO I MISUNDERSTOOD
THE QUESTION SO I WOULD SAY THAT
THE CONCERNS ABOUT FOR HAVE BEEN
REYES.
FOR DECADES NOW WE'VE HEARD WE
HAD ANTI FOR CAMPAIGNS IN THIS
COUNTRY FOR DECADES AND YET WE
DON'T HAVE THAT PROGRAM WE DON'T
HAVE IT THAT ASSURANCE WHY AT
THIS MOMENT ARE THEY OFFERING
THAT WHEN THEY'VE HAD FIFTY
YEARS OF PEOPLE RAISING CONCERNS
ABOUT.
FOR FROM THE DAYS THAT IT CAME
OUT THAT BABY SEALS WERE CLUBBED
TO DEATH UNTIL NOW.
IT WOULD HAVE BEEN GREAT IF
TWENTY YEARS AGO THAT WOULD HAVE
BEEN INSTITUTED AND EVERY FOR
THAT WAS PURCHASED IN CALIFORNIA
HAD THAT CERTIFICATION IT DIDN'T
AND SO WE ARE WE ARE TODAY.
AND I WOULD SAY THAT WE SHOULD
ACT ON THIS NOW THE WAY THAT LOS
ANGELES HAS AND SAN FRANCISCO
HAS AND BRING UNIFORMITY TO THIS
TO THE STATE.
JACKSON CENTER BORDERS.
GERMAN -- I THINK -- MY
COLLEAGUE FROM -- SANTA BARBARA
WAS GOING ON LINE OF QUESTIONING
THAT I INTENDED TO AS WELL --
MAYBE I'LL POSE MY QUESTION.
TO JOHN THAT TALKED ABOUT --
INTERNATIONAL STANDARDS FOR THE
HUMANE TREATMENT OF OF OF
ANIMALS I DON'T KNOW WHAT THE
ACTUAL TITLE IS.
BUT IS THERE NOT AN OPPORTUNITY
HERE.
FOR LEGISLATION TO BE AMENDED
THAT WOULD MANDATE -- THE
APPLICATION IMPLEMENTATION OF
THE STANDARDS IN SUCH A WAY THAT --
WOULD SATISFY THE CONCERNS OR
MOST OF THE CONCERNS RAISED.
ABOUT.
THE IN HUMANE TREATMENT OF
ANIMALS. TO ME I'LL SERVICE.
THE ANSWER IF I MAY.
THANK YOU SO THE THE FIRST
ANSWER THE QUESTION IS IS YES
THIS PROGRAM HAS A BIT BEEN
DEVELOPED OVER THE COURSE OF
LAST FOR FIVE YEARS AGAIN WITH
THE MAJOR BRANDS OF THE TABLE.
USING CURRENT INTERNATIONAL
STANDARDS BASED ON VETERINARY
SCIENCE IN THE TOOLS AVAILABLE
TO US TODAY AND THOSE ARE
CONTINUALLY EVOLVING AND THE
CONCEPT IS THAT THE
CERTIFICATION PROGRAM WOULD BE
SIMILARLY CONTINUALLY EVOLVING --
THE FOR THE THIRD PARTY
INDEPENDENT MONITORING AS I SAID
IS THE SAME PROGRAM THAT IS IN
PLACE FOR THE CATTLE INDUSTRY
THIS ACCEPTED.
PRETTY UNIVERSALLY AND IT IT
USES BLOCKCHAIN TECHNOLOGY SO
THAT THE PELTS OF A YOU GO TO
BUY GARMENT AND THAT G
DE UP OF A NUMBER OF PELTS
EVERYONE WILL HAVE A BAR CODE.
AND YOU CAN GO FIRST OF ALL THE
WAY BACK TO THE FARM TO
GUARANTEE THE FARMING PRACTICES
AND THE SUSTAINABLE PRODUCTION
THROUGH DRESSING AND DYING WHICH
BY THE WAY USES -- IF THE DOES
NOT USE THE CHEMICALS THEY SAY
IT DOESN'T USE VEGETABLE DYES SO
Y THE WHAT WE'VE HEARD FROM THE
AUTHOR AND FROM OTHERS IS THAT --
IT'S VERY DIFFICULT FROM --
THESE THIRD COUNTRIES -- BUT
SIMPLY WOULDN'T BE ALLOWED IN IF
THEY DIDN'T MEET SANDERS AND AND
THAT'S WHAT I'M OF THE TIME WHAT
I'M GETTING AT IS THAT YOU KNOW.
CERTAIN FURS ARE OF DUBIOUS
ORIGIN WE DON'T KNOW WHERE
THEY'RE FROM -- HOW THEY WERE --
PROCESS SO AND SO FORTH -- SO
WOULD NOT BE IN A MIDDLE POSES
TO THE AUTHOR.
I KNOW THAT MAYBE THEY SHOULD
HAVE BEEN DONE A WHILE BACK --
BUT IS THIS NOT ALSO A WAY
FORWARD OF FOR YOU TO SATISFY
SOME OF THE CONCERNS OF THE
CONSTITUENCY THAT CARES ABOUT
THIS ATTER PARTICULAR -- AND
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT STANDARDS --
MAYBE THIS WOULD BE IN A MORE
APPROPRIATE WAY FOR CALIFORNIA
TO MOVE THE NATION -- EN MANDATE
THAT THE IMPORTS ARE COMPLIANT
WITH INTERNATIONAL SET OF NORMS.
WOULD THAT NOT BE BETTER POLICY
THANK YOU SENATOR I APPRECIATE
THE QUESTION AND I REALLY
APPRECIATE THAT YOU ARE.
SORT OF HELP.
TRYING TO HELP -- MAKE SURE THAT --
THE ANIMALS ARE PROTECTED I
REALLY DO APPRECIATE THAT I'M
GONNA ASK THE HUMANE SOCIETY TO
RESPOND BECAUSE THEY'VE DEALT
WITH -- FOR MARK FOR AWHILE.
THANK YOU -- THE STANDARDS THAT
HE'S TALKING ABOUT ARE EXTREMELY
JUST SELF REGULATED -- IT'S
REALLY JUST A LOT OF MARKETING --
THAT GOES INTO IT.
THE THINGS THAT PEOPLE ARE MOST
CONCERNED ABOUT WHEN IT COMES TO
FOR FARMS ARE AN ELECTROCUTION
AND YOU CAN AS A GENTLEMAN -- IT
IS IT IS OKAY UNDER FOR MARK IN
OTHER THE BEST.
CERTIFIED FARMS OUT THERE THE
SAME WITH TRAPPING MEAN TRAPPING
IS A STEEL LOG STEEL JOE LEGAL
TRAP THAT HOLDEN ANIMAL FOR DAYS
THIS IS APPROVED UNDER FOR MARK.
AS WELL AS JUST AS ASSEMBLY
WOMAN FRIEDMAN MENTIONS I MEAN
THE PROBLEMS OF HAVING A ON
DOMESTICATED WILD ANIMAL IN A
CAGE -- THE JUST THE STRESS AND
THE FEAR THAT GOES ALONG WITH
THAT.
DIFFERENT FROM OTHER SUPPLY
CHAINS -- LIKE LEATHER AND SHEEP
SO LET'S LET'S ASSUME THAT.
ALL THESE MISS TREATMENTS OCCUR
IN OUR COMMON LET'S JUST ASSUME
THAT FOR A MOMENT.
WOULD IT NOT BE MORE HELPFUL.
TO CREATE A CALIFORNIA -- PIECE
OF LEGISLATION THAT GIVES MORE
TEETH.
MORE A MORE ROBUST SET OF
REGULATIONS TO A BODY THAT
ALREADY EXISTS BECAUSE WHAT I
HAVE BEEN ALSO HEARD IS.
WHAT IS THE ECONOMIC IMPACT --
FOR THIS LEGISLATION ON DOING --
THIS -- THIS AREA OF SALE --
BECAUSE NOW WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
YOU KNOW HAVING A STRONG
ECONOMIC IMPACT ON ON BUSINESSES --
SO WITHOUT KNOWING IN QUAN AND
HAVING SOMEONE QUANTIFY.
HOW MANY BUSINESSES MICHAEL
WONDER FOR THIS?
LIKE ARE WE JUST KIND OF WE
MISSING MISSING THAT THE BALL
HERE LOOK IT SEEMS AS IF THERE
THIS IS A WAY FORWARD -- WITHOUT.
HAVING OUT RIGHT BAN I CAN
QUANTIFY THE ECONOMIC STAKE SO
I'M SORRY WAS THAT A QUESTION
THE AUTHOR YOU KNOW MAYBE MAYBE
MAYBE IT'S NOT I JUST I THINK I
THINK -- IF THE EXAMPLES THAT
AND I'M LEARNING ABOUT THIS I
DON'T KNOW TOO MUCH ABOUT THE
THAT THE TREATMENT OF THESE
ANIMALS BUT IF IT IS BAD AS IT
SOUNDS.
AND THERE IS A REGULATORY
FRAMEWORK IN PLACE THAT NEEDS TO
BE REVAMPED OR MADE MORE ROBUST.
THAT COULD BE A WAY FORWARD
WITHOUT COMPLETELY ON DOING AN
INDUSTRY.
IT DOESN'T SHE AND I AM DOUBTFUL
THAT IT WOULD ACHIEVE THE
RESULTS THAT EVERYONE WANTS IF
THEY REALLY CAN'T GO TO ARIZONA
AND NEVADA.
AND PURCHASE THE SAME GOODS --
YOU'RE JUST TAKING THE
BUSINESSES OUT OF CALIFORNIA BUT
NOT THE ACTUAL TRIP -- END USER
LET ME JUST -- ALL THIS QUICKLY
SAY TWO THINGS FIRST OF ALL
THEY'RE NOT OFFERING A
CERTIFICATION THAT GIVES US
CONFIDENCE THAT THESE ANIMALS
WILL BE RAISED OR SLAUGHTERED
CRUELTY FREE AND I'M NOT SURE
THAT THE FURNITURE CAN'T DO THAT
OR IS PREPARED.
EVEN PUT THAT ON THE TABLE SO
THEY HAVEN'T COME TO US WITH
THAT SORT OF SET OF REGULATIONS
THAT YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT AS YOU
JUST HEARD.
THOSE TO THE GREGIS PRACTICES
CAN STILL CONTINUE EVEN UNDER
THE CERTIFICATION SECONDLY IN
TERMS OF ECONOMIC IMPACT.
WHO'S NOT BEEN IN THEROOM
ADVOCATING AGAINST THIS BILL OUR
OUR MAJOR RETAILERS.
WE HAVE NOT HEARD FROM
BLOOMINGDALE'S WE'VE NOT HEARD
FOR MACY'S WE'VE NOT HEARD FROM
ANY OF THESE STORED SAYING THAT
THIS IS A HARDSHIP FOR THEM
RIGHT NOW IN LOS ANGELES OR SAN
FRANCISCO OR THE OTHER CITIES
THAT DON'T ALLOW.
FOR YOU ALSO IF YOU ARE A FIRST
SIR SELLER YOU CAN STILL UNDER
THIS BILL SELL SHEARLING WHICH
COMES IN A VERY WIDE VARIETY OF
OF FOR TYPES AND COLORS AND
EVERYTHING ELSE.
PRODUCTS MADE OUT OF COW FOR AN
OTHER DOMESTICATED ANIMALS GOAT
SO THERE IS STILL ROOM FOR THOSE
SALES -- AND SO I I AGREE WITH
YOU WE HAVEN'T HEARD ABOUT
ECONOMIC IMPACT AND THAT'S
BECAUSE THIS IS NOT GOING TO
CAUSE A BIG ECONOMIC IMPACT ARE
THERE SOME FOR YEARS THAT YOU
KNOW WILL BE LIMITED IN WHAT
THEY SELL.
YES OF COURSE THERE WILL BUT WE
HAVE WE DO NOT HAVE A LINE OF
RETAILERS OUT THE DOOR TELLING
US THAT THIS IS GOING TO BE AT
ALL HARMFUL FOR THEM.
AND CLOTHING SALES IN LOS
ANGELES OUR BELIEVE ME I LIVE
THERE ARE STILL VERY STRONG.
SO THERE'S A WE ARE MOTION FROM
SENATOR JACKSON -- ANY OTHER
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS SEEING
NONE -- I'LL BE SUPPORTING THE
MEASURE TODAY -- AND JUST A
COUPLE BRIEF COMMENTS NOT TO
ARGUE YOUR POINTS.
BUT I DO USE THE INTERNATIONAL
CATTLE.
STANDARDS AS THE AS OUR GOLD
STANDARD TO ME I DON'T.
TRUST THE INTERNATIONAL BEEF
INDUSTRIES TREATING THEIR CATTLE
HUMANELY IN CHINA SO.
AND AND WHEN IT COMES TO
CANNABIS.
NO ONE DIES WHEN YOU HARVEST THE
CANNABIS PLANT NIGHT.
I APPRECIATE WHAT YOU'RE TRYING
TO DO IS FOR MARK -- BUT CAN WE
GET CONFIRMATION FOR THE RECORD
OF AROUND THE TECHNIQUES OF
TRYING TO BE APPLIED SO ANAL
EXECUTION ALLOWED AND STILL DRAW
TRAPPING ALLOWED.
THERE'S A VERY LONG LIST OF
VETERINARY APPROVED METHODS OF
EUTHANASIA FOR DIFFERENT SPECIES
IT'S DETERMINED BY SCIENCE.
MAY NOT SOUND GREAT TO US
SITTING IN THE ROOM BUT IT
RESULTS IN THE LEAST STRESS ON
THE ANIMAL AND THE QUICKEST
DEMISE FOR THE ANIMAL.
BUT SO THE ANSWER IS JUST YES ON
THOSE THOSE FRONTS.
THE FIRST ONE IS PRESCRIBED
PERSON FOR CERTAIN SPECIES VERY
LIMITED THE SECOND STILL PUBLIC
TRUST BEST MANAGED BY BEST
MANAGEMENT PRACTICES
INTERNATIONALLY DON'T ALLOW IT.
VERY GOOD WELL I I APPRECIATE
THE CONCERNS -- AND AND THE
CULTURAL SENSITIVITY I I ALSO
KNOW NOTED IN IN THAT SECTION
THREE AROUND NATIVE AMERICAN
USES ALSO SECONDHAND SO.
THOSE WHO STILL CULTURALLY
DESIRE TO HAVE THAT FASHION
OPTION I WOULDN'T UP FOR THAT --
BUT THOSE WHO DO.
OPT FOR IT I THINK THERE'S A
FAIR AMOUNT IN THE MARKET PLACE
THAT -- SHOULD HOPEFULLY SAYS
WHY THAT CULTURAL DESIRE -- AND
I THINK THAT WHAT WE BY IS.
OUR VALUES HOW WE SPEND OUR
MONEY IN THIS STATE AND WHAT OUR
LAWS ARE ARE HOW WE FEEL IS A
STATE ABOUT.
HOW WE TREAT ANIMALS AND THOSE
WITHOUT?
LOBBYISTS AND WHO HAVE NO VOICES --
YOU KNOW WHAT THE REST THE WORLD
DOES HOPEFULLY THEY FOLLOW SUIT --
BUT WE CAN ONLY DO WHAT'S IN OUR
POWER TODAY SO I APPRECIATE YOUR
BRINGING THIS FORD -- AND WITH
THAT IT ALLOW YOU TO CLOSE.
I WOULD JUST LIKE TO VERY
BRIEFLY RESPOND TO THE GENTLEMAN
FROM THE BLACK CHAMBERS
ARGUMENTS -- AND I WOULD JUST
POINT YOU ALL TO THE COMMENTS
THAT THE IMMEDIATE PAST CHAIR OF
THE LEGISLATIVE BLACK CAUCUS
WHAT HE THOUGHT CHRIS HOLDEN
WHAT HIS RESPONSE WAS WHEN HE
HEARD THE SAME ARGUMENTS.
IN THE ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE WHICH
WAS THAT HE FOUND THOSE
ARGUMENTS TO BE DEEPLY OFFENSIVE.
AND IF ANYBODY IS INTERESTED IN
HEARING HIS RATIONALE ABOUT THAT
I DO POINT YOU TO HIS VERY
COMPELLING AND VERY OUTRAGE
TESTIMONY -- THEM WITHOUT I
WOULD REQUEST FULLY REQUEST AN
AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SO THEM THE MOTION IS
DO PASS. TO JUDICIARY -- PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL CENTERS STERN AYE
STERN I'D JONES NO JONES NO
ALLEN.
BURGESS.
FORGES NO COVER EURO HERTZBERG
HUESO JACKSON JACKSON NINE MONEY.
MONEY NINE THE HAS THREE IT'S ON
CALL OKAY SO WE WILL LEAVE THAT
MEASURE ON CALL FOR THE ABSENT
MEMBERS THAT'S A THREE TWO VOTE
RIGHT NOW.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TEST
[inaudible]
YEAH -- ROLL OVER THE REMAINING
READ THAT WITH ME I'D BE HAPPY
TO THERE SHOULD BE.
A LITTLE BIT HAPPIER AND IS MORE
EASILY DECIDES. FOR CGA SO
[inaudible]
OFFICES YEAH [inaudible]
SO [inaudible]
TRY.
TO WHEN WAS THE AND THE BILL AS
WELL -- ALL RIGHT.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS -- FIRST OF ALL AS WE
DISCUSSED LAST WEEK I'M
ACCEPTING THE MODIFICATION OF
THE SUGGESTED A MOMENT THIS REAL
QUICK WHICH WHICH BILL I'M SORRY.
ELEVEN ELEVEN OKAY VERY GOOD SO
SO MEMBERS OFFICE ABOUT DOOR
CREATED SO THAT'S A THAT'S ITEM.
TEN YES SO -- ELEVEN ELEVEN YES
I'M ACCEPTING THE MODIFICATION
OF THE SUGGESTED AMENDMENT ON
PAGE FOUR OF THE ANALYSIS -- AB
ELEVEN ELEVEN CREATES A NEW
OFFICE ABOUT A RECREATION FOR
CALIFORNIA WITHIN THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE.
THIS IS BECAUSE WE RECOGNIZE
THAT OUTDOOR RECREATION IS A
TREMENDOUS OPPORTUNITY NAMIK
DRIVER IN OUR STATE AND COULD BE
EVEN MORE SO IN SOME OF OUR
RURAL AREAS.
THAT REALLY NEED THE ECONOMIC
STIMULUS BUT DON'T HAVE THE
ABILITY TO PROMOTE THEIR AREAS
AS WELL WE HAVE STATED IN THE
ASSEMBLY AND THE SENATE THAT WE
REALLY WANT TO GET DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES INTO THE OUTDOORS.
AND THIS BILL WOULD HELP
COORDINATE ALL OF THE STATE'S
EFFORTS TO DO THAT RIGHT NOW WE
HAVE DIFFERENT OFFICES FROM FISH
AND WILDLIFE -- TO YOU NATURAL
RESOURCES THERE ARE MANY
DIFFERENT STATE AGENCIES THAT
ALL OUR TASK WOULD SORT OF
SIMILAR -- GOALS BUT THERE IS NO
CENTRAL COORDINATION BETWEEN
THOSE OFFICES TO WORK WITH
PRIVATE INDUSTRY TO GET PEOPLE
OUT.
OUTDOORS RECREATION -- WE ARE
BRINGING OUR WITNESSES IN RIGHT
NOW BUT WE HAVE SOME REALLY
GREAT WITNESSES FROM ARI I AND
FROM THE CALIFORNIA OUTDOOR
RECREATION PARTNERSHIP.
AND THEY'RE HERE TO TELL YOU WHY
THEY THINK THIS BILL IS A GREAT
IDEA.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLYMEMBERS AND
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIMELY
APPEARANCE WITNESSES IN SUPPORT --
TWO MINUTES EACH [inaudible]
RIGHT.
GOOD AFTERNOON SENATOR STERN AND
MEMBERS ON KATIE HAWKINS ON THE
CALIFORNIA ORGANIZER FOR THE
OUTDOOR ALLIANCE I'M HERE TO
EXPRESS OUR STRONG SUPPORT FOR A
BI.
ELEVEN ELEVEN OTHER ALLIANCE IS
A NONPROFIT COALITION MEMBERS
BASED ORGANIZATION INCLUDING
ACCESS FUND.
AMERICAN WHITEWATER SURFRIDER
FOUNDATION THE INTERNATIONAL
MOUNTAIN BIKE ASSOCIATION AND
OTHERS WE REPRESENT THE FAST
GROWING HUMAN POWERED OUTDOOR
RECREATION COMMITTEE AND THE
INTERESTS OF MILLIONS OF
CALIFORNIANS.
WHO CLIMBED PADDLE MOUNTAIN
BIKES BACK COUNTRY SKI SNOWBOARD?
AND SNOWSHOEING ENJOY THE
CULTURE RECREATION WATER SINCE
NETSCAPE THE CALIFORNIA.
HOW TO ALLIANCE REPRESENTS
TWENTY THREE THOUSAND MEMBERS
PLUS DOZENS OF GRASS ROOTS
GROUPS?
OUR MEMBERS INCLUDE THE
SURFRIDER ADS IN THE BEACH THE
ROCK CLIMBER IN INYO NATIONAL
FOREST FROM THE PEDDLER AT THE
AMERICAN RIVER. TO THE MOUNTAIN
BIKER WHISKEYTOWN NATIONAL
RECREATION AREA.
OUR MEMBERS PARTNERS IN LOCAL
GROUPS SORRY.
I KNOW FIRST HAND THAT THE MANY
CHALLENGES INFERIORS TRYING TO
WORK ACROSS MULTIPLE AGENCIES
TEMPER PUBLIC ACCESS TO CREATE
VOLUNTEER STEWARDSHIP PROGRAMS
TO ADDRESS THE INFRASTRUCTURE.
NEEDS ON PUBLIC LANDS AND
MAINTAIN TRAILS THEY NEED YOUR
HELP.
CREATING IN A CALIFORNIA STATE
OFFICE OF RECREATION WILL BE A
HUGE STEP FOR TODAY ENSURING
SUSTAINABLE AND ECO NOT.
EQUITABLE RECREATION
OPPORTUNITIES FOR CALIFORNIANS
FROM A FISCAL STANDPOINT THIS IS
A NECESSARY INVESTMENT.
OUR PUBLIC LANDS AND WATERS
ALMOST HALF OF WHICH ARE
FEDERALLY MANAGED AND HAVE
HISTORICALLY BEEN MANAGED WITH
MINIMAL COORDINATION WITH STATE
AGENCIES IN SACRAMENTO.
ARE THE INFRASTRUCTURE THAT
SUPPORTS OUR NINETY TWO BILLION
DOLLAR OUTDOOR RECREATION
ECONOMY THE SINGING SIX HUNDRED
NINETY ONE THOUSAND DIRECT JOBS.
IN GENERATED SIX POINT TWO
BILLION IN STATE AND LOCAL TAX
REVENUE.
THE ALTAR REGARD REPRESENT A
MAJORITY OF OUR CARBON
SEQUESTERING RESOURCES IN A
STATE WHERE WE HAVE MADE CLIMATE
CHANGE MITIGATION FORCE HEALTH
AND RESILIENCE AND FUNDAMENTAL
PRIORITIES.
CALIFORNIA STATE OFFICE OF
RECREATION WILL BRING
UNNECESSARY AND OVERDUE HOLISTIC
PERSPECTIVE TO STATEWIDE PUBLIC
LANDS AND RECREATION RESOURCE
MANAGEMENT.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR ATTENTION
PLAYING YOUR SUPPORT ON AB
ELEVEN ELEVEN THANK YOU MUCH.
WELCOME MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
ON MARK BREAKER DIRECTOR OF
GOVERNMENT AND COMMUNITY FAIRS
FOR ARI I COOPER.
AND WE STRONGLY SUPPORT AB.
ELEVEN ELEVEN REI'S BEEN A
CALIFORNIA BUSINESS SINCE WE
OPENED OUR SECOND EVER STORE IN
BERKELEY IN.
NINETEEN SEVENTY FIVE WE NOW
HAVE TWENTY EIGHT STORES TWO
THOUSAND EMPLOYEES AND ALMOST
FOUR MILLION COOP MEMBERS IN
CALIFORNIA.
WE ALSO GIVE BACK LATELY SORRY I
HIS GIVEN ABOUT A MILLION
DOLLARS PER YEAR TO DOZENS OF
NOT FOR PROFIT NOT FOR PROFITS.
INCLUDING FRIENDS OF THE LA
RIVER.
AND NGOS THAT ARE DIVERSIFYING
THE OUTDOORS LIKE AFTER AFRO AND
LATINO OUTDOORS.
OUR SHARED LOVE OF THE OUTDOORS
IS CENTRAL TO CALIFORNIA'S ANTI
REI'S HERITAGE AND TO OUR FUTURE.
THERE'S EXTRAORDINARY DEMAND FOR
THE OUTDOORS ACCORDING TO ONE
STUDY 56% OF CALIFORNIANS GET
OUTSIDE AT LEAST.
GET INTO THE OUTDOORS AT LEAST
ONCE PER YEAR.
BUT WE NEED TO DO BETTER.
KIDS NOWADAYS SPEND SEVEN HOURS
A DAY IN FRONT OF SCREENS ADULTS
SPEND ELEVEN HOURS A DAY IN
FRONT OF SCREENS.
MEANWHILE HEALTH CARE COSTS ARE
APPROACHING 18% OF GDP.
RATING OPPORTUNITIES TO GET INTO
THE OUTDOORS IS GOOD FOR OUR
WELL BEING.
IT'S ALSO GOOD FOR JOBS AND FOR
THE ECONOMY.
OUTDOOR COMPANIES I SUBMIT ARE
PART OF CALIFORNIA'S INNOVATION
AND GREEN JOBS MOVEMENT.
THE RECREATION OFFICE THAT
YOU'RE CONSIDERING WILL
CULTIVATE THOSE INNOVATORS HELP
FILL TALENT PIPELINES AND OF ALL
OF THESE COMPANIES INTERNATIONAL
BRANDS.
MOREOVER CALIFORNIA HAS GREAT
RURAL TOWNS WITH RECREATION
POTENTIAL THAT'S NOT FULLY
REALIZED THIS OFFICE WOULD HELP
THESE TOWNS REACH THEIR
POTENTIAL.
FINALLY THE OFFICE WOULD HELP
THE STATE AGENCIES TO CARE ABOUT
THE OUTDOORS WORK BETTER
TOGETHER.
WE WOULD CREATE GOVERNMENTAL
EFFICIENCIES FROM HEALTH CARE
AGENCIES TO EDUCATION THE
COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT TOURISM
AND ENVIRONMENTAL AFFAIRS PEOPLE
UNDERSTAND THE VALUE OF TIME
OUTDOORS.
THIS OFFICE WOULD MAKE SURE THAT
THOSE AGENCIES ARE COORDINATED
AND GETTING THE MAXIMUM SOCIAL
ENVIRONMENTAL AND ECONOMIC
BENEFIT FROM TIME OUTDOORS.
THANK YOU FOR SUPPORTING AB ONE
ELEVEN THANK YOU VERY MUCH OTHER
ELEVEN OUR MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
MY NAME IS MERION WARMER DAM ON
BEHALF OF RURAL COUNTIES IF I
MIGHT TAKE ONE ADDITIONAL
COMMENT.
I WOULD LIKE TO EXPRESS OUR
APPRECIATION TO THE AUTHOR FOR
GIVING LOCAL GOVERNMENTS AN
OPPORTUNITY TO ADVISE THE THE
NEW OFFICE PROSPECTIVELY WE
BELIEVE THAT LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
HAVE A REAL KEY INTERESTING
ECONOMIC SUCCESS.
IN MANY OF OUR COUNTIES AS IT
RELATES TO TOURISM SO THANK YOU.
THANK.
VANESSA GONZALEZ ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA STATE PARKS
FOUNDATION IN SUPPORT.
NATALIE NEXT ON BEHALF OF
COMMUNITY NATURE CONNECTION --
MID PENINSULA REGION OPEN SPACE
JERKS MAGE MID PENINSULA
REGIONAL OPEN SPACE DISTRICT AND
LOS ANGELES NEIGHBORHOOD MY
INTEREST IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
GOOD AFTERNOON MEMBERS ON A
RECALL MASTER O NOT A WITH THE
TRUST FOR PUBLIC LAND. NINETY
BILLION PLUS INDUSTRY TO SERVICE
THIS ATTENTION APPRECIATE THE
BILL THANK YOU.
HELLO NOT HER MOMMA ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA RECREATION PARK
DISTRICTS IN SUPPORT THANKS SO
MUCH.
ALRIGHT SEEN NO OTHERS IN
SUPPORT ANY OPPOSITION
[inaudible]
SEEING.
NINE I HAVE TO STEP OUT SOME TO
MAKE ONE BRIEF COMMENT AND HAND
THE GAVEL TO MY VICE CHAIR --
APPRECIATE YOU BRING A BILL FOR
THANK YOU FOR ACCEPTING
AMENDMENTS MY QUESTION WAS TO TO
OUR INDUSTRY PARTNERS YOU KNOW
WE WE STRUGGLE THIS YEAR -- TO
GET ANY FUNDING FOR COMMUNITY
ACCESS AND AND FAILED IN THAT
EFFORT IN THE BUDGET AT A PROP
SIXTY EIGHT OTHERWISE WE JUST
HELD A SURF SUMMIT -- IN MY
DISTRICT OVER THE WEEKEND WHERE.
ABOUT A HUNDRED KIDS FROM ALL
OVER LOS ANGELES SHOWED UP AT
THE BEACH FOR THE VERY FIRST
TIME IN THEIR ENTIRE LIVES --
BUT THERE WAS NO MONEY TO DO
THAT WE HAD TO SCRAMBLE TOGETHER
A BUNCH OF VOLUNTEERS AND GET IT
YOU KNOW SEARCH FOR THE CITY TO
SPONSOR.
I'M JUST TRYING TO GET A SENSE
FROM INDUSTRY WHAT DO YOU ALL
ALREADY INVESTING IN IMPROVING
THIS ACCESS WITHOUT SOME NEW
OFFICER PUBLIC FUNDS HOW MUCH IS
BEING INVESTED.
INTO BRINGING ACCESS TO THOSE
WHO LACK IT TO THESE OUTDOOR
RECREATION OPPORTUNITIES NOW IN
CALIFORNIA GIVE IT. TO A BALL
PARKER SENSE OF SORT OF WHAT
WHAT YOU ALL ARE DOING EITHER AT
OUR YEAH YOU'RE BORN BROADLY.
I CAN SPEAK FOR ARE A I AND I I
DO KNOW THAT THE INDUSTRY IS
MADE UP OF VERY -- A WIDE ARRAY
OF COMPANIES MANY OF WHICH ARE
SMALL AND DO THEIR BEST TO BE
PHILANTHROPIC.
ARI I MIGHT BE ONE OF THE BIGGER
COMPANIES OR ANNUAL
PHILANTHROPIC BUDGET IS EIGHT
MILLION DOLLARS WHICH I OVERSEE.
AND IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN OUR NET
NET BOTTOM LINE AFTER DIVIDEND
WAS FORTY MILLION DOLLARS IN
PROFIT SO OUR PHILANTHROPY
AMOUNTS -- 220% OF OUR PROFITS.
WE FEEL THAT'S FAIRLY
PHILANTHROPIC NO I'M JUST WOULD
YOU INVEST IN CALIFORNIA IS WHAT
I'M CALIFORNIA ARE  NEW
INVESTMENT IS ABOUT A MILLION
DOLLARS.
THAT IN ON THE PHILANTHROPIC
SIDE CORRECT SO ADDED THE EIGHT
ABOUT EIGHT TO THAT AND WHAT
WHAT KIND OF WORK IS THAT.
SO TRADITIONALLY ARI I SPENT A
LOT OF DOLLARS ON STEWARDSHIP
TRAIL MAINTENANCE TRAIL
DEVELOPMENT.
BUT WE'RE ALSO -- AND SO FOR
EXAMPLE ONE OF THE PROJECTS WERE
SUPER EXCITED ABOUT IS
RECLAIMING THE LA RIVER -- BUT
INCREASINGLY WERE ALSO INVESTING
AND ACCESS. FOR PEOPLE WHO ARE
LESS WELL REPRESENTED IN THE
OUTDOORS AND SO WE'VE GOT A AT
LEAST A HALF DOZEN PARTNERSHIPS
IN THE STATE THAT -- GO TO BRING
DIVERSE COMMUNITIES INTO THE
OUTDOORS ARE UNDER REPRESENTED
COMMITTEES AND THE OUTDOORS
EXCELLENT YEAH NO I RESENT TH
HEADWATERS OF THE LA RIVER IN
CANOGA PARK AND NO ONE EVER GOES
THERE.
pCERTAINLY NEEDED SO WE
APPRECIATE THAT GIVE A SENSE
FROM BROADER INDUSTRY.
WELL FRIENDLY NOW PER LINES
PERSPECTIVE WE'RE WORKING WITH
LAND MANAGERS AND RIGHT NOW WE
HAVE THIS YEAR'S SO QUIET FORCE
PLANNING THAT'S COMING TOGETHER.
AND WE'RE IN THIRTY LANGUAGE
WE'RE MOBILIZING OUR
CONSTITUENTS TO HELP.
MAKE SURE THAT THERE'S MORE
LANGUAGE REGARDING ACCESS AND
EQUITY IN PROGRAMS TO SUPPORT
THAT ON BECAUSE WE KNOW IN ORDER
FOR OUR OUR OUR INDUSTRY TO GROW --
WE NEED TO GET MORE STORAGE AND
CONSERVATIONISTS INTO PUBLIC
LANDS AND SO PERMITTED OUTDOOR
LIGHTS PERSPECTIVE WE ARE USING
OUR TIME RESOURCES ARE
VOLUNTEERS ARE STEWART'S TO HELP
BE A PART OF THAT DECISION
MAKING AND POLICIES.
GIVE A SENSE OF TOTAL AMOUNT
INVESTED IN CALIFORNIA IT I
DON'T HAVE A DOLLAR AMOUNT SIR
NOW.
SO.
I'LL STEP AWAY NOW BUT I I
APPRECIATE THE THE THE THE
RATIONALE THE AMENDMENT.
WAS TO REALLY TRY TO LOOK FOR
THOSE PUBLIC PRIVATE
PARTNERSHIPS TO MOVE THIS
FORWARD BECAUSE WE KEEP RUNNING
AND IMPACTS ON STATE DOLLARS
SPECIALLY BOND DOLLARS.
RIGHT TO DO THE SOFT THE SOFT
ACTIVE THE TRANSPORTATION THE
PERSONNEL THE IN THEM -- THAT'S
BEEN AN ONGOING CHALLENGE SO I'M
HOPING THAT THIS OFFICE IS
REALLY GOING TO BE A HUB TO
BRING THE FULL ECONOMIC POWER
THE OUTDOOR RECREATION INDUSTRY
TO BEAR AND THEN WE'LL SORT OF
TO LOOK AT GAP FILLING RIGHT O
SEE OKAY STATE'S GOT BOND
DOLLARS HERE BUT MAYBE.
WE CAN NOT JUST HAVE KIDS GO TO
THE BEACH FOR ONE DAY A YEAR BUT
ACTUALLY HAVE A CAMP THAT THEIR
SCHOLARSHIPS AND THEY CAN SHOW
UP EVERY EVERY DAY YOU KNOW FOR
A WHOLE SUMMER OR YOU KNOW WHAT
WHETHER THEY'RE OUT IN.
THE SALINAS VALLEY YOUR CENTRAL
COAST WHEREVER MAY BE SO --
APPRECIATE YOU TO THINKING ABOUT
BUILDING THAT ARCHITECTURE AND
LOOK FORWARD TO THAT ENGAGEMENT
AFFORD AND WITH THAT I'M GONNA
HAND THE GALLON THE VICE CHAIR
AND STEPPED OUT FOR JUST A SEC --
YOU SUPPORTING YEAH I'LL BE
SUPPORTING THE BILL AND AND THEN
WE WILL TAKE A RECESS BUT I WILL
BE BACK IN JUST. THREE MINUTES
[inaudible]
THEIR MONEY.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR I
APPRECIATE YOUR BRINGING THIS
FORWARD.
KIND OF FOLLOWING UP ON THOSE
QUESTIONS.
HOW DO YOU SEE AS THE AUTHOR HOW
DO YOU SEE THIS OFFICE?
HAVING AN INTENTIONAL.
COMMITMENT TO INVOLVING.
YOUTH AND FAMILIES WHO HAVEN'T
TRADITIONALLY BEEN.
MAYBE MIDDLE OR HIGHER LEVEL
INCOME TO TAKE ADVANTAGE OF
OUTDOOR RECREATIONAL SPORTING
ACTIVITIES YEAH THAT IS
CERTAINLY THE INTENT AND PART OF
THE MANDATE OF THE OFFICE IS TO
BUILD ON THE DIRECTION THAT THE
LEGISLATURE HAS SENT WHICH IS
BRING DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES --
INTO THE OUTDOORS SO THAT'S A
BIG PART OF WHY I THINK WE NEED
THIS OFFICE BECAUSE WE REALLY
NEED THAT COORDINATION.
WITH OUR OWN STATE AGENCIES AND
ALSO WITH INDUSTRY TO DO THAT I
WOULD THINK IS THIS MOVES
FORWARD.
HAVING THAT INTENTIONALITY
REFLECTED ALSO MAY BE IN A%
CONVENTIONAL ADVISORY.
COMMITTEE -- THAT HAS.
NOT A FORMULA -- QUOTA BIT
INTENTIONAL INCLUSION OF
PREVIOUSLY UNDER REPRESENTED
COMMUNITIES IN OUTDOOR
RECREATION.
I KNOW THIS IS THE POLICY
COMMITTEE I'M JUST ANY THOUGHTS
ON FUNDING FOR SOMETHING LIKE
THIS.
A THE COST TO ESTABLISH AN YOU
KNOW I I COME I COME FROM LOCAL
GOVERNMENT AND YOU KNOW I I WAS
ELECTED TO LOCAL GOVERNMENT
RIGHT BEFORE THE RECESSION.
AND DURING THE RECESSION I HAD A
ARGUED -- YOU KNOW SUCCESSFULLY
IN MY CITY THAT THE BEST WAY WE
COULD SPEND OUR MONEY WAS ON
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT AND IT PAID
OFF THEIR DIVIDENDS THAT CAME
BACK TO THE CITY WITH SALES TAX
AND PEOPLE MOVING IN AND I
BELIEVE THE SAME THING I THINK
MONEY SPENT ON ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT.
IS MONEY WELL SPENT BECAUSE IT
COMES BACK TO THE STATE AND WE
HAVE HEARD FROM A LOT OF OUR
ROLE REPRESENTATIVES THAT THEY
HAVE AMAZING OUTDOOR.
AMENITIES IN THEIR DISTRICTS AND
THEIR SUFFERING IN THEIR
DISTRICTS ECONOMICALLY BUT BUT
THERE'S NO PROMOTION SORT OF
STATEWIDE. FOR THEM SO YOU KNOW
I REPRESENT GRAVERT PARK WE HAVE
NO SHORTAGE OF PEOPLE.
FROM ALL OVER THE COUNTRY
RUNNING AROUND GRIFFITH PARK BUT
IF YOU ASK THOSE SAME PEOPLE
WHAT WHERE DO YOU GO WHITE WATER
RAFTING WHAT ABOUT THE
STANISLAUS WHAT ABOUT.
WHERE THAT PICTURE WAS PAINTED
THEY HAVE NO IDEA BECAUSE WE
HAVEN'T TOLD THEM SO WE CAN
BRING THAT SAID THAT SAME
TOURISM LEVEL ALL ACROSS THE
STATE?
AND WE CAN HELP PROP UP AREAS
THAT RIGHT NOW WE'RE SUFFERING
ECONOMICALLY.
GREAT WELL I APPRECIATE YOUR
WORK ON THIS -- YOU MIGHT
CONSIDER SO TO TAX THAT WOULD
GENERATE A LOT OF REVENUES.
THAT'S A GREAT IDEA WE WOULD
LOVE TO A TO IN THIS PROMOTES
COMMUNITY PUBLIC HEALTH SO KEEP
IN MIND.
THANK YOU.
THE END WITH THAT I I WOULD SAY --
I WOULD RECOMMEND YOU NOT DO
THAT RIGHT NOW.
I I ACTUALLY HAVE -- TWO ISSUES
I I KIND OF SAW THIS A LITTLE
BIT DIFFERENTLY THAN THE
CONVERSATION IS GOING AND I
APOLOGIZE FOR MISSING -- SOME OF
THE TESTIMONY BUT THIS I SEE
THIS IS A REALLY IMPORTANT ROLE
ECONOMIC.
OPPORTUNITY BILL AND WHEN I WAS
IN THE ASSEMBLY AND I HAD A
SELECT COMMITTEE ON ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT AND INVESTMENT ROW
CALIFORNIA I THOUGHT WE'D BE
LOOKING AT TOURISM.
NOT BECAUSE TERRACE.
COMMON THEY SPEND MONEY AND THEY
GO AWAY AND THEY NORMALLY DON'T
CAUSE ANY PROBLEMS AND THAT'S
WHAT.
REALLY -- SMALL GROW COMMUNITIES
NEED DESPERATELY NEED -- AND I
IN THE SENATE DISTRICT HAVE ONE
OF THE LARGEST WETLANDS IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND IT'S IT
IS A COMBINATION OF FEDERAL
STATE AND PRIVATE LANDS.
AND YOU WOULDN'T KNOW IT
TRAVELING ON I..
FIVE GOING FROM LA TO WHEREVER
YOU'RE GOING SO -- SO I REALLY
THINK THIS IS THIS IS IMPORTANT --
AND THE MORE THAT WE CAN INCLUDE
LOCAL GOVERNMENT IN SOME OF THE
DISCUSSIONS SO THAT WE CAN
IDENTIFY GATEWAYS IDENTIFY STOPS --
YOU KNOW TEN THINGS YOU CAN DO
TO SEE -- UP WILDLIFE BACK THOSE
KINDS OF THINGS WOULD BE
TERRIFIC BUT ALSO -- SO FACILITY
SIGNAGE YOU KNOW ACCESS ALL OF
THAT IS REALLY IMPORTANT BUT I
ALSO -- THOUGHT THAT IT MIGHT
MAKE SENSE. TO TO HOUSE IT
EITHER AGO BIZZARE VISIT
CALIFORNIA AS OPPOSED TO JUST
STICKING IT IN THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE THAT IT'S RELATED TO
SOMETHING THAT IS.
THAT IS -- ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT --
BUT IT'S JUST IT'S JUST MY MY
OPINION A LOT OF TIMES WE WE
JUST PUT THINGS IN THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE AND THEN --
AND BECAUSE IT KIND OF MAKES YOU
THINK IT'S NEAR AND DEAR TO THE
GOVERNOR'S HEART BUT BUT
SOMETIMES I THINK IT IT DOESN'T
MAKE SENSE TO HOOK IT INTO OTHER
THINGS THAT ARE GOING ON SUCH AS
MY TWO CENTS WORTH I THINK IT'S
AN IT'S A REALLY.
INTERESTING.
OPPORTUNITIES TO DO A BUNCH OF
THINGS AND AND I AM CONCERNED
THAT ULTIMATELY ABOUT HOW IT'S
FUNDED BUT I THINK IT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT TO THE STATE.
THANK YOU I APPRECIATE THAT I I
WILL TO SAY WE'RE GOING TO DO
NEXT TO GOVERNMENT ORGANIZATION
SO WE'RE HAPPY TO CONTINUE THE
CONVERSATION ABOUT THE BEST
PLACE TO DAMASCUS.
THAT'S GREAT THANK YOU
[inaudible]
YEAH YEAH.
I AM ON GEO SO -- AND I'M I'M
SUPPORTING THE BILL TODAY.
TOO AND IT JUST A COUPLE
THOUGHTS AND I HADN'T THOUGHT
ABOUT THAT I THOUGHT IT WAS
GOING FOR SOME REASON I THOUGHT
IT WAS GOING IN THE GO HIS
OFFICE BUT I THINK THERE'S A
CALIFORNIA MY LIVING BETTER.
BUT EITHER ONE I THINK IT'S A
GOOD IDEA SO WE MIGHT CONSIDER
THAT AS A GHOST NGO I WOULD
IMAGINE GOING TO GO TO
PREPARATIONS AFTER GEO -- WHICH
AMAZON PROVISIONS.
SO THAT THE COUPLE CONCERNS --
AND COMMENTS NO NOT NO SPECIFIC
QUESTIONS REALLY BUT THE FUNDING
HAS BEEN BROUGHT UP -- YOU ALSO
GOING FORWARD HOW THAT'S YOU
KNOW GOING TO BE HANDLED
OBVIOUSLY IS A CONCERN ALL THOSE
OF US OF SPOKEN ABOUT IT --
ACCESS -- I THINK THAT'S A A
GREAT GOAL OF THE BILL IN THE
OFFICE -- ONE OF THE THINGS THAT
IS IMPORTANT TO ME YOU MENTIONED
HUMAN ACTS THAT HUMAN POWERED --
OPPORTUNITIES WHICH I'M A PART
OF THAT WITH MY MOUNTAIN BIKING --
SO SENDING ABOUT MAKING
CESSATION IN A SAN DIEGO -- AND
I'VE MOUNTAIN BKE DOLLAR
CALIFORNIA'S SAYS HI BY THE WAY --
GOOD AT AND BUT AND I RAISES
CONCERN WHEN I MET WITH THE
PROPONENTS A COUPLE MONTHS AGO
I'M ALSO YOU KNOW AN IMPORTANT.
THING TO ME IS MOTORIZED ACCESS
AS WELL.
WHICH I KNOW THAT'S NOT PART OF
YOUR PROMOTION O THIS -- I DID
POINT OUT TO THE PROPONENTS THAT
YOU KNOW THOSE OF US THAT ARE IN
THE MOTORIZED ACCESS ALSO SPEND
MONEY AT ARI I A LOT OF IT AND
OTHER PLACES.
I TO GET OUR EQUIPMENT SO.
NOT SO MUCH A CONCERN WITH THIS
BILL -- BUT MOVING FORWARD WITH
THE OFFICE IT WOULD BE I I WOULD
HAVE A PROBLEM IF THE OFFICE
EVOLVED INTO SOMETHING THAT.
WAS PROMOTING AND PROTECTING
HUMAN POWERED ACCESS AT THE
EXPENSE OF MOTORIZED ACCESS THAT
WOULD AND I THINK THAT THOSE TWO
THINGS CAN LIVE.
IN HARMONY -- THEY DO NOW AND SO
I'M JUST REYES AS A CONCERN
MOVING FORWARD IF THIS BECOMES
LAW BECOMES A THING -- THAT
WOULD BE SOMETHING I WOULD BE
LOOKING OUT FOR AS THE OFFICE
INVOLVED -- AND BECAUSE I KNOW
THAT THERE'S YOU KNOW --
INTEREST GROUPS IN IN CALIFORNIA
THAT WANT TO ELIMINATE MOTORIZED
ACCESS A LOT OF AREAS THAT
ALREADY HAVE IT.
AND THAT WOULD BE SOME THAT
WOULD BE CONCERN TO ME -- AND
THEN IT TALKING ABOUT -- FOR
LACK OF A VERY SPREADING THE USE
OF OUR OUR PARKS IN CALIFORNIA
THAT'S A BIG DEAL YOU KNOW WHEN
I MOVED. TO CALIFORNIA NINETEEN
SEVENTY EIGHT CALIFORNIA WAS THE
SHINING EXAMPLE OF STATE PARKS --
THROUGHOUT THE COUNTRY NICE I
STILL THINK IT.
IS AND THEN WE'VE GOT A LOT OF
STATE PARKS THAT ARE -- OVER
USED AND THEN.
AT TO THE POINT I THINK ONE WE
WERE MAKING -- YOU KNOW TEN
MILES AWAY WE'VE GOT PARKS IT
ARGUES HARDLY AT ALL THERE'S
CAMPGROUNDS IN MY DISTRICT.
THAT ARE -- BEAUTIFUL
CAMPGROUNDS HAVE FIRINGS --
VAULT TOILETS WATER HOOKUPS AND
YOU GO IN THERE AND ONE CAMPSITE
MIGHT BE TAKEN AND THAT'S JUST
BECAUSE NOBODY'S PROMOTING THAT
PARTICULAR PARK TO BE AND IT'S
FREE -- NOBODY'S.
PROMOTING A PARTICULAR PARK TO
BE USED SO I REALLY APPRECIATE
THAT BEING ONE OF THE FOCUSES OF
THIS IDEA.
AND THAT'S ALL I HA IN YOUR
WELCOME TO RESPOND ANY OF THAT
ARE THOSE ARE JUST COMMENTS THE
OF THING THAT I HAD I APPRECIATE
THE COMMENTS AS SOMEONE WHO WHEN
I GO INTO THE OUTDOORS MY
PREFERRED METHOD IS NOT HUMAN
POWERED AS WELL I PREFER AB ONE
POWERED.
SO I WILL DEFINITELY -- YOU KNOW
MAKE SURE THAT WE KEEP YOUR
COMMENTS ON A IN FOCUS AND I I
REALLY APPRECIATE THE SUPPORT
TODAY.
THANK YOU I THINK WE CAN USE A
RANCHER CREAM MAC A PARK IS
REALLY AN EXAMPLE OF HOW THAT'S
ACCOMPLISHED -- BETWEEN HUMAN
POWERED -- MOUNTAIN BIKING
THERE'S A A LITTLE BIT OF
MOTORIZED ON THE I DON'T THINK
IN THE PARK ITSELF BUT ON THE
JUST ON THE BORDER OF THE PARK.
AND THEN EXPLAIN -- THERE IS A
WAY FOR ALL OF THOSE.
USES TO LIVE IN HARMONY WHEN
THEY'RE PROPERLY PROMOTED
PROPERLY.
THE USERS ARE EDUCATED AND WE
DON'T HAVE TO LIMIT ACCESS FOR
ONE IN FAVOR OF THE OTHER
THERE'S TWO SECONDS TO SENSE
SENATOR -- COMPLETELY AGREE WITH
THE COMMENTS ABOUT -- LOAD
BALANCING ACROSS PARKS AND BRING
IN A BUSINESS MINDSET -- BIZ DEV
MINDSET SHOULD HELP WITH THAT --
LOAD BALANCING.
ON THE DIVERSITY OF USERS.
IT'S IMPORTANT TO KNOW THAT THE
NINETY BILLION IN ECONOMIC
ACTIVITY IN CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATED WITHOUT A RECREATION
THAT'S NINETY BILLION SPREAD
ACROSS ALL THE USER GROUPS THAT
YOU'RE DESCRIBING AND SO.
THIS DOES NOT WORK UNLESS YOU'VE
BRANDT BROUGHT IN THE RV YEARS
YOU BROUGHT IN THE A TV YEARS
ABROAD IN THE EQUINE.
AS WELL AS AS WE MIGHT BE AT
THAT THE THE LEAD IN THIS MOMENT
BUT WE'RE ALL PART OF A LARGER
COMMUNITY.
THANK YOU FOR RECOGNIZE THAT A I
GREW UP IN COLORADO -- THERE'S
ENTIRE MOUNTAIN TOWNS THAT WERE
DEVASTATED BY THE BY THE EXIT OF
MINING.
THEY HAVE NOW COMPLETELY
RECOVERED.
BECAUSE OF MOUNTAIN BIKING ATV
ACTIVITY WHITE WATER RAFTING --
IT CITIES THE ARE LIKE NOW HIP
AND COOL BECAUSE THEY'VE
COMPLETELY RECOVER BECAUSE THESE
ACTIVISTS THANK YOU.
ARE WE HAVE A MOTION ON THE BILL
NO MOTHER COMMENTS FROM THE
DíAS -- IT WILL TAKE AT LET'S
VOTE REAL QUICK BEFORE WE BREAK.
THIS STERN.
STERN AYE JONES JONES I ALLEN
GORGEOUS.
CABALLERO CAREER AYE HERTZBERG
HUESO JACKSON MONEY.
MONEY AND I THE BILL HAS FOR IT
ON CALL AND I'M SORRY I DIDN'T
THE MOTION WAS DO PASS AS
AMENDED TO THE GOVERNMENT OF
ORGANIZATIONAL COMMITTEE -- DO
YOU WANT ME TO NOW SISTER YOU AN
ANSWER.
OKAY -- SO.
ALL RIGHT GREAT SO -- WE'RE
GOING TO RECESS FOR CAUCUS AND
THEN WILL RECONVENE AT ONE
THIRTY IN ROOM ONE THIRTEEN SO.
THIS IS A RECESS
BELIEVE YOUR FIRST ON THE LIST
HERE AB.
FIVE FIFTY TWO THANK YOU FOR
YOUR PATIENCE MY APOLOGIES FOR
KEEPING YOU WAITING.
I BLAME SOMEONE ELSE -- THANK
YOU FOR HEARING.
OUR BILL AB FIVE FIFTY TO ADD.
A WORKING WITH YOU AND YOUR
STAFF HAPPY TO TAKE THE
AMENDMENTS THAT ARE OUTLINED.
IN THE COMMITTEE BILL IN OR IN
THE IN THE COMMITTEES ANALYSIS.
AND WHAT THIS BILL DOES WE FOUND
SOME REVENUES THAILAND'S
REVENUES THAT HAVE BEEN
COLLECTED FOR A NUMBER OF YEARS
STARTING THE LATE.
AND THEN TWO THOUSAND SIX AND
THEY WERE SUPPOSED TO BE
COLLECTED.
AND USED.
FOR COASTAL RESOURCES AND THEN
IT WAS SWEPT IN THE GENERAL FUND
AND I THINK.
THAT WOULD BE BETTER SERVED TO
TAKE SOME OF THOSE REVENUES AND
MAKE THEM AVAILABLE ALONG THE
COAST AND SINCE THERE COASTAL
DERIVE.
BECOME AVAILABLE IN THE COASTAL
ZONE OF PROJECTS THAT ARE
BUILDING ON ADAPTATION.
WE KEEP TALKING ABOUT.
THE NEED FOR CALIFORNIA TO BE
RESILIENT A NEED FOR CALIFORNIA
TO ADAPT TO OUR CHANGING CLIMATE.
BUT THERE WILL NEED TO BE A
TREMENDOUS AMOUNT OF RESOURCES
AVAILABLE MONEY AVAILABLE TO
HELP LOCAL JURISDICTIONS.
THIS IS THE FIRST TOàN THAT
WATER IF YOU WELL.
OF TAKING A PART OF THOSE
REVENUES BACK FOR HOW THE
GENERAL FUND AND MAKE THEM
AVAILABLE FOR LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS TO DO SOME OF
THEIR ADAPTATION WORK.
WHAT I'M HOPING BECAUSE A LOT OF
THE MONEY THAT WE RAISES BOND
MONEY ANDOTHERS THAT HAVE
RESTRICTIONS BUT I'M HOPING IS
THAT THIS IS MONEY THAT WILL BE
AVAILABLE?
WITH A GREAT DEAL OF FLEXIBILITY
TO LET IS YOUR SIX CAN DO THE
PLANNING THAT'S NECESSARY TO
BUILD RESILIENCE IN THEIR
COMMUNITIES.
THAT'S WHAT THIS BILL IS ABOUT.
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR I'VE THANK
YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIRMAN
OF THE COMMITTEE ON FEDERAL NO
HERE ON BEHALF OF AUTUMN ON
CALIFORNIA'S SPONSORS OF THIS
PIECE OF LEGISLATION FOR YOU
TODAY -- I'LL BE BRIEF AND AND
JUST -- HOPEFULLY TRY TO
COMPLEMENT THE AUTHOR'S COMMENTS --
IN SAYING THAT. ONE OF THE
THINGS AS POINTED OUT BY THE
ANALYSIS IS IS.
THE CRITICAL LACK OF FUNDING FOR
THESE KINDS OF ACTIVITIES THUS
FAR. TO SOME FUNDING THAT'S BEEN
MADE AVAILABLE TO THE CLIMATE
READY PROGRAM AT THE COSTA
CONSERVANCY -- WHICH HAS BEEN
LARGELY FUNDED YOU KNOW TEN
MILLION DOLLARS SO SO FAR.
LARGELY FUNDED THROUGH
ENVIRONMENT LICENSE PLATE ON
ABOUT SEVEN MILLION OF IT.
HAS BEEN -- FROM THAT FUND
SOURCE AND MOST RECENTLY TWO
YEARS AGO OR I GUESS LAST.
YEAR. THREE MILLION DOLLARS FROM
THE GAS PRODUCTION FUND.
I'M YOU KNOW IN IN THIS SESSION
I KNOW THAT THERE HAS BEEN A LOT
OF DISCUSSION ABOUT ADDITIONAL
INVESTMENTS FOR THESE KINDS OF
ACTIVITIES THAT HAVING COME TO
FRUITION -- SO REALLY JUST
POINTS TO THE THE NEED AND AND
THE THE IMPORTANCE OF THE BILL
THAT IS BEING OFFERED BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER STONE.
ARMED AND THEREFORE WOULD --
REQUEST AN AYE VOTE.
YOU SO MUCH OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON JAMIE I WANT TO
HAVE A SOUL AS WELL AS THE
NATURE CONSERVANCY IN SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON NATALIE NEXT ON
BEHALF OF OCEAN CONSERVANCY IN
SUPPORT.
MUCH.
AND ALSO WE HAVE A CYNICAL
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT.
SIR CRISTINA HALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA COASTAL COMMISSION IN
OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
IN NINE ANY OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE WILL BRING IT BACK
TO VERY LONELY DíAS APPRECIATE
YOU BEING A MEASURE FORWARD.
AND WORKING WITH THE COMMITTEE
ON THE AMENDMENTS SETTING HIS
NOVEL.
IT'S TIME WE START PUTTING THAT
FUN BACK TO WORK TO DEAL WITH
THE IMPACT OF OIL AND ALL THE
THE CLIMATE.
COST THAT IT CAUSES AND I THINK
THIS WILL BE AN ONGOING THEME
YOU'LL SEE AND ALL THIS SORT OF
ADAPTATION RESILIENCE BILLS WERE
REALLY KEEN ON TRYING TO
QUANTIFY THE TOTAL SCOPE OF NEED
HERE OVERALL I THINK.
THIS IS THIS A GOOD WAY TO CHIP
AWAY BUT UNFORTUNATELY IT'LL BE
I THINK A DROP IN THE BUCKET AS
TO THE TOTAL OUT SAMEER LIKE THE
FLEXIBILITY THAT FUNDING BUT WE
STILL I THINK IS A STATE OR
FLYING BLIND IN TERMS OF THE
TOTAL.
I'M AT RISK WE'RE FACING
BASICALLY -- SO HOPEFULLY THIS
WILL HELP DRIVE THAT PROCESS
ALONG A LITTLE BIT MORE AND I'LL
BE SUPPORTIVE TODAY [inaudible]
CLOSE.
THANK YOU N. WITH THAT YES IT'S
A SMALL AMOUNT OF MONEY BUT
HOPEFULLY THIS IS A WAY TO PRIME
THE PUMP.
AND KIND OF WHAT EVERYBODY'S
APPETITE WHAT'S POSSIBLE IN FROM
THIS I'M HOPING WE CAN BUILD.
YOUR SUPPORT GOOD THANK YOU -- I
CANNOT ENTERTAIN A MOTION AT
THIS POINT SO WE WILL WHEN YOU
GET AT OCEAN YEAH THANK YOU
THANK YOU SO MUCH [inaudible]
SUMMER MULLIN.
ON WORDS TOWARDS MORE RESILIENCY
AB EIGHT THIRTY NINE YES SIR.
WELCOME.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
I'LL START BY THANKING THE CHAIR%
AND COMMITTEE STAFF FOR AN
EXCELLENT NOW SAYS THERE ARE TWO
PROPOSED AMENDMENTS WHICH I AM
PLEASED TO TAKE.
AND I THINK THEY MAKE IT A
STRONGER BILL THEY ARE COVERED
ON PAGES SIX AND SEVEN OF THE
ANALYSIS.
AS YOU KNOW CALIFORNIA'S DONE
GREAT WORK TO DATE INVESTING IN
RESEARCH AND DEVELOPING GUIDANCE
IN PLANNING FOR CLIMATE CHANGE
ADAPTATION.
AS A COMMITTEE THE HOUSE IS
APTLY POINTS OUT THE CALIFORNIA
NATURAL RESOURCES AGENCY.
IS THE AGENCY LEVEL LEAD ON THE
SEATS CLIMATE ADAPTATION POLICY
AND NATURAL RESOURCES CLIMATE
POLICY.
THE RESOURCES AGENCIES TASKED
WITH REVISING THE SAFEGUARDING
CALIFORNIA PLAN THE STATE'S
CLIMATE ADAPTATION STRATEGY
EVERY THREE YEARS.
AND THE TWENTY EIGHTEEN PLAN
INCLUDES A LIST OF QUALITATIVE
METRICS TO EVALUATE PROGRESS.
TOWARDS MEETING THE STATE'S
ADAPTATION GOALS IDENTIFIED
THERE IN.
MEASURING PROGRESS IS REPEATEDLY
MENTIONED IN THE PLAN.
I INTRODUCED AB EIGHT THIRTY
NINE AND RISK.
CALL FROM NUMEROUS ORGANIZATIONS
ACROSS THE STATE OR IN SUPPORT
OF THE BILL -- INSISTS THAT WE
NEED TO IMPLEMENT MORE TEETH TO
OUR EXISTING EFFORTS TO
ACCOMPLISH THAT.
THE BILL DOES THE FOLLOWING IT
DESIGNATES THE SECRETARY OF
NATURAL RESOURCES TO LEAD THE
STATE'S CLIMATE ADAPTATION%
STRATEGY.
AND TO DEVELOP A STRATEGIC
RESILIENCY FRAMEWORK THAT BUILDS
ON THE SAFEGUARDING CALIFORNIA
PLAN.
CRITICALLY THAT FRAMEWORK WILL
INCLUDE RECOMMENDED ACTIONS WITH
TIME TABLES AND METRICS TO
MEASURE THE STATE'S PROGRESS IN
BUILDING AND INVESTING IN
ADAPTATION RESILIENCY PROJECT.
EACH STATE AGENCY IDENTIFIED IN
FRAMEWORK FOR REPORT TO THE
SECRETARY ON ITS PROGRESS
COMPLETING THE RECOMMENDATIONS
AND ACTIONS.
ADDITIONALLY THE BILL CREATES
THE RESILIENCY THROUGH
ADAPTATION ECONOMIC VITALITY AND
EQUITY ACCOUNT.
WHERE FUNDING FOR ADAPTATION
PROJECTS CAN BE CONSOLIDATED?
NATURAL RESOURCES AGENCY
TREASURER AND PR WILL DEVELOP
GRANTS AND FINANCING TOOLS TO
IMPLEMENT THE RECOMMENDATIONS
AND ACTIONS IN THE FRAMEWORK.
AS HE NOW SAYS ALSO NOTES THERE
ARE NUMBER OF POTENTIAL WAYS OF
THIS ACCOUNT COULD BE FUNDED.
WE WORK WITH THE TREASURER'S
OFFICE ON THE FINANCING LANGUAGE
BECAUSE WE KNOW WE WILL NEED TO
DO MORE THAN JUST AWARD.
PARMI WE ALL RECOGNIZE A MASSIVE
NEED FOR INFRASTRUCTURE DOLLARS
I PERSONALLY THINK THAT
ADDITIONAL BOND MONEY WILL BE
NECESSARY IN THE FUTURE.
BUT AB EIGHT THIRTY NINE LEAVES
THAT DETERMINATION TO FUTURE
BUDGETING DECISIONS ONE LAST
COMMENT BEFORE HE MOVED TO
SUPPORT TESTIMONY.
WE RECENTLY AMENDED THE BILL THE
STRIKE LANGUAGE CONCERNING THE
INSURANCE COMMISSIONER AND
INSURANCE PREMIUMS THE SENATE
INSURANCE COMMITTEE WAS VERY
HELPFUL IN WORKING WITH MY
OFFICE RECOGNIZE.
THAT THERE'S A MUCH LARGER
DISCUSSION ON THAT PARTICULAR.
ISSUE THAT NEEDS TO TAKE PLACE
SO WE FELT THAT THAT'S BETTER
PLACED OUTSIDE OF THIS BILL.
SO WITH THAT I'M HAPPY TO TURN
IT OVER TO OUR WITNESSES -- IN
SUPPORT GOOD THANK YOU
[inaudible]
WELCOME.
DEFINITE THANK YOU CHAIR MEMBERS
READ OUT US ON BEHALF OF PUSHING
CONSERVANCY IN FRIENDS A LOS
ANGELES RIVER.
IN STRONG SUPPORT TODAY.
WELL THE STATE CALIFORNIA'S BEEN
A LEADER ON CLIMATE POLICY FOR
NUMBER OF YEARS.
WE HAVEN'T NECESSARILY CREATED A
COMPREHENSIVE POLICY AROUND
CLIMATE ADAPTATION AND
RESILIENCY.
HE THERE HAS BEEN SOME MEASURES --
WE'VE PASSED OVER THE YEARS THAT --
DO TALK ABOUT ADAPTATION OF OVER
MISSING IS A FRAMEWORK THAT SAYS.
WE SHOULD BE PROACTIVELY DEALING
WITH ADAPTATION RESILIENCY.
THAT WE SHOULD HAVE SOME
GOVERNING CLARITY ON GOVERNING
STRUCTURE AROUND THAT.
WE SHOULD BE TALKING ABOUT
METRICS AND GOALS OF WATER WE
ADAPTING OR WHAT WE BECOMING
RESILIENT TOWARDS OR FOR AND
THEN ULTIMATELY WE KNOW IT'S
GONNA BE A REALLY COMPLICATED
FISCAL.
ISSUE TO DEAL WITH STATEWIDE
WHEN IT COMES TO LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS NONPROFITS STATE
GOVERNMENTS REGIONAL.
I AGENCIES TRYING TO GRAPPLE
WITH THOSE IMPACTS FROM CLIMATE
CHANGE AND THE BILL.
BORDER PUTS FORTH AN INNOVATIVE
PROGRAM.
THAT ALLOWS US TO START THINKING
BACK TO ME TAKE STATE FINDING
OTHER PUBLIC RESOURCE DOLLARS
AND PRIVATE SPENDING IN. TO HIS
BEST TO AS MUCH AS WE CAN. TO
ADVANCE THOSE EFFORTS AROUND OF
THE OVERALL SPIEGEL AND
FRAMEWORK.
SO AGAIN IN STRONG SUPPORT TODAY
THANK YOU FOR WORKING WITH YOU
AND YOUR STAFF ON SOME THE
AMENDMENTS AND APPRECIATE THE AN
AUTHOR'S EFFORT HERE TODAY THANK
YOU SO MUCH OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON THAT WE NEXT ON
BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA CESSATION
OF LOCAL CONSERVATION COURSE
CALIFORNIA TROUT.
I CALIFORNIA HAVE A HABITAT
CONSERVATION PLANNING COALITION
COMMUNITY NATURE CONNECTION ONLY
NEIGHBORHOOD LAND TRUST.
LAND TO SENATORS COUNTY SEE THE
REDWOODS LEAGUE MADE PENCIL
REGION OPEN SPACE DISTRICT AND
SUPPORT.
VERY GOOD THANK YOU SO MUCH
OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
SEEN ON THAN TO ANY OPPOSITION.
TINO BRING BACK TO THE DíAS
MEMBER QUESTIONS COMMENTS.
THANKS FOR WORKING WITH US.
SAME THING APPLIES.
THE COST IS BIG IS THE LA --
SAYS THE AT THE ANNOUNCES POINTS
OUT NO COMPREHENSIVE STATEWIDE
ASSESSMENT OF FUTURE COSTS TO
THE STATE OR LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
HAS BEEN COMPLETED AT THIS TIME
SO.
WE LIKE GETTING THIS FRAMEWORK
IN PLACE.
I THINK I WOULD PUT A PLUG IN TO
TO TAKE A LOOK AT SB FIVE WHICH
I BELIEVE IS COMING YOUR WAY
WHICH IS TAKES A REDEVELOPMENT
APPROACH.
TO I AGREE WITH YOU BINDING IS
GONNA MAKE SENSE THERE'S GONNA
WE'RE GONNA HAVE TO GET CREATIVE
ABOUT REVENUE. TO MEMBER STONE
LOOKED AT THAILAND'S -- BUT
WE'VE ACTUALLY GOT TO ASSESS THE
NEEDS AND HAVE A WAKE UP CALL
HERE ABOUT THE ENDING COST OR
IT'S TOO LATE SO I APPRECIATE
YOU TRYING.
TO GET AHEAD OF THAT ISSUE --
AND I'LL BE SUPPORTING THE
MEASURE TODAY -- AND HOPEFULLY
YOU KNOW ONCE HE SAID THIS
FRAMEWORK IN PLACE HERE AND
INSURANCE ISSUES YOU BROUGHT UP.
BUT YOU'RE QUITE VALID IF WE CAN
START TO BUY DOWN THAT RIZ.
THE INDUSTRY SHOULD REFLECT THAT
I THINK THAT WE'RE SEEING THAT
RIGHT NOW TO PUT THE SPARE ON
FIRE.
GOING HARD IN YOUR HOME OR
MANAGER VEGETATION BUT YOUR YOUR
INSURANCE HASN'T CHANGED AND
WE'RE NOT GETTING ANYWHERE SO I
WANT TO KEEP WORKING WITH YOU ON
THAT ISSUE AND APPRECIATE YOU
YOUR LEADERSHIP HERE INTO THE
STAKEHOLDERS AS WELL SO.
I WOULD ENTERTAIN A MOTION BUT
IF THERE ISN'T.
ONE WE WILL.
LEAVE THE MEASURE ON CALL AND
THEN WE'LL COME BACK TO IT
[inaudible]
OKAY.
ALL RIGHT WE'RE GONNA LEAVE THAT.
SITTON AND WE'LL COME BACK TO IN
A BIT THANK YOU SEVEN OVER THE
BRING THE SPORT [inaudible]
ALL RIGHT.
OKAY DO WE HAVE ANYONE ELSE.
I'M GONNA NEED YOU [inaudible]
GREAT IDEA.
WHAT IS YOUR FOR THE CONSENT
CALENDAR LEASE GET YOUR VOTE ON
RECORD THERE?
YEAH.
AS THE WHY -- I I WOULD
ENTERTAIN A MOTION ON THAT.
AND IT IS FILE ITEM.
SIXTEEN EIGHTEEN AB SIXTEEN
FORTY FOUR AND EIGHTEEN TWENTY
THREE YOUR MINIMAL ALL INNER.
VERY GOOD THIS MOTION CENTER
BORDERS PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
STERN HI.
HI JONES ALAN GORGEOUS.
BUSH'S AYE CABALLERO HERTZBERG
HUESO JACKSON MONEY THEY WILL
LEAVE THE MEASURE ON CALL AND
TAKE A BRIEF PAUSE
. SEVEN HAMMER
WELCOME 27% YOU'RE YOU'RE THE
ONLY MAN.
STANDING OR SITTING AT THIS
POINT.
RIGHT WELL THE MIKE IS ON AT IN
HAND THANK YOU SIR GOOD
AFTERNOON [inaudible]
YEAH AFTERNOON [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
I GUESS IT'S SIMILAR BECAUSE I
WAS JUST SITTING HELP.
GOT A TEXT MESSAGE PLEASE COME.
OPPORTUNITY.
THIS.
IS A GOOD PITCH SO IT'S AB SEVEN
TWO TWO YES YES.
OKAY.
THANK YOU.
I LIKE THE OPTIMISM.
MISTER CHAIR AND SENATORS TODAY
I PRESENT ASSEMBLY BILL SEVEN
TWENTY TWO THIS MEASURE WILL
HELP ALLEVIATE IBM FEES FOR
IRRIGATION DISTRICTS.
WITH LESS THAN FIVE HUNDRED RATE
PAYERS THIS IS A DISTRICT BILL
THAT WILL HELP SEVERAL SMALL
IRRIGATION DISTRICTS IN OUR
RURAL COMMUNITIES BUT NOT JUST
LIMITED TO ASSEMBLY DISTRICT.
FIVE IN AMADOR COUNTY JACKSON
VALLEY IRRIGATION DISTRICT
OPERATES THE JACKSON CREEK DAM.
WITH THE RECENT ADJUSTMENTS TO
THE DAM SAFETY INSPECTION
PROGRAM JACKSON CREEK WILL BE
EXPERIENCING UNFAIRLY HIGH FEES
YOU TO WHAT I BELIEVE ARE UNIQUE
CIRCUMSTANCES. ONE OF THE WAYS
THAT THE A DIVISION OF SAFETY OF
DAMS A BRANCH OF THE W. R. WHO
INSPECT INFRASTRUCTURE RELATED
TO DANCE.
THE TERM IS FEES IS BASED OFF A
HIGH OF THE DAM.
AB I D..
REMEMBER IT'S JACKSON -- EVERY
CATION DISTRICT.
I HAS A HIGH HIGH OF A HUNDRED
NINETY THREE FIFTY BUT ONLY
TWENTY TWO THOUSAND ACRE FEET OF
STORAGE.
IN COMPARISON NEIGHBORING DAMS
WITH ALMOST NINETEEN TIMES YES I
SAID NINETEEN TIMES THE AMOUNT
OF WATER STORED IN THEM.
BUT SHORTER HIGH EIGHT THOUSANDS
OF DOLLARS LESS.
J. V. I. D. PROVIDES WATER
MOSTLY FOR AGRICULTURE.
THEY DO NOT HAVE A CAPACITY TO
CONTINUE PAYING LARGE SUMS OF
MONEY WE'RE SHORT INSPECTIONS.
THEIR FEES ARE A TREMENDOUS
AMOUNT. FIFTEEN I'M FIFTY ONE
THOUSAND DOLLARS THIS YEAR.
WHICH IS A 10%.
OF THEIR IT WHICH IS 10% OF
THEIR BUDGET UNFORTUNATELY AS WE
SUGGESTED THEY DO NOT HAVE THE
ABILITY TO RAISE TAXES ON A
HANDFUL OF USERS.
WHO HAVE BEEN WORKING THIS LAND
FOR GENERATIONS?
MEMBERS MY CONSTITUENTS WENT TO
THE D. S. O. BE ASKING.
FOR WELL SOME HELP.
THEY WERE DIRECTED TOWARDS ME.
AND SEVERAL ARE LEGISLATIVE
IDEAS WERE SET.
THIS MEASURE WOULD ONLY IMPACT
THE DIVISIONS NINETEEN MILLION
DOLLAR PROGRAM BY APPROXIMATELY
A HUNDRED AND TWELVE THOUSAND
DOLLARS.
AGAIN THE ME RESTATE THE
DIVISION HAS NINETEEN A NINETEEN
MILLION DOLLAR PROGRAM.
AND IT WILL ONLY IMPACT THEM BY
A HUNDRED AND TWELVE THOUSAND
DOLLARS.
IN CLOSING I JUST LIKE TO
REITERATE THAT AB SEVEN TWENTY
TWO WOULD CAP THESE FOR
IRRIGATION DISTRICTS WOULD
LESSEN.
I FIVE HUNDRED RATE HERE LIMIT
THE 20% OF THE AMOUNT ASKED FOR
EACH YEAR.
THIS MAJOR MADE IT OUT OF THE
PARK LAST POLICY COMMITTEE ON
CONSENT.
AND OUT OF THE ASSEMBLY WITH
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT.
I'D LIKE TO THANK EACH OF YOU
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE TODAY IN
ADVANCE.
AND WITH ME I HAVE A COUPLE OF
WITNESSES MISTER CHAIR.
I'D LIKE TO INTRODUCE AYE MR
GEORGE LAMBERT HE'S THE BOARD
CHAIR OF THE J. V. I. D.
DISTRICT AND MISTER STEVEN
FREDERIC.
THE GENERAL MANAGER IF YOU WOULD
ALLOW THEM A COUPLE MOMENTS TO
SECURE.
IS ENFORCED PLEASE.
PLEASE COME FORWARD.
YES AND BOASTED OR TAKE A
STANDING MIKE TO OVER THERE --
TO YOUR RIGHTS OR OR HOWEVER YOU
WANT TO DO IT.
WELCOME GOOD AFTERNOON GOOD
AFTERNOON.
MY NAME STEVEN FREDERIC.
MANAGER OF JACK'S MIGLIOR GEISHA
DISTRICT MANAGER SINCE.
TWO THOUSAND THIRTEEN JUST WANT
TO START OFF WITH.
READING THE ANALYSIS OTHER SOME
DISCREPANCIES I'D LIKE TO POINT
OUT OF THE FIRST THING IS -- WHY
ARE?
WHY SHOULD THE JV ID GET
SUBSIDIZED BY OTHER DAM OWNERS?
WE FEEL THAT WE ARE SUBSIDIZING
OTHER DAM OWNERS.
I'LL GIVE A PERFECT EXAMPLE --
EAST BAY MUD WHICH IS A NEARBY
FACILITY.
ONLY LAKE COMANCHE OF FOUR
HUNDRED THOUSAND ACRES BUT
RESERVOIR.
IS LESS OF A DANTE THAN WE DO.
WE HAVE TWENTY TWO THOUSAND ACRE
FEET [inaudible]
DRASTIC DIFFERENCE.
IN COMPARISON IT TAKES US ABOUT
FOUR HOURS EVERY YEAR FR DS
THIRTY TO COME OUT.
AND ACTUALLY INSPECTOR FACILITY.
IT TAKES OVER A WEEK THAT IS
VERY MUCH.
AND THAT'S THE INTENT OF THE DAM
FEE [inaudible]
SO.
THE NEXT OUR POINT IS AS WIDE AS
A JV ID RAISE RATES.
ARE THE ANALYSIS LOOKED AT A TWO
THOUSAND FOURTEEN LAUGHTER
REVIEW.
ACTUALLY IN LATE TWO THOUSAND
FOURTEEN WE DID DO A 50% RATE
INCREASE THAT'S NOT.
TO INCLUDED IN THIS ANALYSIS.
IN MONETIZING OTHER ASSETS WE
ACTUALLY WORE MONETIZED AND AND
HAD A PARTNERSHIP WITH A
INVESTMENT FIRM.
WHAT ARE SMALL HYDRO PLANT?
BUT WE TOOK THAT OVER FOR ONE
DOLLAR BECAUSE THEY COULDN'T
AFFORD THE REGULATORY FEES
[inaudible]
SO -- I HAVE SOME EXAMPLES --
BUT YOU'RE GONNA BE HANDED IS A
A COMPARISON FEET TABLE.
AND RIGHT OFF THE BAT YOU'LL SEE
LAKE AMADOR I THINK WE'RE ALL.
CURRENTLY OF WELL AWARE OF WHERE
LAKE AMADOR IS AND HOW BIG THAT
FACILITY IS.
THEY CURRENTLY PAY YOUR LAST
YEAR'S FEES WERE TWENTY SEVEN
THOUSAND DOLLARS.
EIGHT HUNDRED WE PAID FORTY
THREE THOUSAND THIS YEAR WE PAID.
FIFTY ONE SO THE INCREASE.
IT IT'S AN EXPONENTIAL INCREASE
EVERY YEAR BECAUSE THE S. R. D.
IS RELYING ON THIS [inaudible]
REVENUE STREAM.
BACK IN TWO THOUSAND FOUR IT WAS
ACTUALLY THE GENERAL FUND THE
FUNDED.
DSO DE [inaudible]
OPERATIONS.
NOW THEY RELY HOPE A 100% ON
FEES COLLECTED FROM THE DAM
OWNERS.
AND AFTER THE LAKE ORVILLE
INCIDENT YOU SEE THE BOTTOM
TABLE OR THE GRAPH.
OF WHAT HAPPENED TO JB ID
SPECIFICALLY.
AFTER TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN IN
THE LAKE ORVILLE INCIDENT WHEN
THE DS WOULD BE EXPANDED THEIR
PROGRAM.
WE GOT HIT PRETTY HARD.
OTHER WOMEN IN SPORTS.
I LIKE TO DO TO IT I'M GEORGE
LAMBERT ON THE BOARD.
PRESIDENT OF THE DISTRICT.
WE'VE BEEN CONCERNED ABOUT THIS --
DAM BE BEST TWO THOUSAND FOUR IN.
AND WE SEEN IT ESCALATE AND WE
HAD OUR FIRST OPPORTUNITY TO
WEIGH IN.
THE DIVISION OF DAM SAFETY THIS
LAST YEAR.
WHEN THEY CIRCULATED NEW
REGULATIONS?
IN THE DAM SAFETY HAS BEEN UNDER
SOME PRESSURE TO TRY. TO TO GET
THERE.
BUT THEY'VE BEEN LIVING
TEMPORARY FEES FOR SEVERAL YEARS
NOW AND THE AND THEY'VE BEEN
DIRECTED TO COME UP WITH A
PERMIT REGULATION.
TO PLEASE IT WOULD APPLY AROUND
THE STATE.
OUR CONCERN WAS THAT THERE ARE
THESE TO BE.
A STRUCTURAL CHANGE IN THE WAY
THOSE FEES ARE CALCULATED.
IT'S IN STATUE RIGHT NOW THAT
THEY HAVE TO BE BASED PRIMARILY
ON HAIFA DAM [inaudible]
BUT WHAT WE WERE TRYING TO POINT
OUT TO THE DIVISION OF DAM
SAFETY IS THAT.
A LOT OF OTHER THINGS OR IN PLAY
ON OUGHT TO BE CONSIDERED IN IN
THE THE STRUCTURE.
THINGS LIKE DOWNSTREAM RISK.
THE THE AMOUNT OF WATER IN
STORAGE AND WHAT IT CAN DO IN
THE DOWNSTREAM.
DAMAGE IF THERE WAS A BREACH OF
THE DAM.
OUR LITTLE DAM.
IT WOULD HAVE SOME IMPACT.
BUT WE'D BE PRETTY MUCH LIMITED
TO THE OF THE CREEK THAT WE JUST
CHARGE AND TO AND IT WOULD GET
DOWN AS FAR AS THE TOWN OF GOLF
BUT IT WILL BE MOSTLY IN
AGRICULTURAL AREAS.
WHICH IS OUR NEXT DOOR NEIGHBOR
WOULD WIPE OUT LODI WHICH IS A
PRETTY.
PRETTY GOOD SIZED TOWN.
YOU TAKE IT. FOR AVAIL YOU KNOW
THEY THEY THEY DON'T.
YEAH THEY'RE THEY'RE FEE IS
BIGGER THAN OURS BUT NOT BY VERY
MUCH AND THEY THEIR FEE IS
BASICALLY ABOUT FIVE CENTS PER
ACRE FOOT OF WATER IN STORAGE
AND OURS IS TO SENSE.
ARCHBISHOP TWO DOLLARS.
THERE IS A SPICE SENSE OURS IS
TWO DOLLARS.
IS ONE OF THE LARGEST CALCULATED
ON THE ON THE TOTAL AMOUNT OF
WATER IN STORAGE VINNIE'S ANY
DAMAGE THE STATE.
BUT WE WANT TO THE DIVISION OF
OF DAM SAFETY AND POINTED THESE
THINGS OUT.
THEY WERE VERY SYMPATHETIC TO
OUR ARGUMENT.
BUT THEY WERE IN A POSITION TO
DO MUCH ABOUT IT.
BECAUSE OF THE LEGISLATIVE.
RESTRICTIONS ON I'M.
ON HOW THINGS ARE CURRENTLY SET
UP.
AND THE TRYING TO RE WORKS THE
ENTIRE.
SYSTEM.
IN THE TIME THAT THEY HAD.
WAS A VERY PRACTICAL AND WOULD
RESULT IN A LOT OF WINNERS AND
pLOSERS WHICH THEY DIDN'T WANT TO
GET INTO.
SO THEY DIRECTED US TO MISTER
BIGELOW.
ED TO TRY TO COME UP WITH
SOMETHING THAT WOULD WORK.
AND WE FIRST -- LOOKED AT COMING
UP WITH A DISADVANTAGED WE WE
QUALIFY AS A DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITY.
BUT EVEN THAT I HAD A LOT OF
PROBLEMS -- WERE.
YOU KNOW THERE'S TALK IS A
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES IN
JUST ABOUT EVERY COMMUNITY IN
THE STATE SO IT WOULD BE A
NIGHTMARE TO TRY TO FIGURE IT
OUT ON THAT BASIS.
SO WE CAME UP WITH THIS LITTLE
CUT OUT OR SMALL IRRIGATION
DISTRICT.
AND WHEN WE WE PRESENTED THAT --
TO ASSEMBLYMAN ASSEMBLYMAN
BIGELOW'S OFFICE AND TO THE
DIVISION THE DAM SAFETY
EVERYBODY BREATHES A SIGH OF
RELIEF THAT THIS LOOKS LIKE A
PRETTY SIMPLE. SIX AND AND
WOULDN'T COST VERY MUCH TO
IMPLEMENT.
SO THAT'S WHY WE'RE HERE YOU
KNOW WE WE THINK WE'VE COME UP
WITH A GOOD SOLUTION.
IT'S VERY MODEST AND AND THE
IMPACT ON THE ON THE DIVISION
ADVANCE SAFETY BUDGET. HUNDRED
TWELVE THOUSAND A NINETEEN
MILLION DOLLARS.
AND WE THREE THANK IT WOULD BE A
SUCCESSFUL.
EFFORT.
AND IT WOULD GIVE US A GREAT
AMOUNT OF RELEASED AND OTHER
COMMUNITIES.
SIMILAR TO A THAT'S WHY WE WERE
HERE AND WE THANK GOD.
IT'S A GOOD.
AGOOD WAY TO GO THANK YOU SIR
APPRECIATE YOU MAKING A TRACK.
ANY OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
A SENIOR IRANIAN OPPOSITION.
A SCENE -- NINE I CAN DIRECTORS
TO YOUR BOARD PRESIDENT YOU'RE
SITTING RIGHT THERE.
THE THE CENTRAL CONCERN I HAD --
WAS EXACTLY THE STRUCTURAL ISSUE
YOU BROUGHT UP.
YOU KNOW LOOKING THROUGH THE
ANALYSIS AND EVEN WITHIN THE
DOWNSTREAM HAZARD POTENTIAL
CLASSIFICATIONS RICHARD THOSE
EXPENSIVE.
BECAUSE AT LEAST ONE LOSS OF
HUMAN LIFE.
THERE IS A FAIR AMOUNT OF
VARIABILITY -- AND I RECOGNIZE
THAT IT'S TRICKY TO REWORK THAT
WITHOUT WINNERS AND LOSERS BUT
ON PRINCIPLE I DO HAVE CONCERNS
ABOUT.
THIS SORT OF NARROW CUT OUT
REGARDLESS HOW NARROW IT IS AND
I I KNOW YOU REALIZE THAT.
YOU ALL THIS IS A BIG DEAL BUT
THE CONCERN THAT I'VE I'VE GOT
LOOKING THROUGH THE THEBROADER
LIST.
IS.
EVEN LIKE THE DSO D. COMPARISON
FEET TABLE.
YOU GO TO LA ALL THESE LA COUNTY
PUBLIC WORKS ARE DOWN THE CITY
OF SAN DIEGO.
I'M.
HIGHER FEES A HIGHER DOLLAR FEE
PER ACRE FOOT.
HOW DO YOU MANAGE THAT ISSUE
SOME CAN HAVE MORE FINANCIAL
CAPACITY SOME DON'T?
SEE THE INSIDE BY THE WHEN
YOU'RE TWENTY FOURTEEN RATE
INCREASE AND THAT.
THOSE ARE HARD POLITICS I AM
WELL AWARE THAT.
MY RECOMMENDATION WOULD BE TO
WORK WITH US -- ON WHAT THAT
STRUCTURAL REFORM MIGHT ACTUALLY
ENTAIL.
BECAUSE I THINK YOU'VE GOT SOME
SOUND ARGUMENTS THERE -- BUT AS
A MATTER OF SORT OF JUST GENERAL
POLICY.
STRUGGLING WITH -- JUST PULL IN
ONE PIECE OUT BECAUSE FIRST IT'S
YOU ALL MEN AND SOMEONE ELSE AND
WE ALREADY HELD THE FLOOR A BILL
THAT WAS TANGENTIALLY RELATED
BUT THAT THAT'S THAT'S THE
CONCERN AND SO I DON'T KNOW WHAT
THE OPENNESS OF THE AUTHOR IS OR
YOUR OR YOUR SPONSORS HERE.
BUT I I DON'T MEAN THIS TO BE A
FALSE PROMISE I I REALLY WOULD
BE WILLING TO WORK WITH YOU ALL
IF YOU DID WANT.
TO PULL THE TODAY AND WORK ON
THIS IT TO YOUR BILL AND
ACTUALLY TRY TO GET SOME OF THAT
STATUTORY STRUCTURAL REFORM WITH
THE W. R..
I'M UP FOR DOING THAT WORK BUT I
I TOTALLY APPRECIATE IF YOU JUST
WANT TO MAKE TO VOTE AND SEE WE
LAND -- SO I'LL LEAVE THAT AT
YOUR DISCRETION.
CAN I RESPOND.
PLEASE.
I THINK IN THE IN THE LONG RUN
THAT WOULD BE A GREAT WAY TO GO.
WE WE WE WOULD APPRECIATE
BECAUSE WE'VE BEEN WE'VE BEEN
THINKING ABOUT THIS PROBLEM FOR
OVER TEN YEARS NOW AND AND
WORRIED ABOUT THE LONG TERM
IMPLICATIONS ON OUR BUDGET.
IN THIS YEAR ALONE YOU KNOW IT
THAT THAT BE HAS CONSUMED.
THIRD OF OUR OUR TOTAL WATER
SALES REVENUE.
THIS IS A BIG DEAL TO IT AND
THEN WE DON'T WANT THE MOMENT
THE PAST.
IF WE COULD IF.
THERE'S TWO WAYS TO GO HERE ONE
IS.
THAT BACK AND TRY TO WORK THIS
THING THROUGH TO YOUR BILL AND
GET SOME REAL.
CHANGES IN IN THE WORKS.
ON THE WHOLE DAY TO THE STATE
ALTHOUGH.
YOU KNOW AS I SAID IS THERE'S A
LOT OF POLITICS IN THAT.
THERE'S A LOT OF ECONOMICS AND
ANOTHER WAY TO APPROACH IT WOULD
BE TO GO AHEAD AND CREATORS
DON'T CUT OUT RIGHT NOW
[inaudible]
IN.
REPLACE IT YOU KNOW WHAT THE
BEST A BROADER.
CHANGED LATER ON AS WE GET
THROUGH THE PROCESS. FOR US THAT
WOULD BE PREFERABLE BECAUSE
WE'RE WE'RE SUFFERING
ECONOMICALLY FOR THIS AND WE WE
HAVE A VERY SMALL BUDGET WE ONLY
HAVE A HALF A MILLION DOLLAR A
YEAR BUDGET.
WE'VE SPENT.
ALMOST A HALF A MILLION DOLLARS
JUST IN THE LAST FIVE YEARS ON
ALL THE STUDIES AND SIX UPS AND
THINGS THAT.
NBA WERE UNDER FIRST REGULATION
TO WHICH IS FEDERAL FOR OUR
LITTLE POWER.
AND SO YOU KNOW WE HAVE A BUDGET
REASON TO WANT TO GET SOME
RELEASED.
I SAW THAT WOULD NOT BE MY
PREFERENCE IS.
TO APPROVED THIS BILL GIVE US
SOME RELIEF.
AND AND THAT WE WOULD BE GLADLY
WORK ON A LONGER TERM.
AFTER REFORM UNDERSTOOD.
WELL I'M A I'LL LEAVE THAT FINAL
DECISION TO THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
FOR HOW YOU WANT TO PROCEED MY
PREFERENCE THE PLAN A WHICH IS
OLD.
DO SOME WORK -- SEE WERE WE GET
BUT IF YOU AND TAKE IT TO A VOTE
BY ALL MEANS.
YOU KNOW ALLOW THE COMMITTEE
DISCRETION DID VOTE HOW THEY ARE
THEY WITH MISTER CHAIR I AM OPEN
TO THAT I'VE ALWAYS BEEN OPEN TO
WORKING WITH.
ALL PARTIES TO TRY TO FIND A
GOOD SOUND.
PLACE TO LAND ON SOLID POLICY I
THINK THAT'S WHAT THIS IS IS A
BILL THAT NEEDS TO DRIVE A GOOD
SOUND LEVEL OF THE DIRECTION OF
POLICY -- WE DID LOOK AT A YOU
KNOW FROM A A DISTRICT WIDE
COMPONENT BUT AS DISTRICT WIDE
IT BECAME APPARENT THAT THERE
WERE OTHER -- LAKES DAMS AND
INSPECTIONS THAT WERE.
ALSO EQUALLY IN THE SAME --
SPHERE AS YOU SAW IN THE
EVIDENCE THAT WAS PRESENTED. TO
WE WOULD BE WILLING TO WORK WITH
THE CHAIR AND THE STAFF AND THE
COMMITTEE.
ON OF MAKING THIS A TO YOUR BILL
AND NOT HAVE TO TAKE A VOTE ON
IT I I PREFER TO KEEP A GOOD
RECORD GOING.
I WORKING WITH THE COMMITTEE AND
AND FIND A SOLUTION. TO WITH
YOUR EFFORTS AND YOUR AGREEMENT
I'D BE WILLING TO SHAKE HANDS
AND MOVE FORWARD YOU HAVE MY
COMMITMENT ABSOLUTELY AND AND
YOU ALL AS WELL.
I KNOW THIS MATTERS YOU GREAT
DEAL THIS YEAR BUT I APPRECIATE.
THAT OFFER AND I'M GLADLY ACCEPT
AND HOW TO SOLVE IT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WILL TAKE
THAT COMMITMENT AND WILL
CONTINUE TO WORK ON IT WITH YOU
IN YOUR YOUR STAFF AND AND ALL
THE OTHER MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE THANK THANK YOU SO
MUCH NO DO APPRECIATE IT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR HEARING
NO OF COURSE OF COURSE.
I'LL HEAR MORE FROM YOU SOON
[inaudible]
WE CONTINUE.
TURNER BOARDS YOU WANNA MAKE A
QUICK COMMENT.
I DO INTO AND I WANT TO THANK
THE GENTLEMAN ON COMING OVER AND
OFFERING INSIGHT INTO THIS
PROJECT AND TO ADD TO OF COURSE.
ASSEMBLYMAN MINUTE -- BIGELOW.
HI THIS IS A VERY WORTHWHILE AND
IF.
YOU'RE SATISFIED WITH CONVERTING
THIS TO TO YOUR TO YOUR BILL --
ON THIS IS ALSO IN IN IN MY
DISTRICT I FEEL VERY STRONGLY
ABOUT THIS -- BUT WILL CERTAINLY
BE SUPPORTIVE OF MAKING GOOD
POLICY AND HAVING THAT POLICY BE
SUSTAINABLE -- SO WITH THAT TO
THE NORM I'LL BE SUPPORTIVE OF A
LEAD THAT YOU'RE OFFERING AND I
WANT TO THANK THE CHAIR.
FOR OPENING UP THE COMMITTEE AND
ON YOUR STAFF AND TRYING TO
FIGURE OUT THE BEST PASSPORT
BECAUSE SOMETHING NEEDS TO BE
DONE.
AND AGAIN THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR THE COMMITMENT SENATOR AND
AND AND MISTER CHAIR JUST TO
RECOGNIZE WITHOUT WITHOUT SOME
KIND OF ADJUSTMENT OR ARE WE
FULL HEARTED EFFORT IN IN MAKING
SOME.
SOME CHANGER WE COULD BE FACING.
OUR A REAL LEGACY ISSUE THAT
WILL CHANGE THE LANDSCAPE OF OUR
COMMUNITIES ARE EVER MORE.
SO THANK YOU FOR YOUR COMMITMENT
THANK YOU SIR.
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU APPRECIATE
IT OKAY -- SORRY ONCE
.
OKAY -- WE'RE GONNA KEEP
PROCEEDING HERE A NEXT IN THE
FILE ORDERS -- IT SOMEWHERE Là
MON EIGHTY FOUR OH NINE THANK
YOU BOTH FOR YOUR PATIENCE --
ALL THREE OF YOU NOW -- GOOD
AFTERNOON.
THAT AFTERNOON THANK YOU CHAIR
AND MEMBERS.
I WANT TO BEGIN BY ACCEPTING THE
COMMITTEES AMENDMENTS AB FOUR OH
NINE HAS RECEIVED BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT IN THE ASSEMBLY AND HAS
NO OPPOSITION.
IT WOULD IS COMPETITIVE GRANT TO
DEVELOP CLIMB ADAPTATION TOOLS
RESOURCES AND TRAININGS FOR
FARMERS AND RANCHERS ACROSS
CALIFORNIA PLAN FOR CLIMATE
CHANGE I HAVE WITH ME TODAY TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL
LESLIE ROACH ASSISTING
COOPERATIVE.
EXTENSION SPECIALIST IN
RANGELAND SCIENCE AMENDMENT AT
UC DAVIS.
AND IN ADDITION TO BRIAN SHOW BE
CASE YOU HAVE ANY.
THANK YOU ISN'T SUPPORT WELL AS
YOU TO START A PERIOD HELLO TURN
MEMBERS AT BRANCH OF THE
CALIFORNIA CLIMATE AGRICULTURE
NETWORK.
OUR ORGANIZATION OF FARMERS
RANCHERS SCIENTISTS AND SUSTAIN
LAG ALLIES.
ARE OFFERING THE SERVICE
SPONSORED THIS BILL.
I'M AS PART OF OUR MISSION TO
ENSURE THE FARMERS RANCHERS HAVE
THE RESOURCES THEY NEED TO BE
CLIMATE RESILIENT.
I'M SO DOES NOT AS YOURSELF
SENATOR I GREW UP IN A FARMING
FAMILY AND I THINK WE CAN BOTH
THE TEST THE FACT THAT NO ONE
CHECKS THE WEATHER MORE THAN
FARMERS.
IT'S BECAUSE THEIR LIVELIHOODS
IN THEIR DAILY DECISIONS DEPEND
UPON IT.
AS WE KNOW WEATHER PATTERNS ARE
CHANGING.
AND POST SOME SEVERE THREATS TO
OUR SECURITY IN A RURAL
ECONOMIES.
AS A COUPLE EXAMPLES -- BASED ON
RECENT STUDIES FROM.
CALIFORNIA BASED SCIENTISTS BUT
THEN FOR DECADES YIELDS FOR
ALMONDS GRAPES AND ORANGES ARE
PREDICTED TO DECLINE BY UP 220%.
BROUGH CUTTERS GENERAL PARTNER
IN YOUR AREA.
THEY'RE EXPECTED TO DECLINE OVER
40%.
I'M IN CENTRAL VALLEY ECARDS A
SUITABLE FOR SOME OF OUR TOP
CROPS IN THE STATE -- WALNUTS
AND STONE FOR ITS ARE PROJECTED
TO BE CUT IN HALF IN JUST THIRTY
YEARS.
I THINK KERN COUNTY FARMER PUT
IT BEST WHEN HE SAID WE ARE
ALWAYS AT THE MERCY OF MOTHER
NATURE.
BUT WITH THE TIME A CLICK A
CHANGING CLIMATE WHAT LIES CLOSE
ON THE HORIZON IS UNPRECEDENTED.
SO I CAN TELL YOU FROM
CONVERSATIONS WITH OVER SIXTY
GROWERS AND AG INDUSTRY
PROFESSIONALS LAST FALL.
FARMERS DON'T FEEL LIKE THEY
HAVE THE TRAINING THE
INFORMATION OF THE TOOLS TO HELP
THEM UNDERSTAND ASSESS AND
QUANTIFY THESE NEW RISKS.
NORTHERN ABOUT ALL OF THE GREAT
EMERGING RESEARCH ON ADAPTATION
STRATEGIES.
AND SO -- THIS BILL RESPONSE TO
THE IN THE CLEAR NEED THEY HAVE
FOR AG ADAPTATION PLANNING
DECISION SUPPORT TOOLS.
I JUST WANNA KNOW FOR THE
COMMITTEES THESE TOOLS HAVE BEEN
CREATED IN AND SUCCESSFULLY
DEPLOYED FOR OTHER REGIONS OF
THE U. S. -- AS JUST ONE
COMPELLING EXAMPLE IN THE
SOUTHEAST U. S. THEY'VE
DEVELOPED A TOOL CALLED AGAR
CLIMATE.
THAT INCLUDES A REAL TIME
DISEASE RISK ALERT SYSTEM FOR
STRAWBERRY GROWERS.
AND AFTER THE LAST FOUR SEASONS
OF TESTING IT'S REDUCE FUNGICIDE
APPLICATIONS BY HALF AND SAVE
TERMS OF THE FOUR HUNDRED
DOLLARS PER ACRE.
THAT'S THE KIND OF TOOL WOULD BE
GREAT FAR STRONGER INDUSTRY IN
CALIFORNIA.
I'M SO THIS BILL WOULD FUNDS A
SIMILAR TOOLS TAILORED FOR OUR
GROWERS.
AND I KNOW THERE'S LOTS OF OTHER
ADAPTATION BILLS OUT THERE BUT I
THINK THIS ONE IS RESPONDING TO
A A SPECIFIC URGENT NEED.
A LOW COST.
AND THE WE SHOULD START THEIR
STEP.
PASSED AFTER DR ROACH THANKS.
AFTERNOON.
AS A CORPORATE EXTENSION
SPECIALIST WITH RANCHERS AND
LAND MANAGERS ACROSS CALIFORNIA
AND HAVE SEEN THE IMPACTS ENGINE
CLIMATE HAS HAD ON THESE
COMMUNITIES. FOR EXAMPLE
LIVESTOCK PRODUCERS WERE AMONG
THE FIRST IN THE AGRICULTURAL
COMMUNITY THAT WERE IMPACTED BY
OUR RECENT STATEWIDE DROUGHT I'M
DOING IS UNPRECEDENTED TIME.
RANCHERS IN THE HARDEST HIT
REGIONS OF OUR STATE I TO MAKE
SUBSTANTIAL HEARD REDUCTIONS
WITH SOME COMPLETELY LIQUIDATING.
EXTREME EVENTS LIKE EXTENDED
DROUGHT SO SIGNIFICANT AND
CUMULATIVE CHALLENGES FOR
SUSTAINING CALIFORNIA'S RANCHES
AND RANGE LANDS.
AND WITH A MORE VARIABLE CLIMATE
FUTURE THESE CHALLENGES WILL
CONTINUE PARTICULARLY FOR THE
NEXT GENERATION.
THERE IS A CLEAR AN IMMEDIATE
NEED TO CENTRALIZE AND HIGHLIGHT
THE MOST RELEVANT AND TIMELY
KNOWLEDGE IN TRANSLATE THIS INTO
ACCESSIBLE FORMATS.
DE DIGITALLY MANAGERS NEED
SCIENCE BASED DECISION SUPPORT
TOOLS AND TRAINING TO HELP
ASSESS RISK.
AND ADAPT TO CHANGING CONDITIONS.
THE CALIFORNIA RANGELAND ROUTE
HUB IS ONE EXAMPLE OF SUCCESSFUL
EFFORT THAT INCREASES --
EXISTING RESEARCH AND OUTREACH
RESOURCES -- AND SERVES AS A
CENTER FOR SCIENCE BASED
COMMUNICATION ON RANGELAND
DROUGHT SPECIFICALLY.
IS MULTIMEDIA HUB HAS EXPANDED
ACCESS TO TIMELY MANAGEMENT AND
POLICY RELEVANT RESEARCH TO A
GROWING DIVERSITY OF RANGELAND
DECISION MAKERS INCLUDING ROUTE --
RANCHERS OF RANGELAND --
CONSERVATIONISTS AND LAND
MANAGERS TO PRESERVE AND LEARN --
FROM ON THE GROUND EXPERIENCE IS
THE HUB ALSO HOSTS AUDIO STORIES
FROM THE STATE'S RANCHING AND
FARMING FAMILIES THAT ARE
IMPACTED BY CLIMATE CHANGE NOW.
THE CALIFORNIA RANCHING LIKE
CALIFORNIA OUR CULTURE IN
GENERAL IT'S DIVERSE IT'S
COMPLEX AND IT IS UNIQUELY
VULNERABLE TO CLIMATE RISKS.
REDUCE VULNERABILITY ACROSS ALL
TYPES OF OPERATIONS SCIENTISTS
AND THE AGRICULTURAL COMMUNITY
MUST WORK TOGETHER TO CO DEVELOP
DECISION TOOLS THAT ARE LOCALLY
RELEVANT AND THAT ARE USABLE.
ADDITIONAL UNJUSTLY TARGETED
TRAINING IS ESSENTIAL TO
INCREASING CAPACITY AMONG THE
AGRICULTURAL AND NATURAL
RESOURCE PROFESSIONALS TO MEET
VERY INVOLVING ROLES AS WELL
SUPPORT THE NEEDS OF A GROWING
AND DIVERSE CLIENTELE.
MAKE STRATEGIC DECISIONS IN A
CHANGING ENVIRONMENT THANK YOU
THANK YOU SO MUCH OTHERS IN
SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON THERESA BURKE ON
BEHALF THE CALIFORNIA COMPOST
COALITION IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU TO CROWDED WITH NOT TO
RESOURCES DEFENSE COUNCIL HERE
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU SO MUCH.
MICHAEL GREEN CDS CONSULTING OF
REPRESENTING CALIFORNIA STATE
GRANGE OR THE OLDEST OR
AGRICULTURAL BASED ORGANIZATIONS
IN THE STATE HAS BEEN GOING FOR
A HUNDRED AND FORTY FIVE YEARS.
THE HAS -- ABOUT NINETY THREE
HALL LOCATED IN KNOWN FORTY ONE
COUNTIES IN CALIFORNIA.
AN ALMOST OF LEGISLATIVE
DISTRICTS.
WE ARE RURAL COMMUNITY BASED.
WE STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL
THANK YOU.
OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
TING NINE IN OPPOSITION.
BEING MENTAL BRING BACK TO DIS
MEMBERS COMMENT QUESTION
[inaudible]
CONCERN.
AWAY IN.
A BILL -- WANT TO JOIN YOU AS A
CO AUTHOR OF AT THE
PROPRIOCEPTIVE AND FRUSTRATION
NO.
IS THAT EVERY YEAR NATURAL
WORKING LANDS IT'S THE SHORT END
OF THE STICK IN THE GREENHOUSE
GAS REDUCTION FUND
APPROPRIATIONS AND HAPPEN AGAIN
THIS YEAR [inaudible]
SO.
JUST LIKE WE'RE TALKING NOW THAT
I'VE TATIAN ADAPTATION IN THIS
CONTEXT.
IS GONNA BE THE TIP OF THE SPEAR
THE WATER CRISIS THAT WE'RE
GONNA BE FACING.
I'M I'M SCARED ABOUT INTER
COUNTY.
CENTRAL VALLEY ALL THROUGHOUT
THE STATE WE GOT TO GET AHEAD OF
THIS ONE SO.
I CONSIDER THIS A SORT OF A A
PROMISE THAT HAS TO BE.
FILLED IN FUTURE YEARS IF WE CAN
GET THIS THING PASSED BUT VERY
SOUND FRAMEWORK RESHAPE THE
INPUT.
AND WE'VE GOT A GROUND THIS ALSO
IN PHYSICAL TERMS WE STILL DON'T
HAVE QUANTIFIED AS THE STATE
WITH THE AGGRO WITH THE NET
ECONOMIC IMPACT THE STATE'S
GONNA BE FOR AGRICULTURE SO.
OFFICE WE DEVELOP THAT WE CAN
JUSTIFY A BIGGER NUMBER IN THE
FUTURE BUT OF THAT YEAH SO WE'LL
WORK ON THAT TOGETHER AND I WILL
ENTERTAIN A MOTION AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME OR JUST LEAVE
THEM.
OKAY SO MOTION FROM SENATOR
JONES ALL I YOU TO OF I RESPECT
LAST NIGHT OKAY THANK YOU SO
MUCH.
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
THE AGRICULTURE COMMITTEE UP
PLEASE CALL ROLE.
IN IS STERN HI AND I JONES JONES
I ALLEN OR JUST.
OR JUST AYE CABALLERO HERTZBERG.
HUESO JACKSON MONEY PHONE CALL
WITH A VERY GOOD WILL LEAVE THE
MEASURE ON CALL THANK YOU SO
MUCH [inaudible]
I'M.
NEXT IN THE OFFICIAL ORDER
[inaudible]
MURATSUCHI [inaudible]
ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
JEEZ THOSE WAITING. TO BRING YOU
BACK.
IN A BIT.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GOOD AFTERNOON.
CHAIRMAN [inaudible]
SERVICE.
I'M HERE TO PRESENT TO ASSEMBLY
BILL.
NINE TWELVE ON BEHALF OF THE
STATE LANDS COMMISSION THIS BILL
WILL ALLOW THE STATE LANDS
COMMISSION. TO CONTINUE TO
PROTECT CALIFORNIA'S OCEAN
ECOSYSTEM.
BY FIGHTING THE INTRODUCTION OF
A MARINE INVASIVE SPECIES INTO
OUR WATERS.
INVASIVE SPECIES ACCOUNT FOR UP
TO A HUNDRED TWENTY BILLION
DOLLARS PER YEAR ACROSS THE
COUNTRY IN ECONOMIC LOSSES.
INVASIVE SPECIES DISRUPT.
SHIPPING OPERATIONS AS WELL AS
COMMERCIAL FISHING.
AND DAMAGE NAVE NATIVE HABITATS
AND SPECIES.
THIS BILL WILL ALLOW THE
SHIPPING INDUSTRY ADDITIONAL
TIME. TO DEVELOP THE TECHNOLOGY
NECESSARY TO MAKE CALIFORNIA
STRONG ENVIRONMENTAL STANDARDS
AND AT THE SAME TIME.
THIS BILL GIVE THE STATE LANDS
COMMISSION THE AUTHORITY TO
ENFORCE FEDERAL STANDARDS WHILE
COLLECTING DATA O STRENGTHEN.
THOSE STANDARDS GOING FORWARD.
WITH ME HERE TODAY IS SHERRY
PEMBERTON BUT THE STATE LANDS
COMMISSION. TO THAT TEST PLANS
FOR THE BILL.
THANK YOU SO MUCH WELCOME IS
MEMBERS.
THANK YOU SHERRI PEMBERTON ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA STATE
LANDS COMMISSION WHERE THE
SPONSOR OF AB NINE TWELVE AND IN
STRONG SUPPORT.
IT RESPONSE TO SOME RECENT
ACTION AT THE FEDERAL LEVEL
REGARDING OUR MARINE INVASIVE
SPECIES PROGRAM AND REGULATING
BALLAST WATER DISCHARGES IN
STATE WATERS.
AND AS THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER SAID
WE FEEL THAT IT POSITIONS
CALIFORNIA TO GET THE BEST
INFORMATION AND DATA. TO HELP
PROTECT OUR WATERS AND FIGHT FOR
THE STRONGEST POSSIBLE STANDARDS
SO WE ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH OTHERS IN
SUPPORT. THREE SEPARATE ON
BEHALF OF KILL THE BAY IN
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
OTHERS IN SUPPORT SEEING NONE.
AND IN OPPOSITION [inaudible]
BEING. NINE TO THE DISSECTION.
OR YOU OKAY WITH THE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS YES OKAY VERY GOOD --
APPRECIATE YOUR WORK AND STATE
LANDS COMMISSIONS WORK ON ON
THIS.
BUT THESE MEMORIES WILL BE TAKEN
ANY Q. DUE TO THE DOOR FOR ALL
TIME I JUST TO BE CLEAR ABOUT
THAT.
I MEMBERS YOU HAVE ANY QUESTIONS
COMMENTS.
ENTERTAIN MOTIONS IF.
OKAY MOTION FROM THE VICE CHAIR
A LADY CLOSER THAT'S VERY AYE
VOTE VERY GOOD THANK YOU SO THE
MOTION IS TO PASS THE
ENVIRONMENTAL QUALITY COMMITTEE
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
DENNIS TURN BY TURN AYE JONES
JONES I ALLEN FORGES.
BRIDGES I CABALLERO HERTZBERG
HUESO JACKSON AND MONEY.
RESERVE OKAY FIGURE WILL LEAVE A
MEASURE ON CALL THANK YOU ALL SO
MUCH [inaudible]
I'M.
COMING RIGHT UP [inaudible]
REMEMBER RIVAS.
APOLOGIZE A MEMBER CARILLO
YOU'RE JUST.
NUMBER SEVENTEEN WILL GET.
TO WORKING AS A MEMBER.
GOOD AFTERNOON GOOD AFTERNOON
THE COMMITTEE [inaudible]
THIS CHAIR.
SENATORS COLLEAGUES -- WANNA
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
BE HERE THIS AFTERNOON TO
PRESENT ASSEMBLY BILL.
NINE THREE SIX AND I WANT TO
THANK THE COMMITTEE STAFF FOR
THE WORK OF PREPARING THE NOW
SAYS AND I DO ACCEPT.
THE AMENDMENT SO I APPRECIATE.
THAT ANALYSIS AND I ALSO WANT TO
THANK ALL THE STAKEHOLDERS TO
STAKEHOLDERS WHO ENGAGED.
OUR STAFF AND MYSELF ON THIS
BILL FROM DAY.
ONE I'M PLEASED TO HAVE REMOVED
NEARLY ALL OPPOSITION AND SO --
CERTAINLY -- EXCITED ABOUT THAT.
AND SO THIS LEGISLATION IT
PROPOSES TO ENHANCE -- OIL
TRANSPORTATION SAFETY IN OUR
STATE -- AND IT DOES SO BY FIRST
MAKING SURE THAT WE DEFINE NON
FLOATING OIL IN STATUTE.
AND SECOND ENSURING THAT SAFETY
STANDARDS.
ARE REGULARLY UPDATED TO
INCORPORATE THE BEST POSSIBLE
TOOLS. FOR CLEANUP OF NON
FLOATING OIL.
YOU KNOW LOOK I I KNOW THAT.
EVERYONE IN THIS ROOM --
UNDERSTAND THAT HERE IN
CALIFORNIA OUR STATE WE ARE
BLESSED WITH AN WITH INCREDIBLE
NATURAL RESOURCES.
YOU KNOW A BOOK I READ -- A FEW
MONTHS AGO HIGHLIGHTED THIS FACT.
ONE ONE PART OF THE BOOK IT
SUGGESTED THAT OUR NICKNAME THE
GOLDEN STATE.
EVOKES A DISTINCTIVE AN
UNUSUALLY -- A BEAUTIFUL NATURAL
ENVIRONMENT.
NO LAND NO STATE.
HAS BEEN MORE OFTEN ASSOCIATED
WITH THE EVOCATIVE TERM PARADISE.
IN CALIFORNIA.
AND THEN IN OUR STATE WE HAVE A
VERY LONG HISTORY.
AS A STATE OF PROTECTING OUR
NATURAL ENVIRONMENT.
OF PROTECTING OUR PUBLIC HEALTH
IN OUR SAFETY.
AND THERE IS NO DENYING
[inaudible]
THAT.
HERE TWO THOUSAND AND NINETEEN
MORE AND MORE HEAVY CRUDE OIL.
LIKE THE CANADIAN TAR SANDS OIL
CRUDE STOCKS FROM VENEZUELA AND
MEXICO.
ARE BEING TRANSPORTED TO OUR
STATE AND TRANSPORTED BY WAY
PIPELINE INTEGRITY.
AND BECAUSE OF OUR LOCATION AND
SPECIALIZED REFINING CAPACITY.
CALIFORNIA WE ARE A DESTINATION
FOR NEW SUPPLIES OF THIS NON
VOTING OIL.
UNFORTUNATELY CURRENT STATE LAW
IT DOES NOT SUFFICIENTLY ACCOUNT
FOR SPILLS.
OF NON FOR NOW.
AND THIS CREATES SIGNIFICANT
REST FOR OUR STATE AND IN
PARTICULAR RISK FOR OUR COASTAL
AREAS AND THE COMMUNITIES HERE
IN CALIFORNIA.
SAFETY AND PREPAREDNESS IS
IMPORTANT WHEN IT COMES THIS
ISSUE AND I BELIEVE THE
COMMITTEE ANALYSIS HIGHLIGHTED
THIS VERY WELL.
BECAUSE WE CAN ALL LEARN FROM
THE STATE OF MICHIGAN.
WHEN THE TWO THOUSAND AND TEN A
RUPTURED PIPELINE?
RESULTED IN A SPILL INTO THE
KALAMAZOO RIVER.
THIS BILL OF MORE THAN EIGHT
HUNDRED AND FORTY THOUSAND
GALLONS OF NON VOTING CANADIAN
TAR SANDS OIL.
THIS WAS CITED AS THE LARGEST
OIL SPILL YOU'VE NEVER HEARD OF
REMEDIATION OF THIS BILL TOOK
FIVE YEARS.
COST OVER A BILLION DOLLARS.
ACCORDING TO US AGENCIES TOTAL
CLEANUP PROVED IMPOSSIBLE THE
CONTAMINATION REMAINS TO THIS
DAY.
ASSEMBLY BILL.
NINE THREE SIX IS ABOUT SAFETY
AND PREPAREDNESS.
AGAIN THIS LEGISLATION MANDATES
AN UPDATE OF CALIFORNIA'S -- THE
CONTINGENCY PLANNING TO ENSURE.
TO ENSURE THAT THE OFFICE OF THE
SPILL PREVENTION AND RESPONSE
OSCAR IS ADEQUATELY PREPARED TO
DEAL WITH SPILLS OF THESE NON
VOTING OILS.
OIL THE MOST LIKELY TO CAUSE
LASTING DAMAGE TO OUR MARINE
ENVIRONMENT OUR WATER WAYS
PUBLIC HEALTH AND CERTAINLY.
IRAQ.
IT DID IT WILL IMPACT.
THIS GOLDEN STANDARD WE HAVE SET --
OF FROM OUR THE ON A NATURAL
RESOURCES PERSPECTIVE THIS
INCREDIBLE CASTLINE WE HAVE IT
WILL FUNDAMENTALLY ALTER THAT.
SO I APPRECIATE THE TIME TO
SHARE.
AND I DO HAVE SPONSORS HERE AND
WE'LL OTHER TO DO A VERY GOOD
THANK YOU SIMILAR. TO THOSE IN
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU -- BUT JUST AS HE IF
POSSIBLE YOU CAN BE BRIEF
SOMEONE.
IF YOU LIKE.
OKAY.
I THINK WE'RE GONNA HAVE HEAVY
OPPOSITION.
THANK THANK YOU APPRECIATE THAT
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS -- BUT I CAN BURKE WITH
CENSUS KOBE KEEPER HERE IN
SUPPORT OF AB.
I THIRTY SIX I WANT TO THANK THE
MEMBER RIVAS FOR HIS LEADERSHIP
ON THIS ISSUE -- TEXAS KOBE IS
UNDER THREAT.
ACTUALLY FROM THESE I'M FROM
FROM HEAVY OILS AND TAR SANDS
AND THE OTHER HERE WE ALSO
SOMETHING OR YOU JUST.
MENTIONED IT HAS IS THE LA AREA --
ALONG BEACH -- THOSE
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES IN
THOSE AREAS ARE ESPECIALLY UNDER
THREAT -- SMALLER SPILLS TEND TO
HAPPEN YOUR WORKS -- AND THOSE
CAN HAVE BIG IMPACTS LIKE
IMPACTS BELT AND HELLO -- ON THE
BAY WHERE -- I CITY OF A HUNDRED
TWENTY THOUSAND PEOPLE WAS
ORDERED TO SHELTER INDOORS
BECAUSE OF THIS BILL.
ABOUT TWO YEARS AGO SO -- THESE
GUYS JUST BILLS HAVE VOLATILE
COMPOUNDS THEY GET INTO THE AIR
AND THAT'S WHAT COST --
INSTANTLY HEALTH SO.
WE'RE GROPING TODAY -- MAKE
THINGS A LOT SAFER FOR THOSE
COMMITTEE SAN FOR CALIFORNIA IS
ALL -- SO I RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR IDOL.
THANK YOU SIR.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS I'M JENNIFER SCHEME WITH
THE NATURIST WORST AND COUNSEL
HERE IN SUPPORT OF AB.
NINE THIRTY SIX THIS BILL IS A
REALLY VITAL PRUDENT MEASURE TO
ADDRESS THE THREATS THAT NON
POLLUTING WILL SUPPOSED TO
CALIFORNIA'S COMMUNITIES.
ECONOMY AND AS ALREADY MENTIONED
THE ICONIC GOLD COAST.
HI IT'S AN ESSENTIAL STARTING
POINT FOR BETTER PREPARING
CALIFORNIA FOR THE UNIQUE AND
SIGNIFICANT CHALLENGES FROM A
SPELL OF NON POLLUTING OIL --
OFF THE COAST OR INDOOR STATES
RIVERS LAKES OR PAYS.
THE THREAT OF NON FLOATING OIL
SPILLS IS ALREADY PRESENT AND
WILL LIKELY GROW.
PROPOSED INFRASTRUCTURE OUTSIDE
THE STATE SUCH AS THE RECENTLY
APPROVED TRANS MOUNTAIN PIPELINE
IN CANADA CREATE A STRONG
LIKELIHOOD OF INCREASED IMPORTS
OF THIS WELL TO REFINERIES IN
LOS ANGELES AND SAN FRANCISCO.
AS I ALREADY MENTIONED THE
PEOPLE MICHIGAN LEARNED ALL TOO
WELL IN TWENTY TEN AND GET ON
NON FOLDING WILL IS UNIQUELY
DIFFICULT TO CONTAIN IT.
AFTER A SPELL THIS BILL
CLARIFIES CALIFORNIA LAW TO
ACCOUNT FOR THESE CHALLENGES
ENSURING STATE AGENCIES AND
SMALL RESPONDERS HAVE
CONTINGENCY PLANNING EXPERTISE.
RESOURCES AND EQUIPMENT TO
RESPOND RAPIDLY AND EFFECTIVELY
IN THE EVENT A LARGE NON
FLOATING UP OIL SPILL -- THIS
BILL ALSO CREATES NON VOTING
WILL CERTIFICATION FOR STILL
RESPOND HERS AND LEASES
RESPONSIBILITY FOR SCHOOL
PREPAREDNESS ON THE OPERATORS.
MOVING THE OIL INTO THE STATE'S
ABOUT IT THIS BILL DOES OCCUR I
IMPACTS CAN BE MITIGATED AS
QUICKLY AND EFFECTIVELY AS
POSSIBLE
IGNORING THIS CRITICAL THREAT
THAT NON VOTING WILL POSES TO
CALIFORNIA'S ENVIRONMENT AND
COMMUNITIES WOULD BE REALLY
DANGEROUS AND SHORT SIGHTED.
EIGHTY NINE THIRTY SIX STARTS TO
BRING CALIFORNIA LAW UP TO DATE
TO ADDRESS THIS THREAT.
AND COULD MEAN THE DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN A CONTAINS BILL AND
CATASTROPHE FOR CALIFORNIANS
PRECIOUS NATURAL RESOURCES AND
CITIZENS -- WITH BANK ASSEMBLY
MEMBER RIVAS FOR OFFERING THIS
BILL AND RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
DRIED OUT.
THANK YOU SO MUCH OTHERS IN
SUPPORT. THREE SEPARATE ON
BEHALF OF HILL THE BAY IN
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
BRENNAN DAWSON ARMY OFFICER
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT THANK.
KATHY CARED BEHALF OF THREE
FIFTY BAY AREA ACTION AND ALSO
BENICIA INS FOR SAFE AND HEALTHY
COMMUNITY.
YOU SO MUCH.
MELISSA ROMERO WITH THE
CALIFORNIA LEAGUE OF
CONSERVATION VOTERS IN SUPPORT.
VERY MUCH AS IN SUPPORT.
BEING NINE IN OPPOSITION
[inaudible]
TEAM [inaudible] ONE ONE SHARE.
SEVEN IN WELCOME BUT AFTERNOON
MISTER CHAIRMAN HOW YOU DOING
THIS AFTERNOON.
MORNING GOOD AFTERNOON MEMBERS
P. ANTHONY THOMAS ROBINSON THE
CALIFORNIA INDEPENDENT PETROLEUM
ASSOCIATION LET ME.
START BY SAYING.
THAT IT IS BEEN ACTUAL JOY TO
WORK WITH THE MISTER RIVAS.
A MAN OF HIS WORD.
I'M A PERSON AND A PERSON WHO IS
NOT ONLY LISTENED. TO OUR
OPPOSITION BUT ACTUALLY ACCEPTED.
MANY OF OUR SUGGESTION THAT
REMOVING ELEMENTS OF THE BILL.
I NEED TO AND I HAVE TO SAY --
AFTER THE START.
WE DO HAVE  CHALLENGE NOT SO
MUCH WITH THE BILL BUT WITH THE
AMENDMENT.
ARE REPLACE AVAILABLE TECHNOLOGY.
VERSE.
BEST ACHIEVABLE TECHNOLOGY.
THE BEST AVAILABLE TECHNOLOGY
MEANS PRESENT TENSE.
WHAT WE HAVE CURRENTLY IN OUR
HANDS BEST ACHIEVABLE SAYS?
CHASING SOMETHING THAT IN FACT.
DO WE RECEIVE IT DO WE OBTAIN IT
OR DO WE NOT.
THAT BEING THE CASE MISTER
CHAIRMAN WE HAVE MOVED OUR
OPPOSITION BUT I JUST FIND IT
VERY INTERESTING THAT THE
PROPONENTS.
OF THOSE GIVE ME THAT THE
SUPPORT OF THE BILL
ORGANIZATIONS TO MY RIGHT AND
THOSE WHO HAVE.
CAME UP IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
WILL IN FACT SUPPORT
[inaudible]
IMPORTING [inaudible]
OIL.
VERSUS THE SOUTH PRODUCTION OF
WHAT WE DO HERE IN THE STATE.
AND THE MOST SAFEST.
ANIMALS ANIMALS CLEAN IS WAY IN
A WIN AND NOT ONLY IN THE NATION.
WE ARGUE IN THE WORLD.
SO AGAIN I DO FIND IT A BIT
INTERESTING THAT ACTIVISTS
ORGANIZATION SAY LET
[inaudible]
THE IMPORTATION.
OF CRUDE VERSUS PRODUCING IT
HERE AND THEY ACTUALLY CALL FOR
KEEPING IT IN THE GROUND.
I JUST FIND IT VERY INTERESTING
MISTER CHAIRMAN AND WITH THAT I
JUST WANT TO SAY WE THANKS AGAIN
AUTHOR WAS WORK AND LOOK FOR THE
CONTINUES TO WORKING WITH.
THANK YOU SO MUCH [inaudible]
ANY IN [inaudible]
FIRM OPPOSITION.
SEEING NINE BRING BACK TO THE
DAYS MEMBERS COMMENTS QUESTIONS
MOTIONS.
MOTION FROM CENTER COVER GYRO.
IT WAS A COMMENT OF INTEREST.
THE POINT OF INTEREST I BELIEVE
WAS WHAT WAS RAISED THERE.
THEIR REQUEST THERE IS A MOTION
[inaudible]
IN.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN IRA
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
SO THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO ENVIRONMENTAL QUALITY
COMMITTEE.
IN THIS WHOLE [inaudible]
ALL RIGHT.
PLEASE DUMP IN.
JUST WANTED TO A KIND OF FIGURED
OUT.
HE IS CHIEF OF OVER SEVILLA.
THAT IS THAT SOMETHING THAT THE
WAS A KEY AMENDMENT FROM EARLIER
ON IN THAT.
IS KEY TO KEEPING.
THE LANGUAGE OF HELL VERBAL.
MINUTE TO MINUTE JUST HELPED
REAL QUICK SO THE EXISTING LAW
IF YOU LOOK AT AGE SIX OF THE
BILL -- EXISTING LAW USES BEST
ACHIEVABLE TECHNOLOGY.
SO.
THAT'S DEFINED UNDER CURRENT LAW
SAID.
THIS WITHIN THIS WOULD CONFORM
TO EXISTING LAWS ALREADY IN THE
GOVERNMENT CODE AS OPPOSED TO
TRYING TO ESTABLISH A NEW
DEFINITION OF BEST AVAILABLE SO
THE INDIVIDUAL REPRESENTED --
SAID.
I WAS.
IN A PERFECT WORLD WISHING FOR A
THAT UNDERLYING -- ALLEGORY TO
BE REFORMED IF AS MANY WISHES --
I'M.
I'M NOT.
I'M NOT SURE EXACTLY BUT HOW
THAT IN WHICH HE HE'S HERE BUT I
THINK HE WAS TWENTY ALSO BROADER
ISSUE AROUND IMPORTATION AND
DOMESTIC EXTRACTION AS WELL --
BUT I DIDN'T HEAR -- NO ACTUAL
REQUEST OKAY ALL RIGHT THANKS
I'M SPEAK FROM SELF IT WOULD
YEAH YOU CAN SPEAK FOR YOURSELF
I DON'T TO SPEAK FOR YOU SIR.
I YOU PREFER IT THE OTHER WAY
YOU'D PREFER BEST AVAILABLE
SUPPOSED ACHIEVABLE.
YES THERE ARE WOOD OKAY YES OKAY
I WANT TO BE ON THE RECORD BY
SAYING THAT'S FINE.
THAT'S FINE SO JUST TO BE CLEAR
THAT THEY WOULD PREFER IT AS
BEST AVAILABLE.
WE THINK BEST ACHIEVABLE MAKES
SENSE BECAUSE IT'S BECAUSE
CONSIST WITH EXISTING LAWN
DOESN'T ADD ANY NEW DEFINITION
STATUTES OF THAT'S WHY I'M
SUPPORTING THE AMENDMENT BUT
LEAVE IT TO YOUR DISCRETION.
THANK YOU THOUGH.
COLLEGES FOR INTERACTION THERE
IS A MOTION DO PASS AS AMENDED
TO ENVIRONMENTAL QUALITY MANY
MORE CLOSE NO HERE DID YOU DID
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR OUR AYE
VOTE THANK YOU FOR THAT.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ENTER STERN
AYE STERN AYE JONES.
JONES NO ALLEN FORGES
[inaudible]
CABALLERO.
I HERTZBERG HUESO JACKSON THE
MONEY TO LINE OKAY TEN WHEN WE
WILL LEAVE THAT MEASURE ON CALL
THANK YOU SO MUCH TO EVERYONE
INVOLVED HERE.
I'M LET'S SEE FILE ORDER HERE --
FRIEDMAN YOU GET.
YOU GET NEXT.
I FOLLOWS FOURTEEN FIFTEEN
SEPTEMBER.
AND JUST TO BE CLEAR I MISS THE
BACK IN YOUR LAST PRESENTATION
WE ARE ON AB FOURTEEN FIFTEEN
AND THEN FIFTEEN SIXTEEN CORRECT
THANK YOU OKAY VERY GOOD.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS IT'S VERY NICE TO BE
BACK WITH YOU -- AB A FOURTEEN
FIFTEEN ALLOWS THE DEPARTMENT OF
WATER RESOURCES TO ENFORCE
EXISTING WATER REPORTING
REQUIREMENTS.
SOME WHICH HAVE BEEN IN PLACE
FOR DECADES.
WE'VE DONE A LOT OF WORK IN THE
LEGISLATURE SETTING UP
REQUIREMENTS FOR A PUBLIC
AGENCIES IN TERMS OF WATER
REPORTING.
MODEL EFFICIENCY WATER PERCY
LEGISLATION THAT WE DID LAST
YEAR.
OUR REQUIRES THAT TO WORK
PROPERLY BUT BECAUSE WE DON'T
HAVE AN ENFORCEMENT MECHANISM
RIGHT NOW OR A WAY TO COME HELP
REPORTING REQUIREMENTS.
WE SOMETIMES DON'T GET THOSE
REPORTS -- FROM AGENCIES MANY OF
OUR AGENCIES PROBABLY MOST OF
YOUR AGENCIES HERE IN THIS ROOM
ARE GREAT ABOUT TURNING OVER THE
REPORTS OF THE REQUIRED TO UNDER
THE LAW BUT NOT ONLY DO ALL.
AGENCIES DO OUR PURPOSE IS TO
GET COMPLIANCE WITH THIS LET'S
BE CLEAR WE WANT COMPLIANCE IS
PUT SOME TEETH -- BEHIND THOSE
REPORTING REQUIREMENTS WHEN WE
PASS LAWS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA WE EXPECT EVERYBODY
TO FOLLOW THOSE INCLUDING OUR
PUBLIC AGENCIES.
WE ALSO HAVE LEGISLATION THIS
YEAR THAT STREAMLINES REPORTING
SO THAT IT MAKES IT EASIER FOR
ALL OF THE AGENCIES TO COMPLY
AND THAT'S REALLY IMPORTANT
WE'RE GIVING THEM -- RELIEF FOR
SAY WE'RE GONNA MAKE IT A LOT
EASIER FOR YOU TO COMPLY BUT NOW
WE EXPECT YOU TO IT IF YOU DON'T
WE'RE GOING TO COMPEL COMPLIANCE
TO THIS MECHANISM.
I'M WITH THAT I'M HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS AND I I'M
HERE TODAY WITH A ROW HE SHARMA
WITH AN RTC TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT.
THANKS SO MUCH WELCOME HEY THANK
YOU GOOD AFTERNOON AT THE CAIR
AND MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY
NAME IS ARE WHO SHARMA ANDI'M
HERE WITH THE NATURAL RESOURCES
DEFENSE COUNCIL IN SUPPORT OF AB.
FOURTEEN FIFTEEN AS YOU ALREADY
KNOW AB FOURTEEN FIFTEEN
AUTHORIZES D. W. R. TO INCREASE
COMPLIANCE WITH EXISTING WATER
DATA REPORTING REQUIREMENTS THIS
BILL DOES NOT CREATE ANY NEW
REPORTING REQUIREMENTS ALL IT
DOES IS EMPOWER D. W. R.. TO
ENFORCE THE LAWS THAT ARE
ALREADY ON THE BOOKS.
IF THERE'S ONE MESSAGE THAT I
HOPE YOU TAKE AWAY FROM MY
REMARKS IT'S THIS.
DATA HAVE VALUE.
WHEN THE ENTITY IS RESPONSIBLE
FOR COMPLYING AND FOR PROVIDING
CRITICAL WATER DATA DON'T COMPLY
WITH THE LEGISLATIVELY MANDATED
REPORTING REQUIREMENTS?
THE PUBLIC IS LEFT WITH AN
INCOMPLETE AND INACCURATE
PICTURE OF HOW WATER IS USED
DISTRIBUTED AND MANAGED ACROSS
THE STATE.
WHEN 56% OF FARM GATE DELIVERY
REPORTS ARE MISSING THE
OPPORTUNITY FOR ANALYSIS AND
ACCOUNTABILITY IS STIFLED?
ADVOCACY ORGANIZATIONS AS
STUDENTS PROFESSORS THINK TANKS
CAN USE ALL OF THIS WATER DATA
TO DETERMINE PATTERNS OF WATER
USE IN OPPORTUNITIES FOR
TARGETED WATER EFFICIENCY
IMPROVEMENTS AND INVESTMENTS.
BUT WHEN 13% OF RECENT WATER
LOSS AUDIT REPORTS ARE MISSING
THOSE ANALYSES ARE INCOMPLETE.
LEGISLATORS AND POLICY MAKERS
LIKE YOURSELVES CAN USE THAT
DATA FROM THESE REPORTS TO
DETERMINE THE EFFICACY OF WATER
CONSERVATION LAWS.
BUT WHEN 65% OF ALL MODERATE
MODEL WATER EFFICIENT LANDSCAPE
ORDINANCE REPORTS ARE MISSING
THAT ADVOCACY CAN'T BE PROPERLY
CALCULATED.
WHEN WATER DATA IS ALLOWED TO
LEAK THROUGH THE CRACKS PEOPLE'S
ABILITY TO USE THAT DATA IS
STIFLED RESTRICTED AND
DIMINISHED?
THANKFULLY WE CAN FIX THE LEAKY
WATER DATA PIPELINE IN AB
FOURTEEN FIFTY PROVIDES THE TOOL
FOR D. W. R. TO INCREASE
COMPLIANCE WITH EXISTING WATER
DATA REPORTING REQUIREMENTS.
I HOPE WE CAN ALL AGREE THAT
WATER IS ONE OF THE MOST
PRECIOUS NATURAL RESOURCES IN
OUR GOLDEN STATE.
DO YOU HAVE YOU ARE CANNOT
MANAGE WHAT IT DOES NOT
EFFECTIVELY MEASURE AND SO I
URGE RESPECTFULLY AN AYE VOTE ON
FOURTEEN FIFTEEN THANK YOU SO
MUCH. FOR BEING HERE OF OTHERS
IN SUPPORT.
MELISSA ROMERO WITH THE
CALIFORNIA LEAGUE OF
CONSERVATION VOTERS IN SUPPORT.
YOU BROWN AND ASSOCIATES
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT.
ANY OTHERS IN SUPPORT BEING NINE
ANY OPPOSITION.
AFTERNOON CHAIR IN MEMBER -- I'M
JULIE HALL WITH THE ASSOCIATION
OF CALIFORNIA WATER AGENCIES --
THINK IF THE OPTION TO SPEAK ON
THIS BILL.
WHILE WE APPRECIATE THE GOAL OF
THE LEGISLATION -- WE'RE
CURRENTLY OPPOSED TO THE
APPROACH IN THE BILL.
SO I WOULD LIKE TO I THINK THE
AUTHORS OFFICE FOR CONTINUING TO
WORK WITH US TO IDENTIFY
ALTERNATE PATHWAYS REPORTING
COMPLIANCE WE DON'T HAVE AN
ISSUE WITH THE IDEA OF
INCREASING REPORTING COMPLIANCE.
I'M CURRENTLY UNDER THE BILL THE
FIRST MORNING TO A LOCAL AGENCY.
FAILING TO SUBMIT A REPORT ON
TOP.
WOULD BE A CIVIL PENALTY OF A
THOUSAND DOLLARS SO IT SEEMS
LIKE A DISPROPORTIONATELY HARSH
PENALTIES FOR FAILURE TO SUBMIT
A REPORT ON TIME -- AS A
COMEDIAN ELSE'S NOTICE IS NOT
THE ONLY POTENTIAL COMPLAINTS
MECHANISM AND WITH THE GRADUAL
APPROACH COMPLAINTS BE MORE
APPROPRIATE.
I'M WE SURE TO MEMBERS WITH THE
AUTHORS OFFICE THAT WOULD
INCLUDE IN THIS PROCESS AND
NOTIFICATION TO THE LOCAL AND
CITY OF THEIR FAILURE TO SUBMIT
A REPORT.
IN ORDER TO ALLOW THEM TIME TO
COME INTO COMPLIANCE ON THEIR
OWN BEFORE IS A CIVIL PENALTIES
ISSUE.
AND THIS ALTERNATE WOULD ALLOW
THE LOCAL ENTITY TO CORRECT
THEIR MISTAKE WITHOUT HARSH
PENALTIES.
WOULD LIKELY INCREASE OVERALL
REPORTING COMPLIANCE I WOULD
LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUING TO
WORK WITH THE AUTHOR AND HER
STAFF AND MORE GRADUAL APPROACH
TO COMPLIANCE.
AND GIVE MUCH ANY OTHERS IN
OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
BARBARY WITH THREE GOVERNMENT
RELATIONS.
ON BEHALF FIRST WITH ELDORADO
YOUR GAZE AND DISTRICT DOESN'T
WATER AGENCY.
WE ECHO THE COMMENTS OF THE
ASSOCIATION CALIFORNIA WATER
AGENCIES.
AS TO THE VALLEY ATWATER
COALITION OPPOSITION IT'S UNLESS
AMENDED.
EXISTING LAW BUT WITH RESPECT
FARM GATE MEASUREMENT.
DOES NOT REQUIRE.
MEASUREMENT WHEN IT'S NOT
LOCALLY COST EFFECTIVE SO WE
HAVE ASKED THE THE AUTHOR AND
HER STFF TO CONSIDER AN
AMENDMENT.
IN THE EXCEPTIONS PORTION OF THE
BILL.
WHERE A LOCAL AGENCY WOULD BE
ABLE TO DEMONSTRATE THAT FARM
GATE MEASUREMENT IS NOT LOCALLY
COST EFFECTIVE?
IN THOSE SITUATIONS OF FINE.
WOULD NOT BE IMPOSED
[inaudible]
YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
MANY OTHERS IN OPPOSITION.
BEING NO BRING BACK THE DIET --
AND WHAT -- WE SUPPORTING THE
BILL TODAY SHOULD YOU BRING IT
BOARD FRAMEWORK BILLS LAST YEAR
[inaudible]
CRITICAL.
WILL PROBABLY BE WRESTLING WITH
SOME OF THESE ISSUES AND
JUDICIARY.
ARMS OF MECHANICS AND EXAMINE
SOME OF THESE ISSUES.
AROUND TIMING AND NOTICE AND BUT
ON THE WHOLE I THINK.
THE SOUND MEASURE AND BY YOU TO
CLOSE YOUR WELCOME TO RESPOND TO
ANY OF THE OPPOSITION IN YOUR
CLOTHES IF YOU LIKE BUT I WOULD
JUST I WOULD JUST SAY THAT -- WE
HAVE TO END DISCRETION FOR D. W.
ARE IN TERMS OF ENFORCEMENT AS
WELL AS OFF RAMPS -- FOR VARIOUS
ISSUES THAT MIGHT COME UP WITH
THESE AGENCIES SO THAT D. W. R..
DOES HAVE A PROCESS BY WHICH
THEY COULD HEAR IF THERE WAS AN
EQUIPMENT -- PROBLEM OR THEY
DON'T HAVE TO ISSUE THE PENALTY --
BUT GIVEN THE STREAMLINING THAT
WE'RE DOING WITH REPORTING
REQUIREMENTS THERE REALLY IS YOU
KNOW NOT A LOT OF EXCUSE FOR NOT.
NOT -- BEING ABLE TO FILE IN
AGAIN YOU W. R. DOES HAVE
DISCRETION WHEN IT COMES TO THE
PENALTIES.
YOU REMIND ME AGAIN BUT YOU IN
ANOTHER BILL FOUND IN ADDITION
SEE AND HAVE YES THAT THAT YOU
CAN.
YOU CAN USE YOUR URBAN WATER
MANAGEMENT PLANNING WELL THAT
THAT WE HAVE ANOTHER BILL THAT'S
PASSING THROUGH THE LEGISLATURE
RIGHT NOW THAT WILL -- BASICALLY
STREAMLINED THE REPORTING SO
THAT THEY ONLY HAVE TO DO IT
EITHER ONCE OR TWICE A YEAR TO
RATHER THAN HAVING ALL AND
THAT'S FOR ALL SORT OF WATER
REPORT SO INSTEAD OF HAVING ONE
DO THIS MONTH AND ONE TWO AND
THREE MONTHS.
YOU CAN SORT OF EITHER DO IT
ONCE A YEAR OR TWICE A YEAR ALL
AT ONCE WHICH SHOULD MAKE THINGS
A LOT EASIER. FOR THEM SO THEY
SHOULD BE AN EXCUSE FOR SORT OF
ACCIDENTALLY MISSING ONE OF YOUR
DEADLINES.
THANKS THAT -- I WOULD ENTERTAIN
A MOTION BUT IF THERE IS NOT ONE
AT THIS TIME WE'LL JUST.
BUT YOU MOVE ON WITH YOUR DAY
AND WE'LL CONSIDERATION YEAH
WE'LL GO IN THE NEXT.
ONE VERY GOOD YOU HAVE A MOTION --
WILL MOVE ON THE FIFTEEN AB.
FIFTEEN SIXTEEN YES YOU MEMBERS
I'M NOT GOING TO GO INTO DETAIL
ABOUT THE WILDFIRE CRISIS THAT
WE'RE HAVING AND HOW -- DRASTIC
ELEMENTS BE COMMON I'M SURE
YOU'VE HEARD A LOT OF BILLS IN
THIS AREA I WILL JUST SAY THAT
ONE OF THE POINTS OF LEARNING
THAT'S COME OUT OF THE MORE
RECENT WILDFIRES.
WHERE WE'VE HAD NEWER BUILDINGS
THAT HAVE TODAY'S CODES
INSTITUTED WHAT'S THE DIFFERENCE
THAT HAVING OF DEFENSIBLE SPACE
RIGHT CLOSE TO A STRUCTURE MAKES?
IN TERMS OF WHETHER OR NOT THAT
STRUCTURE SURVIVES.
I'M I COULD SHOW YOU SLIDE AFTER
SLIDE OF PROPERTIES WERE RATHER
THAN SORT OF A WALL OF FIRE
MOVING THROUGH.
YOU HAVE AN ENTIRE YARD THAT
DIDN'T BURN TREES ARE INTACT
GRASSES ARE INTACT.
THE YARD WAS FINE BECAUSE AN
AMBER HIT -- SOMETHING THAT WAS
FLAMMABLE RIGHT NEXT TO A
BUILDING THE BUILDING WAS LOST
SO WHAT THIS BILL DOES IS CREATE
A NEW.
DEFENSIBLE SPACE REQUIREMENT IN
HIGH FIRE SEVERITY ZONES OF ZERO
TO FIVE FEET THIS IS NOT EXIST
RIGHT NOW IN OUR CURRENT CODES
BUT WORKING WITH CAL FIRE AND
FOR OUR FIRE AGENCIES ACROSS THE
STATE.
THEY HAVE SAID THAT THIS IS
ACTUALLY PROBABLY THE MOST
IMPORTANT AREA TO HAVE A NON
COMBUSTIBLE ZONE SO WHAT WE WILL
DO IS MOVE FORWARD TO CREATE
THIS NEW ZONE.
AND THEN HAVE CAL FIRE WORK TO
COME UP WITH SORT OF A GUIDELINE
FOR COMMUNITIES IN HIGH FIRE
ZONES TO SAY.
WHAT REALLY WE SHOULD BE GUIDING
PEOPLE TO DO MAYBE THERE IS SOME
PLANTING THAT'S ALLOWABLE BUT
YOU KNOW DON'T COVER YOUR HOUSE
OF BOOKMOBILE USER VINES DON'T
PLANT THE REDWOOD RIGHT UP
AGAINST YOUR STRUCTURE I HAD A
RED WITH THAT WENT THROUGH MY
DECK?
NOT A GOOD IDEA SO WE WANT TO
CHANGE THAT AND REALLY PUSH OUR
COMMUNITIES AND WORK WITH OUR
COMMUNITIES TO GET COMPLIANCE
ACROSS THE WHOLE COMMUNITY
BECAUSE ONE OUT OF COMPLIANCE
HOUSE CAN LEAD TO LOSING AN
ENTIRE NEIGHBORHOOD OF THAT
BUILDING GOES UP.
IN SMOKE -- IS SO -- WE WILL
WORK TO HAVE THE RIGHT TREE
RIGHT PLACE PLANTING UNDER
ELECTRICAL LINES AS ALSO AS PART
OF THIS BILL AND A GUIDE BOOK TO
PROVIDE LANDOWNERS OPTIONS FOR
VEGETATION THAT WON'T GROW INTO
ENERGIZED CONDUCTOR SO THERE'S A
PART OF THE BILL.
IT ALSO DEALS WITH THE WITH THE
POWER LINES.
ON THE FARM BUREAU WOULD LIKE
SPECIAL CONSIDERATION BEING
GIVEN -- TO GATED FUTURE NOT
ORCHARDS AND PART OF THE BILL.
AND I DO THINK THAT THAT
DESERVES SPECIAL CONSIDERATION
BECAUSE THOSE ARE IRRIGATED
THEY'RE DIFFERENT THEY HAVE A
DIFFERENT KIND OF FIRE RISK AND
SOMEONE WHO SPIRALING FIRE WOULD
A YOU KNOW UNDER THEIR STARES
FOR INSTANCE -- EVER WORKING ON
LANGUAGE TO PRUNE BACK THE BILL
TO ADDRESS THEIR CONCERNS.
THAT WAS A PINE IN LAUGHING --
AND FINALLY WE RECENTLY HAD A
REQUIREMENT FOR HELLFIRE TO
DEVELOP A PARCEL LEVEL WILD WILD
FIRE RISK MODEL TO HELP
COMMUNITIES UNDERSTAND THEIR
INDIVIDUAL RISK AND WHAT WE CAN
DO TO REDUCE THAT RISK.
AND WE'RE WORKING WITH
STAKEHOLDERS ON AN ADVISORY --
COUNTS UP PANEL.
AB FIFTEEN SIXTEENS RECEIVED
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT IT HAS TO
SUPPORT THE NATURE CONSERVANCY
SIERRA CLUB RESEARCH
CONSERVATION DISTRICTS FIRE SAFE
COUNCILS THE BUILDING INDUSTRY
WHO'S HERE WITH ME TODAY.
THE INSURANCE INDUSTRY AND AS D.
G. AN E..
ARMED WITH THAT I WILL TURN TO
CVA THEIR COMMENTS THANK YOU
WELCOME CHAIRMAN SENATOR I'M BOB
ROEMER SENIOR ENGINEER WITH THE
BUILDING INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION
AND IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THE
BILL.
THE FIRST SET OF FIRE HARDENING
STANDARDS TO CUT BACK BACK IN
TWO THOUSAND AND EIGHT WE'VE
INCREASE ASTRINGENCY THE
STANDARDS FOUR TIMES OVER THE
PAST DECADE.
OR WORKING ON THE NEXT SET OF
INCREASES IT'LL TAKE A FACT IN
JULY OF TWENTY TWENTY ONE ARE.
THE STANDARDS ARE INCREDIBLY
INFECTED -- IN REDUCING THE TIME
IT TAKES FOR FIRE TO PENETRATE
THE STRUCTURE.
BUT THE EFFECTIVENESS DROPS LIKE
A ROCK WHEN WE DON'T HAVE
DEFENSIBLE SPACE AND SO A. B.
FIFTEEN SIXTEEN SIX TO ADDRESS
THAT BY ESTABLISHING A MANDATORY
ENFORCEMENT OF THE DEFENSIBLE
SPACE REQUIREMENTS THAT HAVE
BEEN ON THE BOOKS. FOR TWO
DECADES BUT HAVEN'T BEEN RABIDLY
ENFORCED OUT THROUGHOUT THE
JURISDICTIONS ALSO THE FIVE FOOT --
BUCK TURNS PERIMETER WE'RE
ALREADY WORKING ON THE BUILDING
STANDARD TO ADDRESS THAT -- ALSO
OF THE VIRUS MODEL -- WE'RE
LOOKING VERY MUCH FORWARD TO
THAT'S GONNA HELP US WITH BOTH
THE EXISTING AND A NEW
CONSTRUCTION -- BUT TO SPEAK TO
THAT ARE FORMER STATE FARMERS
OKAY DARKENED EYES HERE THANK
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN.
WELCOME IS STARTING.
THANK YOU CHAIR AND MEMBERS.
I AM HERE TO SPEAK TODAY ALSO
BOTH FORMER CALIFORNIA STATE
FIRE MARSHALL AND A BOARD MEMBER
FOR THE CALIFORNIA STATE FIRE
SAFE COUNCIL WHICH IS IN SUPPORT
OF THE BILL.
SO I AM HERE TODAY TO TALK TO A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT THE MOST RECENT
AMENDMENTS THE RISK MODEL AND
SUBSEQUENT RISK MAPS
ASSEMBLYMEMBER FRIEDMAN
CORRECTLY IDENTIFIED IN HER
INFORMATIONAL HEARING THIS
SPRING.
THAT THERE WAS A GAP.
AND SHE PROPOSED AMENDMENTS. TO
CONSTRUCT A RISK MODEL. FOR THE
STATE AND THAT'S CRITICAL
BECAUSE FIRE HAZARD SEVERITIES
OWN MAPPING AND MODEL THAT WE
CURRENTLY USED TO DETECT ARE
WILD FIRE HAZARD IS GREAT BUT IT
IS NOT DESIGNED TO SERVE.
IN MITIGATION FUNDS BETWEEN THE
FEDERAL AND STATE AND LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS AND PRIVATE
HOMEOWNERS.
WE NEED A TOOL TO BE ABLE TO
METRIC WHAT THAT RISK
EFFECTIVENESS IS ARE WE CHANGING
OUR RISK ARE WE BUYING DOWN RISK.
PUBLICALLY VETTED MODEL DONE
THROUGH STATE AGENCY WILL GIVE
US A COMMON BASIS BY WHICH TO
EVALUATE THAT RISK.
THAT EXPENDITURE THERE OR HAVING
AND TELL US OVER THE YEARS AHEAD
WHETHER WE ARE ACHIEVING THE
EFFECTIVENESS THAT WE WANT
SHOULD WE NOT ENACT.
THIS TYPE OF PROVISION SHOULD WE
NOT HAVE A PUBLICALLY VETTED
RISK MODEL IT WILL FALL TO THE
MANY DIFFERENT TYPES OF PRIVATE
MODELS.
EACH INDEPENDENT LOCAL
GOVERNMENT OR INSURANCE COMPANY
OR DIFFERENT ENTITY WILL PUT OUT
THERE AND THEN WE WILL START
ARGUING ABOUT WHAT THE MODEL
VALIDITY IS NOT WHETHER THE
MEDICATIONS ARE EFFECTIVE.
SO THIS IS -- GET AHEAD OF THE
GAME PROPOSAL THIS AMENDMENT I
THINK IT'S ONE OF THE MOST
IMPORTANT PIECES OF THE
LEGISLATION AS IT'S CURRENTLY
WRITTEN.
ARE AND I WANT TO SPEAK TO MY
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU SO MUCH. TWO OTHERS IN
SUPPORT HERE TODAY.
GOOD AFTERNOON NEARLY GOVERNOR
WITH THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
OF REALTORS WHILE WE'RE NOT
REFLECTED IN THE ANALYSIS WE ARE
HERE IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANKS SO MUCH.
GOOD AFTERNOON SIR IN TAYLOR
WITH THE PERSONAL INSURANCE
FEDERATION CALIFORNIA ALSO IN
SUPPORT.
AND WORKING WITH THE AUTHOR ON
THE AMENDMENTS THAT INSURERS
WITH EXPERTISE IN.
WALL VIRUS MANAGEMENT. TO THE
MODEL AND APPRECIATE YOUR
EFFORTS ON THE BILL AND I THINK
IT'S BEEN A VERY IMPORTANT HAVE
THAT INFORMATION THAT PARCEL
BASED.
AND COMMUNITY BASED RISK
INFORMATION TO HELP US MAKE
BETTER DECISIONS.
WELL IT WHILE I HAVE YOU THERE.
IS THE IS THE IN THE INSURANCE
INDUSTRY RIGHT NOW DO YOU ALL
HAVE INDIVIDUALLY WOULD SAY
WITHIN VARIOUS.
PLANS THIS KIND OF PARTIAL LEVEL
ANALYSIS NOW UNFORTUNATELY DOWN
THAT'S PART OF THE BIG DEBATE
RIGHT NOW WHEN PEOPLE TALK ABOUT
MITIGATION AND AND SORT OF THE
WHOLE NON RENEWAL ISSUE.
PART OF THAT IS THAT INSURERS
DON'T HAVE THAT PARCEL LEVEL
DATA TO MAKE THOSE TYPE OF
REGULAR DECISIONS AND SO WE
REALLY WANT TO WORK TOWARDS
GETTING THAT DATA. TO FURTHER
THE DISCUSSION ON THIS THIS YEAR
AND CAN YOU FORESEE IF IF WE DO
GET TO THAT KIND OF MODEL AND
FOLKS ARE MAKING THOSE
AGGRESSIVE ACTIONS AT THEIR
HOMES FOR HARDENING OR EDUCATION
MANAGEMENT.
THAT ACTUALLY GOING TO BE
MEANINGFUL THEN TO THEM ON THEIR
INSURANCE WHETHER ON RENEWALS OR
CANCELLATIONS I MEAN COULD WE
CAN YOU ENVISION A FUTURE WHERE.
THAT RISK BY DOWN WILL ACTUALLY
HAVE AN IMPACT ON RATE CERTAINLY
HOPE SO I MEAN THAT BE THE GOAL
RIGHT NOW WE DON'T HAVE THAT
DATA AND WE LACK IT AND SO --
HOPING THAT WITH THAT WE'LL BE
ABLE TO MAKE MORE GRANULAR
DECISIONS.
THANK YOU.
THANKS ALL RIGHT OTHERS IN
SUPPORT.
DAUGHTER MOM ON BEHALF OF THE
MID PENINSULA REGIONAL OPEN
SPACE DISTRICT IN SUPPORT THANKS
SO MUCH.
AND ALSO BE OFFICE HERE COMPOUND
FOR HIS PART.
THANK YOU.
LIZ FORSBERG COME OUT THE NATURE
CONSERVANCY IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
VERY MUCH.
GO FAR WITH THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF RESOURCE
CONSERVATION DISTRICTS AND
SUPPORT.
MUCH.
YEAH NIKOLINA NONE AS WITH ANY --
GAS AND ELECTRIC COMPANY IN
SUPPORT VERY GOOD.
ALL RIGHT SEEING NO OTHERS IN
SUPPORT DO WE HAVE ANY
OPPOSITION.
GOOD AFTERNOON KEREN MILLS FOR
THE CALIFORNIA FARM BUREAU
FEDERATION HAS THE AUTHOR
POINTED OUT.
WE DO HAVE CONCERNS WITH A
PROVISION OF THE BILL THAT
IMPLICATES ORCHARDS AND I'VE
BEEN TALKING TO THE AUTHORS
OFFICE AND VERY MUCH APPRECIATE
THEIR UNDERSTANDING AND
APPRECIATION OF ISSUE IN
RECOGNITION.
OF ORCHARDS AND A START FIRE SO --
WE'RE HOPEFUL THAT WE CAN
RESOLVE THE MATTER QUICKLY THANK
YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU VERY
MUCH TO THE AUTHOR AND ARE ALL.
THANK YOU -- SEEING NO OTHERS IN
OPPOSITION BRING IT BACK TO THE
DICE MEMBER.
SURPRISED HERE.
I KNOW YOU MENTIONED IN YOUR
OPENING BELL ARE YOU TAKING IN
THE MEN'S TODAY OR YOUR MEANING
THE BILL LATER OR WE WEREN'T
GIVEN ANY AMENDMENTS FROM THIS%
COMMITTEE WE'RE GOING T
CONTINUE TO DISCUSS WITH THE
FARM BUREAU AND I'M I'M YOU KNOW
VERY CONFIDENT THAT WE'LL BE
ABLE. TO COME UP WITH AMENDMENTS
WITH THEM TO ADDRESS THEIR
CONCERNS OKAY WHAT IS THE
GOVERNOR.
OKAY SAUSAGE I'M GONNA SUPPORT.
ENERGY OKAY SIZE -- IS A GO TO
JUDICIARY ACTUALLY.
WILL SIT ON THE FLOOR OKAY SO
I'M GONNA SUPPORT TODAY UNDER
THE UNDERSTANDING THAT.
AND I BELIEVE EVERYBODY SO --
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
OKAY THANK YOU MISTER VICE CHAIR
AND SHOULD THERE BE.
A TRAPPER TWENTY FOR A MOMENT.
WANT TO JOIN YOU THE CO AUTHOR
PRINCIPLE CO I I I THINK THIS IS
LYNCH BEEN TO THE ENTIRE FIRE.
BACKAGE BUT A YEAR.
GRAVE MISTAKE IF WE PROCEED ON
OTHER ISSUES AROUND. TO THE
LIABILITY AND YOU KNOW FUND
CONSTRUCTION IF WE DON'T
ACTUALLY EMPOWER [inaudible]
HOMEOWNERS REALTORS BUILDERS
LOCAL COMMUNITIES TO ACTUALLY GO
MITIGATE THE RISK AND NOT JUST
BE PASSIVE.
IN THE FACE THIS FIRE WE'VE GOT
EMPOWER FOLKS IN [inaudible]
I I'M.
MY ONLY CONCERN IS IS DOESN'T GO
QUICKLY ENOUGH.
IS HOW LONG IS THIS MODEL AND
TAKE.
AND HOW LONG ARE WE GONNA TAKE
TO ACTUALLY ENFORCE BECAUSE EVEN
IN JURISDICTIONS WE HAVE STRONG
DEFENSIBLE SPACE.
IMPORTS MINCE YOU KNOW LUMPY.
EVEN YOU KNOW LOOK AT LA COUNTY
RIGHT I MEAN.
WE HAVEN'T SEEN NEARLY LEVEL
COMPLIANCE ON PRIVATE LANDS IT
THAT WE KNOW WE NEED AND AND
FRANKLY THE CAL FIRE FEEL
MITIGATION.
STRATEGY THUS FAR IT'S BEEN VERY
BIG TREE FOLK.
AND WHILE THEIR EIGHT ME NO
THERE'S BIG ISSUES IN THE NORTH
COAST FOR ALL THE SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIANS HERE AND TENDONS.
WE HAVE HUGE ISSUES YOUR
HILLSIDE COMMUNITIES AND
CHAPARRALS AND WHILE THEY IN
URBAN INTERFACE SO.
I'M JUST CONCERNED THAT.
WE'RE GONNA LEAVE FOLKS PASSIVE
HERE SO.
I HOPE WE CAN FIND A WAY TO A
SORT OF IS THERE IN YOUR OPINION
IS THERE A WAY.
TO YOUR SHORTTERM WAY TO
ACHIEVE SOME OF THE GAMES YOU
WANT TO BE ACHIEVING HERE AS
OPPOSED TO SORT OF HAVING A
MULTI YEAR PROCESS MISTER ROEMER
AT ANY AYE AYE ANDERSON THE CODE
PROCESS.
TAKES A WHILE TO DEVELOP A JUST.
MEANINGFUL DATA THE BILL TO GET
TO THE INSURANCE INDUSTRY TO
REALTORS AND THE FIVE FOOT
CLEARANCE WERE ALREADY WORKING
ON THAT -- THERE'S A THERE'S A
THERE'S A WILD AND URBAN TASK
FORCE THAT'S BEEN IN STE IN
PROCESS BLAST DECADE.
ALREADY WORKING ON THE FIVE PUT
PRIMER AFTER SEEING THE BILL
EXCELLENT THANK YOU THAT'S SOME
GOOD NEWS.
I'D BE HAPPY TO GIVE YOU MY
ESTIMATE ON WHAT IT WILL TAKE
YEARS WEISS I DO THINK IT WILL
TAKE TWO YEARS TO DEVELOP THE
MODEL.
AND THREE YEARS FOR A RIGOROUS
DATA COLLECTION PROCESS SOME OF
WHICH CAN BE PURCHASED AHEAD OF
TIME.
AND THAT GETS THINGS JUMPSTARTED
BUT I DO THINK THAT
REALISTICALLY IT WILL TAKE FIVE
TO GET IT. TO GET REAL METRICS
BACK TO THE LEGISLATURE IT IS
REALLY.
AS AS REALISTIC AS I CAN GIVE
YOU MAYBE IT'S NOT GREAT.
SO IT'S CONCERNING BECAUSE IN
THE NEXT TWO OR THREE YEARS
DURING HIS THEIR POLICIES
CANCELED OR YOU ACTUALLY.
CAN'T EVEN BUY A HOME BECAUSE
THANK GOD A MORTGAGE IS YOU
DON'T HAVE INSURANCE AND YOU
HAVE LOCAL JURISDICTIONS -- WE
HAVE A HOUSING CRISIS ON OUR
HANDS I'M JUST.
IF THERE IF THERE ARE EXPEDITED
WAYS TO ADDRESS THIS ISSUE NEAR
TERM VERY OPEN TO IT I THINK IS
A GOOD STEP TOWARD BUT JUST WANT
YOUR FOR THE THINKING ON THAT
ANOTHER VICE CHAIR AT I WAS JUST
GONNA SAY THAT'S REALLY AN
INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT.
COMMENT THAT YOU MADE AND REALLY
VERY VERY ASTUTE AND I'M VERY
PROUD TO ADD YOU AS A CO AUTHOR
SO THANK YOU FOR THAT.
SO THERE'S YOU KNOW THOSE FEW
DIFFERENT PIECES HAVING THAT
RISK ANALYSIS MODEL IS GOING O
BE VERY IMPORTANT TO
UNDERSTANDING THE EFFECT OF ALL
OF OUR RESILIENCY EFFORTS AND
CERTAINLY.
WERE A BETTER GUIDE FOR
HOMEOWNERS WHEN THEIR PURCHASING
PROPERTY FOR INSURANCE COMPANIES
WHEN THEY SET RATES ALL OF
THAT'S IMPORTANT.
AND OR BUT AT THE SAME TIME WE
ALSO KNOW THAT THE THIS NEW
COMBUSTIBLES OWN MAKES A REALLY
BIG DIFFERENCE SO WE KNOW ABOUT
ALL OF THE DIFFERENT HOME
HARDENING.
I FEEL LIKE WHAT WE HAVE TO
THINK OF THOSE ON TWO DIFFERENT
TRACKS AND ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT I'VE COME TO REALIZE IS
I'VE GOT MORE IN.
IN DEPTH IN THIS AREA IS THE
LACK OF KNOWLEDGE SUCH OUT FOR
HOMEOWNERS I DID A TOWN HALL A
COUPLE WEEKS AGO MY DISTRICT OF
PEOPLE WHO SHOW UP AT THESE TOWN
HALLS ARE REALLY YOUR MOST
INVOLVED HOMEOWNERS.
EASIER H. AWAY PRESIDENT'S THESE
ARE PEOPLE THAT HAVE BEN AROUND
FOR A LONG TIME THE INFORMATION
ABOUT HOME HARDENING THAT WE
GAVE.
LIKE FLOOR PEOPLE THEY HAD NO
IDEA WE HAVE DONE A TERRIBLE JOB
AND PUSHING HOME HARDENING
INFORMATION OUT PEOPLE EVEN STOP
THAT'S PRETTY SIMPLE NO MY
HUSBAND'S A LANDSCAPE ARCHITECT
HE HAD NO IDEA ABOUT YOU KNOW.
THE ABOUT THE AFFECTED SOME OF
THESE PLANS COULD HAVE ON A
PROBLEM YOU KNOW ON A HOUSE WHEN
THEY'RE FOR EVEN FOUR FEET AWAY
OR PUT.
EVEN SO WE WE ABSOLUTELY LIKE
YOU SAID WE SHOULDN'T WASTE ANY
TIME TO PUSH THAT INFORMATION
OUT TO MAKE SURE THAT
COMMUNITIES ARE.
COMFORTABLE TO ADOPT THIS BILL
SO WE HAVE THIS NON COMBUSTIBLE
ZONE AND THEN TO MAKE SURE THAT
OUR COMMUNITIES ARE QUIPPED TO
ENFORCE THESE ZONES.
AND TO WORK WITH THEIR
COMMUNITIES TO GET COMPLIANCE
I'M NOT SAYING GO OUT AND START
FINING PEOPLE I'M SAYING GOING
OUT TO GO OUT AND IDENTIFY THOSE
PROPERTIES IN YOUR CITY AND SAY.
YOU HAVE A REAL SAFETY RISK ON
YOUR HANDS HOMEOWNER AND HERE'S
WHAT YOU CAN DO A. B. C. AND D..
TO FIX THAT SO THAT WE WERE WE
BUILD UP OUR COMMUNITIES WE WERE
ABLE TO GET FIVE MILLION DOLLARS
IN THIS YEAR'S BUDGET TO HELP
WITH THAT DEFENSIBLE SPACE
REQUIREMENTS.
THAT'S NOTHING WE COULD SPEND
FIVE MILLION DOLLARS IN GLENDALE
ALONE EASILY GETTING COMPLIANCE
I WOULD LIKE IF THE GOVERNOR
THERE IS LISTENING OR ANYBODY
WHO CARES ABOUT THIS IS
LISTENING LET'S GET THE GOVERNOR
AT THIS YEAR.
ALLOCATE A LOT MORE MONEY TO
DEFENSIBLE SPACE BECAUSE WE'VE
GOT LOW INCOME HOME OWNERS AND
SENIORS WHO CAN AFFORD TO DO THE
WORK.
THANK YOU ONE TREE OUT CAN COST
YOU FIVE THOUSAND DOLLARS AND UP
SO WE HAVE TO HELP OUR
HOMEOWNERS TO THAT WE HAVE SAFER
COMMUNITIES.
CLEARLY AGREE MISTER VICE CHAIR.
SEGWAYS.
GREAT INTO MY QUESTION BECAUSE
IN YOUR OPENING YOU MENTIONED
YOU -- REDWOOD TREE COMING
THROUGH A A DECK.
WHICH IS NOT UNCOMMON REDWOODS
IN MY DISTRICT UNCOMMON BUT
TREES GROWING UP TO THE DECK ARE
NOT UNCOMMON -- AND THEN -- YES
SIR.
THE BILL IS A PROSPECTIVE BUT
IT'S ALSO YOU KNOW YOU'RE YOU'RE
GONNA BE ADDING.
ADDITIONAL REQUIREMENTS ON
SITUATIONS LIKE THAT SO.
HOW HOW DO YOU ENVISION -- THE
NINETEEN YOU MENTION FIVE
THOUSAND DOLLARS REMOVE THE TREE --
AND YOU KNOW SOME SITUATIONS
THAT THAT COULD BE ON THE LOW
END -- SO HOW DO YOU ENVISION
THIS.
IMPACTING SOME IS GONNA HAVE TO
REMOVE SOMETHING LIKE THAT ARE
NOT HAVE SOMETHING LIKE THAT.
AND WE'VE ALSO TALKED ABOUT LIKE
WHO'S GONNA GO TELL GRANDMA
SHE'S GONNA TAKE OUT A ROSE
BUSHES YOU KNOW THERE'S THIS IS
NOT GONNA BE EASY I I YOU KNOW
WE GOT THAT.
AND THAT'S WHY WE DO HAVE THIS
PROCESSES ARE COMING UP WITH
REGULATIONS AND GUIDELINES AND
WE ALSO HOPE THAT OUR
COMMUNITIES UNDERSTAND THE
FLEXIBILITY OF SAYING YOU KNOW
MAYBE THE ROSE BUSH AND STAY.
BUTYOU HAVE YOU GOT SOMETHING
THAT'S CLEARLY A HAZARD.
AS A HOMEOWNER YES MAYBE THAT
FIVE THOUSAND DOLLARS IS PAINFUL
BUT A LOT MORE PAINFUL AND MINE
WAS A EUCALYPTUS SO IT WAS KIND
OF LIKE A BOMB READY TO GO OFF.
WHAT'S MORE PAINFUL IS IF THAT
BOMB HAD GONE OFF AND I LOST MY
WHOLE HOUSE SO REALLY EDUCATING
PEOPLE AS TO WHY THEY SHOULD
WANT.
TO MAKE THAT INVESTMENT BECAUSE
THE BIGGER INVESTMENT IS THERE
IS THERE HOME.
AND THEIR FAMILIES SAFETY INSIDE
OF IT AND SO WE HAVE TO BE VERY
CAREFUL HOW WE DO THIS SO PEOPLE
DON'T THINK IT'S PUNITIVE THAT
THEY UNDERSTAND.
THAT -- THERE'S A RATIONALE BUT
THAT I WOULD LOVE TO SEE
FINANCIAL TOOLS TO HELP
HOMEOWNERS WHO ARE YOU KNOW EVEN
MODERATE INCOME BE ABLE TO CLICK
TO TO COMPLY.
THANK YOU AND IF WE CAN GET THAT
DONE IN THE NEXT.
SESSION BEFORE YOU KNOW.
BUDGET ROOM THERE'S STILL SOME
PARTS OF FUNDING SO.
I THINK THERE'S A BIG
OPPORTUNITIES AT EVERY HEARD THE
WOULD BILL EARLIER ON HOME
HARDENING AS WELL.
AT FUNDING FILL OUT THE BUDGET.
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS LONG
TERM RESILIENCE CANCEL OUT IN
THE BUDGET FOR SAFE DRINKING
WATER.
WE GOT GAPS YOU GOT FILM NOW
THOUGH.
I APPRECIATE THE DISCUSSION YEAH
RIGHT.
I'LL ENTERTAIN A MOTION AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME.
MOVIE MILL OKAY TO TO MOTIONS
FROM THE VICE CHAIR MOTIONS TO
PASS TO ENERGY UTILITIES AND
COMMUNICATIONS.
THIS CALL THE ROLL -- STERN.
SORRY WE'RE ON AB.
FIFTEEN SIXTEEN YEAH NO THAT'S
ALRIGHT.
YEAH WE GOT CHECK.
THE SENATORS STERN BY.
I JONES.
JONES I ALLEN ORANGES CABALLERO.
I HERTZBERG HUESO JACKSON MONEY
IN ITS OWN CALLED OKAY LEAVE A
MEASURE ON CALL.
LET'S CONSULT OUR ORDER HERE --
SIMILAR CALDERON.
AS MAJORITY LEADER WELCOME.
BUT AFTERNOON SIR.
AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS HOW WILL BE AS QUICK AS
I CAN FIRST I'D LIKE TO BEGIN BY
ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS
AND I WANT TO THANK YOU AND YOUR
STAFF.
WORKING ON THIS ISSUE WITH US I
CONSIDER THIS ONE OF OUR SERVER
BILLS THAT SAID AFTER.
BUT WE DO HAVE AN OUNCE OF EARLY
IN THE WAY.
CALIFORNIA HAS LONG BEEN
ENVIRONMENTAL LEADER
CONSERVATION AND WE ARE LUCKY TO
BE IN RICH WITH THE BEAUTIFUL
PACIFIC COASTLINE AND AN OCEAN
THAT CONTRIBUTES.
MIGHTILY TO THE STATE'S ECONOMY
HOWEVER COASTAL EROSION AND THE
PROLIFERATION OF POLLUTION
THREATEN HEALTH OF OUR OCEAN IN
OUR ENVIRONMENT EVERY.
EVERY DAY AB SEVEN NINE SEVENTY
FIVE WILL ESTABLISH THE
CALIFORNIA CULTURAL LINES IN AN
ADAPTATION LEADERSHIP AND
COORDINATION ACT OF TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN THIS ACT REQUIRES THE
SECRETARY OF NATURALIZATION SEE
TO COLLABORATE WITH OUTSIDE
NATIONS TO SUPPORT.
AND PROMOTE THE GOALS POLICIES
AND BEST MANAGEMENT PRACTICES
RELATING. TO GLOBALLY SHE OUR
GLOBAL GLOBALLY SHARED OCEAN
RESPECTIVELY THE SECRETARY.
CURRENTLY OVERSEES PROTECTION OF
THE OCEAN AND COAST WITH THE
HELP OF STATE AGENCIES AND
OUTSIDE PARTNERS HE'S
COLLABORATED THESE COLLABORATIVE
EFFORTS.
ARE STRICTLY WITHIN CALIFORNIA'S
BECAUSE AN OCEAN I ENDED TAX
ONLY OUR CAR BECAUSE IN OUR
OCEAN -- BUT THEN AND THERE'S NO
REQUIREMENT.
IN STATUTE FOR THE SECRETARY TO
COLLABORATE WITH AND COMMUNICATE
WITH OTHERS IN A SOME NATIONAL
GOVERNMENTS NAY STATES OTHER
OTHER OTHER FOLKS OUTSIDE THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA -- TO
ADDRESS THE ISSUES OF CONSERVING
CORAL REEFS WHICH IS ACTUALLY
BIG ISSUE WOULD BEEN DEALING
WITH YOU SEEN THE STATE OF
HAWAII THAT'S BàN.
A LOT OF SUNSCREENS BECAUSE OF
OF BLEACHING AGREES.
OCEAN MONITORING AND CONTINUED
EFFORTS IN SUSTAINABLE FISHERIES
I AN OFFSETTING THREATS POSED BY
OFFSHORE DRILLING IN THE GROWING
REAL GROWING MILLION MARINE
POLLUTION SPECIFICALLY SINGLE
USE PLASTICS AND MICHAEL
PLASTICS ARE.
ARE CHOKING OUR OCEAN -- SO
BASICALLY THIS BILL JUST SAYS
COLLABORATE OUTSIDE OF
CALIFORNIA SO THAT THERE'S MORE
CONSISTENCY IN POLICY NOT JUST
IN TERMS OF OVER DOING IN
CALIFORNIA AND WHAT IMPACT US
BUT SO THAT WE CAN BE A LEADER
IN PROVIDING IDEAS AND HELP TO
OTHER NATIONS AND OTHER.
STATES AND AND HAVE A
COLLABORATIVE EFFORT WITH JED
THEM AND US.
AND WITH THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AND I BOTH.
ARE GOOD THANK YOU -- WHAT IS IN
SUPPORT AS CHAIR MEMBERS READ
ADDISON BEHALF OCEAN CONSERVANCY
IN SUPPORT TODAY?
I WAS IN SUPPORT OF THE MULLIN
BELL EARLIER THAT -- IN THE
HEARING AID TRIES TO ESTABLISH A
GOVERNING STRUCTURE FOR HOW THE
STATE'S GONNA DEAL WITH
ADAPTATION WE SUPPORT THIS
MEASURE BECAUSE REALLY SAYING
THAT SECRETARY RESOURCES SHOULD
HAVE SOME GUIDANCE TODAY OUT WE
SHOULD HAVE AN STATUTES.
THE NOTION OF AS HE TALKS ABOUT
IN DEALS WITH CLIMATE ADAPTATION
OR IS IT RESILIENCY OUTSIDE OF
CALIFORNIA WHICH IS DESPERATELY
NEEDED WHETHER THAT'S JUST.
THE STATE'S UP THE COAST FOR
MEXICO BELOW FOR THE PACIFIC RIM.
WE DO NEED TO THINK ABOUT THE
WAY WE DO WITH ADAPTATION
ESPECIALLY AROUND OUR OCEANS
BEYOND CALIFORNIA.
PUTTING IN STATUTE THAT THE
SECRETARY IS PERSON YOU SHOULD
BE HAVING THIS CONVERSATION.
HAVING THE CRITERIA AND THE
MECHANISMS HERE IN THE BILL THAT
SAY HOW HE SHOULD BE DOING THAT
WITH THE GOVERNOR IS IMPORTANT
TO US AND THEREFORE IN SUPPORT
TODAY THANK YOU VERY GOOD THANKS
SO MUCH OTHER OTHERS IN SUPPORT
HERE [inaudible]
YES.
NATALIE MAX ON BEHALF OF SAY THE
REDWOODS LEAGUE IN SUPPORT VERY
GOOD THANK YOU SO MUCH OTHERS IN
SUPPORT.
THING NINE ANY OPPOSITION.
BEING NON BRING BACK TO THE
DíAS [inaudible]
COMMENT [inaudible]
STERN.
I WOULD LOVE A MOAT.
THAT'S A MOTION FOR CENTER
CABALLERO.
THANK YOU.
I DON'T KNOW THE STATE OF OUR
SERVE CAUCUSES BUT THIS
CERTAINLY BELONG TO THE TOP OF
THE LIST I'M GLAD YOU BROUGHT
THIS FORWARD -- YOUR DUCKS IN A
ROW GETTING LEGISLATIVE BY INTO
OUR INTERNATIONAL EFFORTS.
AND APPRECIATE WORKING WITH THE
COMMITTEE TO ON THIS.
TRYING TO START TO QUANTIFY THE
RISK I STILL DON'T.
THINK WERE FLYING BLIND WHEN IT
COMES THE COST.
MARCOS IN OUR OCEAN RESOURCES IN
THIS STATE HOW BIG OF AN
ECONOMIC IMPACT IT'S GONNA HAVE
AN ECONOMY'S LOCALLY SO -- WE
GOT TO TRY TO FIND TOOLS TO
ACTUALLY GET AHEAD OF THIS BUT I
THINK IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT STEP
SO -- WITH THAT THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AS AMENDED TO ENVIRONMENTAL
QUALITY I NEED YOUR CLOTHES BACK
WESTERN I'VE OPENED VERY GOOD.
SENATE STERN VICE STERN AYE
JONES ALLEN BUDGET.
THAT WE ARE OF AYE HERTZBERG
HUESO JACKSON IMANI [inaudible]
THANK YOU -- HOLDEN.
LAST MAN SITTING.
GOOD AFTERNOON AND WELCOME
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
WE'RE ON ITEM.
THIRTEEN EIGHTY THIRTEEN TWENTY
EIGHT THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE IT'S A PLEASURE TO BE
HERE TODAY TO PRESENT AB
THIRTEEN TWENTY I WANT TO START
BY THANKING YOUR COMMITTEE.
AFTER WORKING SO DILIGENTLY WITH
US -- WE ARE HERE TO ACCEPT THE
AMENDMENTS [inaudible]
AS PRESENTED.
I ALSO WANT TO EXPRESS.
THAT WE HAVE REMOVED ALL KNOWN
OPPOSITION FROM. TO THIS BILL.
THERE ARE TENS OF THOUSANDS OF
OLDER TENSELY LEAKING OIL AND
GAS WELLS IN CALIFORNIA.
SOME OF THE SITES ARE IDLE
DESERTED OR HAZARDOUS AND THOSE
ARE THE FOCUS OF THIS BILL.
LIKE ACTED PRODUCTION SITES IDLE
DESERTED AND HAZARDOUS OIL AND
GAS WELLS CAN LEAK POLLUTION.
FOR EXAMPLE IN TWO THOUSAND
SIXTEEN A PAIR OF IDLE.
OIL AND GAS WELLS WERE FOUND
LEAKING HAZARDOUS LEVELS OF GAS
IN ECHO PARK NEIGHBORHOOD IN LOS
ANGELES.
LESS THAN A HUNDRED FEET FROM
NEARBY RESIDENTS.
IN ADDITION EARLIER THIS YEAR
AND OIL OLD OIL WELL IN MARINA
DEL REY.
EXPERIENCE RELEASE DURING
REMEDIATION WORK.
POTENTIAL EMISSIONS FROM IDA
WELLS INCLUDE METHANE AND
BENZENE METHANE IS A CLIMATE
CHANGE GAS MANY TIMES MORE
POWERFUL.
THAN CARBON DIOXIDE WELL OTHER
CO ADMITTED.
AIR POLLUTANTS LIKE BENZENE CAN
CAUSE CANCER.
AB THIRTEEN TWENTY EIGHT WOULD
MAKE THIS INFORMATION ON LEAKS
PUBLICLY AVAILABLE.
CREATING A BODY OF INFORMATION
THAT IS IMPORTANT TO KNOW IN THE
SIZE AND SCOPE OF THE EMISSIONS
FROM IDLE.
AND DESERTED WELLS.
INFORMATION COLLECTED UNDER A.
B. THIRTEEN TWENTY EIGHT CAN BE
USED TO CREATE A BETTER
UNDERSTANDING.
OF THE EMISSIONS FROM ALL OF
CALIFORNIA'S OIL AND GAS WELLS.
IN CLOSING I'LL IN DESERTED
WELLS CAN AND DO LEAGUE AND WHEN
THEY DO THEY CAN WROTE RESULT IN
EMISSIONS THAT CONTRIBUTE TO
CLIMATE CHANGE.
AND ENDANGER THE PUBLIC HEALTH.
AB THIRTEEN TWENTY EIGHT SIX TO
ADDRESS THIS ISSUE CREATING A
SCIENTIFIC STUDY.
OF THESE WELLS AND REQUIRES THE
DATA COLLECTED TO BE MADE PUBLIC.
I HAVE WITH ME TIM O'CONNOR FROM
ENVIRONMENTAL DEFENSE FUND IS
IMPORTANCE OF THIS LEGISLATION I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR DR THANK
YOU SEVEN HOURS.
CHAU CONNOR.
IF YOU MISTER CHAIR A COMMITTEE
MEMBERS MY NAME IS TIM O'CONNOR
I'M A SENIOR DIRECTOR AT THE
ENVIRONMENT DEFENSE FUND MAWSON
APPOINTED MEMBER OF THE ADVISORY
COMMITTEE TO THE LOS ANGELES
COUNTY OIL AND GAS STRIKE TEAM.
AND WE ARE ACTIVELY LOOKING AT
THE EMISSIONS FROM ABANDONED AND
IDA WELLS IN THE LOS ANGELES
AREA. ONE OF THINGS THAT'S CLEAR
IN THE MISTER HOLDEN THE STATED
IS THAT THERE ARE TENS OF
THOUSANDS OF THESE WELLS IN
CALIFORNIA.
AND IT IS IT IS ARE BASED ON
SCIENCE THAT WE CAN SAY THAT
THESE WELLS CAN AND DO LEAK AND
SOMETIMES THEY LEAK IN
SIGNIFICANT QUANTITIES
[inaudible]
THE JOB.
GOVERNMENT NASA HAS DONE A STUDY.
IN LOOKING AT THE ATMOSPHERE
OVER LOS ANGELES COUNTY AND
FOUND ABNORMALLY HIGH
CONCENTRATIONS OF METHANE IN THE
ATMOSPHERE.
AND THE BY LOOKING AT ISOTOPES
IN IN THOSE SAMPLES THEY HAVE
BEEN ABLE TO DISCERN.
THAT THERE ARE.
WILLING GAS EMISSIONS THAT ARE
CONTRIBUTING TO METHANE
EMISSIONS ABOVE LOS ANGELES AND
AS OF YET THERE IS NO CLEAR
INDICATION OF THE SOURCE SOME
PEOPLE HAVE SAID.
THEY'VE SUGGESTED THAT I DON'T
HAVE BEEN WELL AS MAY BE PART OF
THE CAUSE OF THIS.
EVIDENCE FROM LIKE PENNSYLVANIA
HAS SUGGESTED THAT IDOL IN A
BAND WELLS CAN MAKE A
SIGNIFICANT CONTRIBUTION THERE
IN PENNSYLVANIA IT'S NEARLY 528%
OF THE TOTAL STATES METHANE
BUDGET.
AND THE INCIDENCE OF VITAL
MINERALS LEAKING IS HAS RECEIVED
MUCH ATTENTION BECAUSE OF THAT.
CALIFORNIA WE OF COURSE HAVE A
SPECIAL PROBLEM IN THAT WE HAVE
MANY PEOPLE THAT LIVE IN VERY
CLOSE PROXIMITY TO THE SOURCES.
TENS OF THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE LIVE
WITHIN ONE HUNDRED FEET OR LESS
OF AN OLD ABANDONED OR I DON'T
WELL WELL.
IN A STUDY BY THE CALIFORNIA
RESEARCHERS BOARD IN TWENTY
FIFTEEN SHOW THAT IN OVER HALF
OF THE LEAKS THAT THEY STUDIED.
FROM OLD OIL WELLS OVER HALF OF
THEM CONTAIN CANCER CAUSING
COMPOUNDS AND SO WHEN WE HAVE
PEOPLE LIVING IN CLOSE PROXIMITY
TO THESE.
SOURCES IT CAN CREATE EVEN FOR
THE PROBLEM.
THIS CREATES A STUDY TO EVALUATE
THE PREVALENCE OF LEAKAGE OF
THESE WELLS AND TO ALLOW THE
STATE TO START TO TARGET AND
pSTATE RESOURCES.
AT BEST WORK TO TARGET THE
HIGHEST EMITTING RESOURCES.
IN THIS WELL INVENTORY AND TO
TARGET OF THE MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS ARE SPENDING CURRENTLY.
PLUGGING THE WELLS THAT ARE OF
THE HIGHEST PRIORITY.
WITHOUT THIS KIND OF INFORMATION
CALIFORNIA IS IS FLYING BLIND IN
SOME WAYS -- AND WE CAN USE THIS
INFORMATION TO DEVELOP A
TARGETED ASSESSMENT AND TO ALLOW
THE STATE'S MORE EFFICIENTLY USE
ITS PRECIOUS RESOURCES.
THANK US RIVAL VERY GOOD THANK
YOU SO MUCH ANY OTHERS IN
SUPPORT TODAY [inaudible]
BEING.
ONE MELISSA ROMERO WITH THE
CALIFORNIA LEAGUE OF
CONSERVATION VOTERS IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
MANY OTHERS IN SUPPORT SEEING
NONE ANY IN OPPOSITION OR IN
BETWEEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON ONCE AGAIN MISTER
CHAIRMAN P. ANTHONY THOMAS
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
INDEPENDENT PETROLEUM
ASSOCIATIONS -- YES WE HAVE
REMOVED OUR OPPOSITION FORMALLY
TO ASSEMBLY BILL -- THIRTEEN
TWENTY EIGHT BUT IF WE COULD THE
RICHEST A NOTE THAT WE WOULD
LIKE TO MAKE FOR THE RECORD.
AND I REQUEST SAID TO THE AUTHOR
IT BE SO INCLINED -- ARE OF
CONCERN WAS THAT A RELATED TO
COST OF THE STUDY.
IN A RELEASE.
THE RELEASE OF INFORMATION PRIOR.
HOW TO RELEASING A REPORT?
OUR REQUEST IS THAT IF IN FACT
STAKEHOLDERS COM SHOULD SEE
COULD SEE THAT INFORMATION
INFORMATION.
AS A WAY TO ENSURE ITS ACCURACY.
AND NOT.
THIRD PARTIES TO TAKE DATA OUT
OF CONTEXT.
AND TO MISINFORM THE PUBLIC IF
THAT'S BEEN ADDRESSED.
ME LIKE THIS REALLY HEAR IT N.
TO HEAR HOW THAT'S GOING TO BE
DONE.
AND SUPPOSE IS FINE WITH THE
LANGUAGE -- WE LIKE TO KNOW WHO
WOULD BE ACTUALLY A PART OF THE
PEER REVIEW PROCESS AS WELL.
WE THINK WE HAVE THAT TO THAT
RIGHT TO KNOW SINCE TALK IS
GOING TO BE MY MEMBERS WELLS
IT'S GOING TO BE INSPECTED.
BY IF DEPENDING STUDY INCLUDES
TESTING THE VAPORS OF WILL HAVE
TO REQUEST.
THAT THE TESTING SHOULD ALSO
IDENTIFY HOW FAR AWAY FROM THE
WELL -- THAT THE SAMPLES WERE
ACTUALLY TAKEN.
I WOULD MAKE THIS REQUEST
BECAUSE A SAMPLE TAKEN AT THE
WAR OF THE WELL NOT BE THE SAME
AS IT BEING FURTHER AWAY.
FROM THE BORE ON THESE TESTS
PROVIDE WE THINK THE SAME RESULT
AS A. B. SIX ONE SEVEN THAT WAS
IN FACT -- I CHECKED IN TWENTY
SEVENTEEN BY MEMBER CRISTINA
GARCIA AND OF COURSE A STATS
PROGRAM.
SO WHILE WE THINK THAT SOME OF
THE STUDY MAY BE DUPLICATIVE --
WERE FINE WITH TO STUDY BUT WITH
THOSE MINOR REQUEST OF THE
AUTHOR WE WHICH IS FAST -- AND
FROM THAT STANDPOINT.
WE STAND ON OPPOSED TO THE BILL
A VERY GOOD THANK YOU SO MUCH.
ANY IN OPPOSITION TO THE MEASURE.
SEEING NONE OF BRING IT BACK TO
THE DIETS QUESTION ALMOND --
THANK YOU THANK MEASURE HERE --
IMMENSE LOOKS SOUND -- THANK YOU
STAFF FOR DOING THE WORK ON THIS.
AS A NOTE.
YOU KNOW NOT JUST ABANDON OIL
WELLS WHICH WE'VE BEEN TALKING
ABOUT TODAY BUT ALSO.
WE'VE HAD SOME.
PROBLEMATIC WELLS IF YOU MAY
CALL THEM THAT ITALY SO CANYON
WITCHER RIGHT IN THE BACKYARD OF
MANY FOLKS OUT THERE. ONE TO GET
A SENSE FROM THE SPONSOR OR YOUR
YOUR LEAD WITNESS WHAT WE HAD IN
HERE.
RAISING OUR PRESENCE ALL THE WAY
FROM LOS ANGELES -- I I KNOW YOU
GUYS BEEN WORKING HIS FUGITIVE
EMISSIONS ISSUE FOR A VERY LONG
TIME.
YOU SEE THIS.
SECTOR YOU WANT TO CALL THAT AS
ANGELI SIGNIFICANT SOURCE OF
OVERALL FUGITIVE EMISSIONS IN
THE STATE THAT WE'RE NOT
TRACKING FROM.
HI BLINDS OTHERS SORT OF LEAKY
INFRASTRUCTURE.
COULD THIS BE.
NICOLE HE SAID THAT.
I THINK IT REALLY GOT IN THE
AGGREGATE.
METHANE EMISSIONS FROM OIL AND
GAS ARE THE LARGEST SOURCE OF OF
METHANE EMISSIONS A CALIFORNIA
AGRICULTURE IS.
WHAT WE HAVE HERE ARE EMISSIONS
THAT ARE -- CO LIMITED WITH
THINGS LIKE BENZENE AND OTHER
AIR TOXICS.
WE ALSO HAVE SOURCES OF
POLLUTION THAT ARE IN MANY
PEOPLE'S BACKYARDS IN SO THE
DATA SHOWS THAT THERE ARE SOME
WELLS THAT ARE LIKELY TO COMMIT
A LOT.
AND OTHER WELLS THAT ARE LIKELY
TO OMIT NONE OR LITTLE WE JUST
REALLY HAVE NO WAY OF
UNDERSTANDING WHAT SORT OF
ATTRIBUTES OF THESE WELLS
CONTRIBUTE TO THOSE.
LEAKAGE RATES AND SO WE ARE
UNABLE TO KNOW HOW LARGE OF A
PROBLEM IT IS WE DO KNOW IN
PLACES LIKE PENNSYLVANIA IT IS A
SIGNIFICANT PROBLEM -- BUT THERE
THEY DO HAVE A LOT OF GAS
PRODUCTION BY IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA FOR EXAMPLE OF WE
HAVE A LOT OF HEAVY OIL
PRODUCTION.
IN NORTHERN CALIFORNIA WE HAVE
MORE DRY GAS PRODUCTION.
IT DEPENDS ON WHERE YOU ARE AND
WHAT TYPE OF WELL YOU'RE LOOKING
AT AND I DO THINK THAT WHEN YOU
START TO LOOK AT THIS DATA AND
YOU START TO EVALUATE.
THE DIFFERENT TYPES OF WEATHER
OUT THERE YOU'LL SEE THAT
PROBABLY IN SOME WELLS IS
SIGNIFICANT ANOTHER WELL AS IT
IS LESS SO WE JUST HAVE NO WAY
OF KNOWING AT THIS.
MOMENT.
WE CAN'T MANAGE WE DON'T
UNDERSTAND HERE SO YET SENATOR.
MISTER CHAIR AND I I JUST
REALIZED THAT THAT I DIDN'T HEAR
A RESPONSE FROM THE AUTHOR IN
REGARDS TO THE ISSUES THAT WERE
RAISED BY SYFY -- ONE BY ONE
WITH THE COST OF THE STEADY BUT
THE OTHER ONE IS A STAKEHOLDERS
BEING ALLOWED TO SEE THE REPORT.
AND I WONDERED IF YOU HAD AN
ANSWER THAT.
I THINK.
I HAVE TO GO BACK AND BUT MOST
OF WHAT I THOUGHT I HEARD A SAID.
IS IN THE IS IN THE BILL -- SO.
HEY YOU KNOW WITHOUT GOING BACK
AND SERVE.
THE PLANE EVERYTHING THAT WAS
LAID OUT IN DETAIL BECAUSE QUITE
FRANKLY.
EVERYTHING WITH THERE WAS
DELINEATED.
THE BILL HAD BEEN READ BUT BEEN
ABLE TO SAY THAT'S IN HERE IT'S
NOT AND THEN WHATEVER WAS
DETERMINED BY THE OP THE BY THE
SPEAKER.
THAT NEW COULD.
OWN IN ON IT.
I THINK OF WHAT I HEARD.
MOST IF NOT ALL OF IT IS IN THE
BILL [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
AND WE'RE JUST LOOKING THROUGH
THE AUTHOR IS A MAN'S.
LOOK IN THE EYE TALLY.
I THINK IT'S ON PAGE. NINE AND
THEN AS THE BILL AND MEDIA MEN'S
BUT THE AUTHORS MEN'S.
SOME OF THE GRANULARITY IN TERMS
OF UNDERSTANDING WHAT THE
TESTING SCHEDULE AND HOW THAT.
AND IT -- THERE'S MORE
GRANULARITY ADDED THAT -- ALSO
CAP ON COSTS.
YES.
YES TO THE COST CAP IS THERE --
YEAH I DID YOU IF YOU HAVE ANY
ON THE BORDER ISSUE WERE SIX
SEVENTEEN LIKE WHAT WHAT WON'T
SIX SEVENTEEN ACCOMPLISH THAT
WE'RE GONNA GET DOWN HERE.
IS AB SB SIX ONE SEVEN IS DONE
ONLY FUNDAMENTALLY DIFFERENT
THAN THIS PARTICULAR BILL. SIX
ONE SEVEN REQUIRES THE
DEVELOPMENT OF OF COMMUNITY
PLANS TO IDENTIFY.
HOW COMMUNITIES MAY BE ABLE TO
REDUCE OUR SOURCES OF EMISSIONS
IN AGGREGATE IN THOSE
COMMUNITIES IT IS NOT?
MONITORING PLAN FOR IDENTIFYING
THE CONTRIBUTION OF INDIVIDUAL
SPECIFIC SOURCES TO LOCAL
CONDITIONS.
NEITHER DOES THE STAMPS PROGRAM
IDENTIFY THIS TYPE OF DATA IS
NOT PROGRAM IS ABOUT DEPLOYING
SOME MONITORS IN A LOCATION FOR
A FEW MONTHS AT A TIME.
NOT DOING A SCIENTIFIC BASE
STUDY ABOUT A CERTAIN TYPE OR
CHARACTERISTIC OF WELLS OR TYPES
OF POLLUTANTS THAT OCCUR ACROSS
THE STATE.
AND SO THIS PARTICULAR BILL IS
TARGETED SPECIFICALLY AT WHAT WE
KNOW IS A PROBLEMATIC SOURCE
THAT HAS BEEN UNDER STUDIED AND
UNDER MANAGED AND SO THE SIX ONE
SEVEN IN THE STATE'S PROGRAM.
SIMPLY DO NOT CARE [inaudible]
UNDERSTOOD.
WHEN YOU'RE TEN EMOTION BUT I DO
WANT TO ALLOW YOU TO CLOSE
[inaudible]
YOUR I I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR
AYE THANK YOU SO MEMBER.
ALL RIGHT MOTIONS CENTER
CABALLERO THE MOTION IS TO PASS
THE ENVIRONMENTAL QUALITY
COMMITTEE AND THE AMENDMENTS
THAT YOU ACCEPTED WILL BE TAKEN
THEIR OUT OF PROCEDURAL TIMING.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL -- STERN
HYPE STERN I'D JONES ALLEN
FORTUS CABALLERO. ZERO HI
HERTZBERG HUESO JACKSON MONEY
SOME COLLECTIVE OKAY VERY GOOD
AS SEVERAL WILL LEAVE THAT
MEASURE UNCLE.
THANKS SO MUCH THANKS FOR BEING
HERE [inaudible]
I KNOW.
SHE WAS SO PATIENT.
SERGEANT PLEAD WITH THE SEMINAR
CARILLO TO GIVE US ONE MORE TRY
HERE
.
CONSUMMATE PATIENT ASSEMBLY
MEMBER THANK YOU FOR WAITING IN
SORRY FOR ALL THE DELAYS BUT
WELCOME BACK.
NO LARA FILE ORDER YEAH IN WORK
AGAINST YOU BUT YOU'RE HERE NOW --
AND IT IS A. BE.
SIXTEEN SIXTY EIGHT GOOD
AFTERNOON THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PATIENCE GOOD AFTERNOON I HAD
GOOD MORNING IN MY NOTES. TO
EDIT.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE.
I AM PROUD TO PRESENT ASSEMBLY
BILL SIXTEEN SIXTY EIGHT A BILL
THAT ENJOYS BIPARTISAN SUPPORT
AND WOULD CREATE AN EDUCATION
AND EMPLOYMENT REENTRY PROGRAM.
TO BE OVERSEEN BY THE CALIFORNIA
CONSERVATION CORPS.
AND PROVIDE VALUABLE JOB
OPPORTUNITIES FOR FORMALLY
INCARCERATED INDIVIDUALS.
I WOULD LIKE TO BEGIN BY
THANKING THE COMMITTEE STAFF.
WORKING WITH MY OFFICE ON THIS
BILL I AM COMMITTED TO WORKING
ON THE COMMITTED SUGGESTED
AMENDMENTS AS OUTLINED IN THE
ANALYSIS.
AB SIXTEEN SIXTY EIGHT PROVIDE
TOLL WHEN OPPORTUNITY FOR
FORMERLY INCARCERATED
INDIVIDUALS.
BY OFFERING A TRUE PATH TO
LIVING WAGE JOBS THAT MOVE OUR
STATE FORWARD.
ON CRITICAL RESOURCE MANAGEMENT
OBJECTIVES.
FORMERLY INCARCERATED
INDIVIDUALS OFTEN FACE A RANGE
OF SINCERE CHALLENGES WHEN WE
INTEGRATING.
BACK INTO SOCIETY SUCH AS REDUCE
TIES TO THEIR FAMILIES AND
COMMUNITIES.
IN OFTENTIMES BARRIERS TO
HOUSING AND GAINFUL EMPLOYMENT.
POST RELEASE.
IN CALIFORNIA THOUSANDS OF
CURRENTLY INCARCERATED PEOPLE
SERVING PRISON FIRE CREWS.
AT WILDFIRE SCENES PROTECTING
THE LIVES OF COUNTLESS
pCALIFORNIANS WILL HAPPEN WELL
HELPING TO MANAGE MASSIVE
WILDFIRES WHICH HAVE BECOME THE
UNFORTUNATE NEW NORMAL OF OUR
STATE.
IN FACT ON JUNE THIRTY FIRST OF
LAST YEAR.
DURING THE CAR FIRE THE FERGUSON
FIRE AND THE MENDOCINO COMPLEX
FIRE.
THE DEPARTMENT OF CORRECTIONS
TWEETED AND I QUOTE.
TODAY MORE THAN.
TWO THOUSAND VOLUNTEER INMATE
FIREFIGHTERS INCLUDING FIFTY
EIGHT YOUTH OFFENDERS ARE
BATTLING WILDFIRES CLAIMS
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA.
INMATE FIREFIGHTERS SERVE A
VITAL ROLE CLEARING BRUSH DOWN
TO BARE SOIL TO STOP THE FIRE
SPREAD AND QUOTE.
THE REALITY IS THAT THE MEN AND
WOMEN WHO DO THIS WORK HAVE
RECEIVED THE TRAINING EXPERIENCE
AND SKILLS THAT HAVE REAL
EMPLOYMENT VALUE.
IN THE CRITICAL AREAS.
OF RESOURCE CONSERVATION AND
MANAGEMENT FUEL AND VEGETATION
CONTROL AND DISASTER SUPPORT.
AB SIXTEEN SIXTY EIGHT WILL
ENSURE THAT THE FOLLOWING THE
COMPLETION OF THEIR SENTENCE.
THESE INDIVIDUALS CAN UTILIZE
THE SKILLS THAT THEY HAVE
ATTAINED THROUGH THE ALREADY
EXISTING.
CONSERVATION CAMP PROGRAM
OPERATED BY THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF CORRECTIONS AND
REHABILITATION.
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
FORESTRY AND FIRE PROTECTION.
WE ARE IN NEED OF A SKILLED
WORKFORCE TO ENGAGE IN CRITICAL
AND COST EFFECTIVE COST
EFFECTIVE DEFENSE AGAINST
NATURAL DISASTERS. FOR THE
REPORTS SOME OF THE HIGHEST
RECIDIVISM RATES.
IN THE NATION THE LEGISLATURE
HAS A RESPONSIBILITY TO
CULTIVATE PROGRAMS THAT FOR TO
FORWARD THINKING MATH METHODS.
OF OVERCOMING BARRIERS OF
REINTEGRATION.
AB.
SIXTEEN SIXTY EIGHT IT'S A WIN
FOR CALIFORNIA IT IS A STEP
FORWARD IN INCREASING JOB
OPPORTUNITIES REDUCE RECIDIVISM.
AND HELP OUR STATE WITH ME HERE
TO TESTIFY IT'S ALSO THE VERY
PATIENT KRISTY BONA OF THE
CALIFORNIA PROFESSIONAL
FIREFIGHTERS ASSOCIATION.
THANKS SO MUCH WELCOME THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE CHRISTY VELMA BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA PROFESSIONAL
FIREFIGHTERS.
US SO HONORED TO BE PARTNERING
WITH ASSEMBLY WOMAN KERR CARILLO
ON THIS MEASURE.
THE FIRE SERVICE DOES RECOGNIZE
THAT THERE IS MORE WORK IN
RESOURCE AND VEGETATION
MANAGEMENT FEELS REDUCTION.
OF THEN WE HAVE THE WORK FORCE
TO DO IT.
THIS BILL BUILDS ON AND RELIES
UPON THE TRIPLE SEASON THEIR
EXPERTISE AND COLLABORATING
COORDINATING EDUCATIONAL
OPPORTUNITIES AND PROJECT
PARTNERSHIPS.
BUT WE DO APPRECIATE THE
CHAIRMAN AND IS A COMMITTEE
STAFF FOR HELPING US.
FIGURE OUT THE RIGHT PATH FOR
THIS BILL SO WE HAVE A PATH FOR
THE FORMERLY INCARCERATED -- WE
THINK THE CCC HAS THE
PARTNERSHIPS WE WOULD LIKE THEM
TO PARLAY THOSE RELATIONSHIPS
AND COLLABORATIONS.
WITH THE APPROPRIATE STATE AND
LOCAL AGENCIES THAT WORK.
FOR DEVELOPMENT AGENCIES TO
CREATE AN EDUCATIONAL
REEMPLOYMENT REENTRY PROGRAM.
FOR THIS POPULATION YOU KNOW
CALIFORNIA HAS ESTABLISHED VERY
AGGRESSIVE CLIMATE GOALS A
RESTORING FORCE TELLS REDUCING
GREENHOUSE GASES.
PROTECTING OUR WATERSHEDS AND
BATTLING THESE INTENSE WIRE FOR
WILD FIRES AND WE SEE A PATH
HERE.
IN A WORK FORCE TO TO ADDRESS
THOSE GOALS.
SO WE LOOK FOR TO CONTINUE TO
WORK WITH THE CHAIRMAN AS WE
MOVE OUT OF THIS COMMITTEE AT
YOUR GRANT TODAY. TO TO MOVE
THIS THIS POLICY FORWARD SO WE
CAN HAVE A GREAT PROGRAM.
FOR THESE INDIVIDUALS AND TO
SUPPORT THE WORK.
OF THE MY MEMBERS DO EVERYDAY.
THANK YOU SO MUCH THREE BROTHERS
IN SUPPORT.
AFTERNOON ASPEN IS WITH ANTI
RECIDIVISM COALITION STROKES.
THANKS SO MUCH.
OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
DENIED ANY IN OPPOSITION.
IN NINE OH BRING IT BACK TO THE
DíAS QUESTIONS COMMENTS.
IN A MOTION [inaudible] NINE
MOTIONS CENTER CABALLERO.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR EFFORTS HERE.
I THINK THERE.
ANTI RECIDIVISM COALITIONS HERE
TODAY.
TALKING EARLIER TRYING TO FIND
THE FIT.
ALL KINDS OF DIFFERENT FORMALLY
INCARCERATED.
FIND THEM A PATH.
IN THE CCC.
WHEN PROGRAMS ARE WORKING ON --
EVEN LOOKING AT PROGRAMS LIKE
CAL STATE LA WHERE YOU'VE GOT A
REALLY INTERESTING PARTNERSHIP
THERE WITH TRADES.
I THINK THEY'RE HUGE
POSSIBILITIES IN THIS IS A
LITTLE MODICUM OF THIS CLIMATE.
DISASTER THAT SPACE IN THE STATE.
ACTUALLY HAS SOME PEOPLE.
THE POWER THE THE RESPONSE
EFFORT THAT'S GONNA TAKE AND
TAKE.
MAN IN A LOT OF WOMAN POWERS
THANKS FOR BEING A WOMAN POWER
TODAY AND WE'RE SHOWN A PATH FOR
TO A LOT OF PEOPLE WHO NEEDS MY
HOPE IN THEIR LIFE -- SO THE
MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO PUBLIC
SAFETY COMMITTEE -- ALIGHTED
CLOSE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR A CAL
STATE LA IS ALSO AN ASSEMBLY
DISTRICT [inaudible]
FIFTY ONE PROUD ALUMNI.
BUT YOU'RE ABSOLUTELY CORRECT WE
HAVE A RESPONSIBILITY AT THE
STATE LEGISLATURE TO ENSURE THAT
HOUSE FOLKS HAVE PAID THEIR DEBT
TO SOCIETY.
AND WHILE CALIFORNIA HAS ALSO
INVESTED IN TRAINING AND THE
SKILL LEVEL THAT THEY HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO USE IT.
THE BECOME ACTIVE MEMBERS OF
SOCIETY SO I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST FOR ABOUT.
VERY GOOD THANK YOU SO MUCH.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
STERN AYE STERN HI JONES ALLEN
OR JUST A YEAR AGO.
I REQUEST SO JACKSON MONEY ZERO
ONLY THE MEASURE ON CALL THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR PATIENTS
[inaudible]
OKAY [inaudible]
OKAY SO [inaudible]
YEAH.
MEMBERS WE WE JUST THE WHO WILL
LIVE CALLS BUT I ALSO NEED IF
YOU COULD HELP US OUT WE NEED
SOME SOME MOTIONS WE HEARD A FEW
BILLS IS SUBCOMMITTEE EARLIER
TODAY -- THOSE WERE.
ITEM NUMBER FOUR AB FIVE FIVE
TWO AB EIGHT THIRTY NINE AND A.
B..
FOURTEEN FIFTEEN BY BE ONE
ENTERTAIN A MOTION ON AB.
FIVE FIVE TO ANYONE'S AMENABLE
[inaudible]
SO -- THIS WOULD CALL FOR OKAY
SO SORRY IN ORDER AND OKAY SO
THEY'RE GOING OR MY APOLOGIES
WE'LL COME BACK.
TO SO FAR THE NUMBER ONE AB
THIRTY EIGHT MOTIONS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO GEO.
THIS CALL MAY HAVE SOME.
A CURRENT VOTERS FORTY ONE
SENATORS ALAN OR JUST.
BURN HUESO [inaudible]
HUESO I CONTROL.
MEASURE BACK ON CALL A MEMBER TO
AB FORTY FOUR FRIEDMAN MOTIONS
TO PASS TO JUDICIARY COMMITTEE.
VOTERS THREE TO TWO CENTERS
ALLEN CABALLERO [inaudible]
HERTZBERG [inaudible]
HUESO.
OKAY BACK ON CALLER THREE WE
WILL LEAVE THE MEASURE ON CALL
AB.
FORTY FOUR ITEM NUMBER THREE AB
FOUR OH NINE LOW MOAN.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
TO THE AGRICULTURAL COMMITTEE.
VOTERS THREE ZERO SENATORS ALLEN
CABALLERO.
EVERY YEAR I HERTZBERG HUESO.
HUESO AYE JACKSON MONEY TO BACK
ON QUALIFYING MEASURE BACK ON
COAL -- OKAY.
BUT YOU GET SETTLED HERE WERE
JUST REAL QUICKLY.
LIMóN SO WE'RE READING ONE THE
ONLY THING CALLS YOU WOULD ONLY
NEED TO LIVE CALL FOR MONEY.
LAST.
ONE THE FIRST.
TWO OKAY SO WHAT WILL OPEN THE
ROOM ONE MORE TIME ON ITEM
NUMBER THREE A. B..
FOUR OH NINE THAT IS LIMóN OWN
DO PASSES MANAGE THE AG
COMMITTEE PLEASE CALL THE OF
SOME MEMBERS SENATORS ALAN.
BERG JACKSON OF MONEY.
MONNING EYES BACK ON COLLEGE
OKAY SO NOW WE'RE ON ITEM NUMBER --
FOUR ENTERTAIN A MOTION AT THIS
TIME AND AB.
FIVE FIVE TWO SO MOVED TO PASS
AS AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL SENATORS
STERN BY STERN AYE JONES.
JON SNOW ALLEN OR JUST.
CABALLERO CAREER AYE HERTZBERG
HUESO.
HUESO AYE JACKSON MONEY.
MONEY AYE WHO'S ON CALL FOR ONLY
THE MEASURE ON CALL ITEM NUMBER
FIVE WAS -- PULLED BY THE AUTHOR
WILL BE WORK ON THAT IS A TWO
YEAR MEASURE. FOR A BROADER
STRUCTURAL STICKS AROUND DAM
FEES.
I NUMBER SIX I WOULD ENTERTAIN A
MOTION THAT'S AB.
EIGHT THIRTY NINE THAT'S MORE.
MOTION CENTER HUESO THESE ALL
THE THE MOTION I'M SORRY DO PASS
AS AMENDED TO THE INSURANCE
COMMITTEE PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
I UNDERSTAND I EARN I'D JONES.
JONES NO ALLEN.
OR JUST.
BE HERO. ZERO I HERTZBERG HUESO.
HUESO AYE JACKSON MONEY.
MONEY I AND SOME CALLS.
ON CALL BELIEVE THAT MEASURE ON
I NEVER SEVEN EIGHTY NINE TWELVE
MAR TWO G. MOTIONS TO PASS TO
THE ENVIRONMENTAL QUALITY
COMMITTEE PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS.
THE CURRENT VOTERS THREE ZERO
SENATORS ALLEN CABALLERO.
I HERTZBERG HUESO.
HUESO AYE JACKSON MONEY.
MONEY HI.
YES NINETY NINE WELL -- LEAVE
THAT MEASURE ON CALL MS. SIX
WIVES AS EXPOSED TO AN ORDER
EIGHT AB NINE THIRTY SIX RIVAS
MOTIONS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
THE ENVIRONMENTAL QUALITY
COMMITTEE.
ALL THE APPS MEMBER VOTERS TO TO
ONE SENATORS ALAN.
THIS.
SPRING HUESO.
HUESO AYE JACKSON MONEY.
MONEY I AS A MEASURE ON CALL
THOSE FOUR VOTES I REMEMBER NINE
EIGHTY NINE SEVENTY FIVE THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
THE ENVIRONMENTAL QUALITY
COMMITTEE THESE ALL THE AS A
MEMBER THE CURRENT VOTERS TO
DESERVE CENTERS JONES.
JON SNOW ALAN OR JUST
[inaudible]
HUESO.
BUT SO I JACKSON MONEY.
MONEY HI AS FOR THE MEASURE ON
CALL I NUMBER TEN AB ELEVEN
ELEVEN FRIEDMAN MOTION IS TO
PASS AS AMENDED TO THE
GOVERNMENT GOVERNMENTAL
ORGANIZATION COMMITTEE -- YES
MEMBERS THE CURRENT VOTERS FOUR
ZERO CENTERS ALLEN PORGES.
HERTZBERG HUESO.
HUESO AYE JACKSON HAS BY VOTERS
GAVE FIVE VOTES WITH AN ON CALL
ITEM ELEVEN A. B. ELEVEN NINETY
ONE BONTA MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
THE CURRENT VOTERS FOUR ZERO
CENTERS JONES [inaudible]
IS YES.
JONES I ALLEN OR JUST
[inaudible]
HUESO.
HI SO I SIX IS BACK ON CALL OKAY
I WILL LEAVE THAT ON CALL SIX
VOTES ITEM TWELVE A. B. TWELVE
SIXTY MAIENSCHEIN MOTIONS TO
PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS THIS CALL
THE AS A MEMBER.
CURRENT VOTERS FOUR ZERO CENTERS
JONES.
GEN SNOW.
ABOARD JUST HERTZBERG HUESO.
HUESO I MONEY.
BONNIE IN AYE.
IT HAS.
ALL THE THE MEASURE BACK ON CALL
ITEM THIRTEEN AB THIRTEEN TWENTY
HOLDEN MOTIONS TO PASTOR BERMAN
AB.
FOURTEEN FIFTEEN AB FOR FOURTEEN
FIFTEEN THAT IS FRIEDMAN.
MOTIONS CENTER MONEY MOTION IS
TO PASS TO THE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE.
I UNDERSTAND FIVE AND I JONES
JONES NO ALLEN BUSHES.
OR JUST NO CABALLERO. ZERO NO
HERTZBERG HUESO [inaudible]
JACKSON MONEY.
MONNING I BILLS ON CALL WITH.
TO BELIEVE THAT MEASURE ON CALL
TO VOTE.
NEXT ITEM AB FIFTEEN SIXTEEN
FRIEDMAN.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO ENERGY
UTILITIES AND COMMUNICATIONS
COMMITTEE THIS CALL THE AS
MEMBERS THE CURRENT VOTERS THREE
ZERO SENATORS ALAN.
OR JUST. FIFTEEN SIXTEEN BARGES
NO [inaudible]
HUESO.
HUESO AYE JACKSON MINE
[inaudible]
MONEY I IT HAS FIVE FIVE WILL
KEEP AN ON CALL ITEM SIXTEEN A.
B. OH SORRY THAT.
I GUESS WHAT WILL OPEN THEIR ON
THE CONSENT CALENDAR NOW --
THAT'S AB SIXTEEN FORTY FOUR AND
A. B..
EIGHTEEN TWENTY THREE ALL YES
EMBERS CENTERS JONES.
TURNS AYE ALLEN CABALLERO.
I HERTZBERG HUESO.
HUESO AYE JACKSON MONEY.
MONEY I WILL PUT THAT BACK.
A VERY GOOD LEAVE IT ON CALL AND
LASTLY -- I ITEM.
SEVENTEEN AB SIXTEEN SIXTY
CARILLO THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
PUBLIC SAFETY COMMITTEE CURRENT
VOTERS TO DO ZERO SENATORS JONES.
JONES ALAN BURGESS.
OR JUST AYE HERTZBERG.
HUESO.
HUESO AYE JACKSON MONEY.
MONEY IN AYE WELCOME BACK ON
CALL THAT HAS A WILL PUT THAT
MEASURE BACK ON CALL
[inaudible]
YEAH.
HAVE YOU AS A KNOWN ABOUT.
JUST CHECK A CENTER MONNING ITEM
ONE AND WELL.
HAVE THEM AS AN EYE ON ONE HERE
IS AN EYE ON ITEM.
ONE THEY HAVE AN AS A AND I ON
AND I AM TWELVE YOU'RE COVERED.
AND I HAVE AN ON EVERYTHING.
I CHECKED WHEN WE MAKE SURE.
ON EIGHTEEN YES COUNTY SAN
[inaudible]
YEAH.
YEAH A LOT OF CALLS FOR YOU.
IT'S OKAY.
YES [inaudible]
THE MONITOR
CALLS ON THE
OUTSTANDING ITEMS -- SO WE'LL
START ITEM NUMBER ONE AB THIRTY
EIGHT WOULD DO PASS AS AMENDED
TO GEO.
THE CURRENT VOTERS FIVE TO ONE
SENATORS ALAN.
ALLEN I PORCHES.
OR JUST AYE HERTZBERG
[inaudible]
HERTZBERG HI.
SO THIS.
BILLS OUT -- YEAH I REMEMBER TO
AB FORTY FOUR FRIEDMAN THE
MOTION IS TO PASS TO JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE.
CURRENT VOTERS THREE DID TO
SENATORS ALLEN.
ALLEN AYE.
COME GYRO.
HERTZBERG HERTZBERG AYE HUESO.
OF THE BILLS OUT WITH OKAY I
HAVE THE BILL IS OUT.
BELIEVE THAT ON CALL.
YEAH REALLY THEY DON'T CALL.
RIGHT WE'LL JUST WAIT TO SEE IF
HUESO COMES BACK.
I'M SORRY.
THAT'S RIGHT ITEM NUMBER --
THREE Là MON AB.
FOUR OH NINE MOTIONS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO THE AGRICULTURAL
COMMITTEE.
PLEASE HOLD ABSENT MEMBERS
CURRENT VOTERS SIX ZERO CENTERS
ALLEN.
ALLEN AYE HERTZBERG.
AYE JACKSON [inaudible]
YES.
JACKSON HI BILLS OUT DESERVES
OUT -- ENTER FOR EIGHTY FIVE
FIVE TWO STONE DO PASS AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS PLEASE
CALL THE AS A MEMBER.
VOTERS FOUR TO ONE SENATORS
ALLEN ALLEN AYE BARGES.
BARGES SNOW HERTZBERG HERTZBERG
AYE JACKSON.
JACKSON I'D THAT BILLS OUT BILLS
OUT I MEAN ITEM NUMBER FIVE WAS
PULLED BY THE AUTHOR TO WORK ON
AS A TO YOUR BILL WITH THE
COMMITTEE ITEM NUMBER.
SIX IS AB EIGHT THIRTY NINE
MULLIN THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO THE INSURANCE
COMMITTEE AB EIGHT THIRTY NINE
MULLIN.
VOTERS FOUR TO ONE CENTERS ALLEN.
ALLEN AYE BARGES [inaudible]
HERTZBERG.
FILE IN SIX AB.
EIGHT THIRTY NINE I JACKSON
JACKSON HI.
THE BILLS OUT OF BILLS OUT.
SEVEN SEVEN SEVEN ON SEVEN ONE I
DIDN'T. SEVEN EIGHTY NINE TWELVE
MAR TWO G. MOTION IS TO PASS IN
THE ENVIRONMENTAL QUALITYCOMMITTEE.
VOTED SIX TO ZERO SENATORS ALAN.
ALLEN AYE HERTZBERG.
AYE JACKSON JACKSON I WAS OUT.
OUT.
I DON'T EIGHT EIGHTY NINE THIRTY
SIX RIVAS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
THE ENVIRONMENTAL QUALITY
COMMITTEE.
VOTERS FOUR TO ONE CENTERS ALLEN.
ALLEN AYE FORGES.
HERTZBERG HERTZBERG AYE JACKSON.
JACKSON I BILLS OUT OF BILLS OUT.
AB NINE SEVENTY FIVE CALDERON DO
PASS AS AMENDED TO THE
ENVIRONMENTAL QUALITY COMMITTEE.
PHONE IS FOUR ZERO CENTERS ALAN.
ALLEN HI BRIDGES [inaudible]
HERTZBERG.
HERTZBERG AYE JACKSON JACKSON
HIGH.
THE BILL IS OUT.
I AM TEN A. B. ELEVEN ELEVEN
FRIEDMAN DO PASS AS AMENDED OF
THE GOVERNMENTAL ORGANIZATION
COMMITTEE CURRENT VOTERS FIVE
ZERO SENATORS ALAN.
ALLEN I BOARD JUST.
OR JUST AYE HERTZBERG HERTZBERG
AYE JACKSON.
JACKSON I WAS OUT NINE ZERO IT
WAS A NINE ZERO ITEM ELEVEN
BONTA AB ELEVEN NINETY ONE TO
PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS.
CURRENT VOTERS SIXTY ZERO
SENATORS ALAN.
ALLEN I BURGESS BURGESS I
RESPECT.
I BILLS OUT.
NINE ZERO OKAY A BILLS AT NINE
ZERO ITEM.
TWELVE AB TWELVE SIXTY
MAIENSCHEIN DO PASSED TO
APPROPRIATIONS VOTED SIX TO ZERO
SENATORS.
BURGESS.
OR JUST NO HERTZBERG.
I BILLS OUT.
SEVEN TO TWO AB.
TWO AB TWELVE SIXTY MAIENSCHEIN.
WITH US WHEN WE JUST I'M SORRY.
THOUSAND TWO OUT OKAY GOOD.
ITEM THIRTEEN AB THIRTEEN TWENTY
EIGHT HOLDEN MOTIONS TO PASS THE
ENVIRONMENTAL QUALITY COMMITTEE.
VOTERS FOUR ZERO CENTERS ALLEN.
ALLEN AYE BARGES [inaudible]
HERTZBERG.
THIS IS A. B. THIRTEEN TWENTY
EIGHT HOLDEN.
NO WOMEN A LITTLE CAN I THINK
THE NEXT ALREADY TAKE THEM IN
THE NEXT COMMITTEE.
YES.
HI JACKSON JACKSON I BILLS OUT
BILLS OUT.
NEXT AB FOURTEEN FIFTEEN
FRIEDMAN TO PASS THE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE.
VOTE IS.
TWO TO THREE SENATORS ALLEN.
ALLEN AYE.
HERTZBERG.
AYE.
JACKSON.
JACKSON HI.
OKAY THAT'S OKAY THAT BILLS OUT --
OKAY.
AN FIFTEEN A. B. FIFTEEN SIXTEEN
FRIEDMAN.
YOU PASS THE ENERGY TO LOSING
COMMUNICATIONS COMMITTEE VOTERS
FIVE ZERO CENTERS ALLEN.
ALLEN AYE HERTZBERG.
AYE JACKSON.
JACKSON HI NOTED -- THAT WAS ON
FIFTEEN SIXTEEN AUTHORS OUT OF
THERE. EIGHT TWO ONE THAT THAT
MEASURES OUT OF THE CONSENT
CALENDAR WHICH IS AB SIXTEEN
FORTY FOUR AND AB EIGHTEEN
TWENTY THREE CENTERS ALLEN.
ALLEN AYE HERTZBERG THERE'S A
GUY JACKSON JACKSON I WAS OUT
OKAY.
I MEASURES OUT LASTLY ON THE
AGENDA AB SIXTEEN SIXTY EIGHT TO
PASS PUBLIC SAFETY.
VOTERS SIXTY ZERO CENTERS ALLEN.
ALLEN AYE HERTZBERG.
AYE JACKSON.
SORRY THAT IS AB SIXTEEN SIXTY
EIGHT CARILLO [inaudible]
CONSERVATION CORPS.
NO AMENDMENTS TAKEN A COMMITMENT
FROM THE AUTHOR TO KEEP WORKING.
OKAY JACKSON I HAVE RESULT NINE
DESERVE BILLS AND NINE ZERO AND
WE WILL CLOSE THE ROLE ON ITEM
TO THAT BILL IS ALSO OUT AND WE
STAND ADJOURNED